hey this is andrew brown your cloud
instructor at exam pro and i'm bringing
you another complete study course and
this time it's the azure data
fundamentals certification made
available to you on free code camp
so this course is designed to help you
pass the exam and achieve microsoft
issued certification
and the way we're going to do that is by
going through lots of lecture content
getting some hands-on experience with
follow alongs
and on the daily exam i have these
really great cheat sheets that are going
to help you
pass for sure so the great thing is at
the end of it you'll be able to get that
certification and
show that on your resume or linkedin
that you have the azure knowledge so you
can go get that
data job or that promotion you've been
looking for just to
introduce myself i'm previously the ct
of multiple edtech companies 15 years
experience
with five years specializing in the
cloud i'm an aws community hero
and i've published many many free cloud
certification courses and i love star
trek and coconut water
i just want to take a moment here to
tell you that this video cloud
certification course is made possible by
viewers like you
and i appreciate your support and thank
you if you want to
help support more free cloud courses
just like this one
the best ways to buy your extra study
materials at exam pro dot co
forward slash dp hyphen 900 to get study
notes flash cards quizlets
deliverable cheat sheets practice exams
you can ask questions and get some
support from our cloud engineers
and just so you know if you want to keep
up to date with upcoming courses you can
follow me on twitter at
andrew brown that's uh and what you can
do is once you do that you can tell me
you passed the exam
you can tell me what you'd like to see
next because a lot of times the next
course i make is based on the feedback i
get from you so
let's jump into the course now
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are at the start of our journey
asking the most important question first
which is what is the dp900 so the azure
data fundamental certification
is for those seeking a data related role
such as data analysts
data engineer or data scientists and the
certification will demonstrate a person
can define and understand
coordinated concepts hadoop workloads
apache spark workloads mssql databases
nosql databases data lakes data
warehouses elts and big data
analytics and more the certification is
generally referred to by its course
code the dp900 and it's the natural path
for the
azure data engineer or the azure data
analyst
certifications this is an easy course to
pass and great for those new to cloud
or data related technology so let's look
at our big old road map here
and what i'm going to do is pull out my
laser pointer so you can see where i
am and we'll get some lines in here
because i want to show you
some of the paths you can take with the
certification so we're over here with
the dp900 and this is at the
fundamentals
level right and so a lot of times what
people will do is they will
have the az-900 they'll take that first
if they're 100 new to cloud so i see a
lot of people they start here
and if you're if you've never used azure
before it's a great starting point
and then they'll move on to the dp900 or
sometimes what they'll do is they'll
move on to the ai-900
and then onto the db dp900 or they'll
take the dp900 and then the ai
fundamentals
but the reason you want to take this
data fundamentals certification
is primarily because you you're very
likely want to take the data engineer
certification
or the data analyst certification which
is at the associate track so this one
it's basically uh the dp900 but actually
knowing how to implement everything and
then the data analyst is really focused
on power bi so just knowing how to use
uh power bi uh to uh to its maximum
extent okay
now a lot of people that are going for
the data scientists or ai engineer track
will take the dp900 because you do need
foundational knowledge
about data to understand these roles
and so you know it's just if you are
going for the data scientist you
probably want to add the dp900 to your
track
but if you've taken the az-900 and the
az-104
you might want to skip over this it's
just up to you um but yeah there's a lot
of ways that you can go
about this okay and we'll just move on
uh here so
how long to study to pass the dp900 so
if you have one year experience with
azure
you're looking at five hours of study if
you've passed the az900 you're looking
at 10 hours
if you're new to cloud you're looking at
15 hours of study for
new people i'm saying 30 minutes a day
for 14 days
the course content itself is not very
long but the thing is you have to factor
in that you have to do
um you have to do practice exams and you
also
just have to put that knowledge into
practice by using the console so
even though you know the course
content's not long there's additional
time you have to
do there where would you take this exam
well you can do it in an in-person test
center
or online from the convenience of your
own home so there are two options you
got psi and pearson vue
and uh they both actually do in person
and online
and so just so you know if you ever
heard the term proctor a lot of times we
talk about online exams being proctored
exams because there's a person or
supervisor that's watching you
take the exam online okay so what does
it take to pass this exam well you got
to watch the lecture videos
you got to do hands-ons and follow
alongs and it helps to do
paid practice exams that simulate the
real exam this is pretty easy
certification so you could probably get
away with um
[Music]
okay so what i did was i just googled
dp900 exam guide and so i made it to the
microsoft site if you scroll on down
you're looking for that skills measure
download that pdf open it up it will be
over here now it's very common to see
this red text here
azure loves to update their exams even
once a month they'll do this to me
and people ask me are your exams out to
date i'm like no they're just making
my new changes if they do make major
changes what they'll do is actually
release a new version
they'll call it the dp901 that's when
you should be concerned about
changes uh but yeah they do it
frequently so what you'll do is if you
get if you see red text
you've got to scroll down to the real
section because it's the old one and
this is the new one where they make
minor changes okay
and what we'll do is work our way down
here and and take a look here so
describe core data concepts
so batch and streaming relational data
we have data linux concepts so
visualizations bi types of bar like
types of charts they're talking
specifically about power bi
because there's a lot of different kinds
of visualizations describe analytic
techniques so descriptive diagnostic
predictive prescription cognitive most
places don't describe cognitive so they
add that additional one there
elt and etl so um
uh extract elt is more common for clouds
that's the one you really want to
understand
describe concepts of data processing
onto how to work with relational data so
describe what a relational workload is
describe the structures within
a database if you've ever worked with
any kind of database you already know
them tables indexes views columns etc
we have described relational data
services so they do p-a-s-i-a-s
and s-a-s they're specifically talking
about
in that comparison you'll see that like
in the az 900
those three although i think they might
have removed them as of recent but
um they're specifically talking about
the azure sql family so down below here
you have azure sql and underneath it has
a bunch of
variants so like sql database sql manage
instance and virtual machines and these
sit
in the pas and iis and you have to know
that okay
describe azure synapse analytics
describe database for postgres maria
bicycle that's the open source sql
databases
uh so then we have relational data so uh
provisioning deployment of relational
data
deployment with the portal azure
resource templates powershell cli
you know what i don't ever see these on
the exam you know
but um you know they they have this in
here okay
identify security components now they
say firewall they're actually talking
about when you have a database
because there's actually azure firewall
but then there's
um a a server firewall built into azure
sql and that's what they're talking
about their authentication like how to
connect
because there's a few different ways you
can do that connectivity from on-prem to
azure vnets etc
identity query tools so azure data
studio sql studio management
sql sql cmd utilities and things like
that describe query techniques for using
uh sql so compare ddls with dmls
there's actually a lot more types of
data language files for sql so we do
them all just because it's
you know it's the proper way to do it
but they only care about these two
query relational data in sql database uh
azure disk postgres azure database for
mysql we'll go on down to this section
here non-relational data workloads
so describe the non-relational data
describe non-relational and nosql data
recommend
correct data stored determine when to
use non-relational data
and they're all talking about um because
like non-relational data is mostly
cosmodb
cosmodb like has a bunch of different
sql engines there so that's going to
help you
understand that like graph and document
key value store things like that
describe non-relational data so we have
table blob files cosmodb
identify basic management tasks for
non-relational data so provisioning
deployment of non-relational data
services describe
method of deployment in uh azure portal
etc etc
again i don't see these a lot on the
exam so i don't know why this is in here
identify data security components so
it's the same thing as before it's just
for non-relational data
basic connectivity issues v-nets et
cetera identify management tools for
non-relational data
describe analytical workloads so
transactional data the difference
between transactional analytical
and we're talking about olap and oltp
okay difference between batch and
real-time uh warehouses
data warehouse solutions describe modern
data warehouses so here we're talking
about data breaks
hadoop systems synapses kind of like a
data lake house
and then actually azure data lake and
it's storage medium
down below we have data ingestion so
loading data
azure data factory um hdinsights
databricks
etc and then down with below we have a
whole section on power bi
what i'm surprised is they don't have
much like on azure um
streaming analytics and event hub
because a lot of these have to consume
from there
so that's something i think that should
be on the example they don't have it in
here
but yeah it's uh it's not a super hard
exam it's mostly just describe describe
identify see
so you're all going to be in great shape
and i hope that helps you out and we're
on to the actual course now
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a quick look at all
the core data related azure services
that we are likely to encounter through
this course so let's get to it
the first starting with azure storage
accounts and this is an umbrella service
for various storage types such as tables
files and blobs
we have azure blob storage and this is a
data store
that stores things as objects instead of
files and the advantage here is that you
get distributed storage these objects
can span
multiple machines for unstructured data
you have azure tables which is a key
value no
sql data store more like a database but
it's under azure storage accounts and
it's intended for its simpler projects
you have azure files and this is a
managed file share for nfs or smb so if
you need a file share or file system
that you need to mount to multiple
virtual machines or workstation
this is what you would use you have
azure storage explorer this is a
standalone application you download to
your windows linux or mac machine
that easily allows you to explore the
various services above
then you have azure synapse analytics
this
is a data warehouse and unified
analytics platform the service used to
be called
something like azure warehouse but they
added analytics on top of it kind of
making it into a lake house
service and so that's what it is now we
have cosmodb
this is a fully managed nosql database
service that can host various nosql
engines
such as azure tables documents key value
and graph
when you use cosmodb it's going to have
a core mode
and that pretty much is its documents
engine so a lot of times when we talk
about cosmodb we just think of it as a
documents documents database but it can
actually have a variety
underneath you have azure data lake
store generation two
we won't talk about gen 1 because it's
just not really in use anymore
but this is a centralized data
repository for big data blob storage
designed for vast amounts of data
it actually is just azure blob storage
with an additional layer of management
you have azure data analytics this is a
big data as a service
you can write you sql to return data
from your azure data lake
then you have azure data box which isn't
really covered in the exam but
i'm including here because i think it's
a great addition so you can import and
export terabytes of data
via hard drive you mail into the azure
data center
onto our next page here we have sql
server for azure virtual machines this
is when you need an sql server
where you're migrating an existing sql
from your on-premise
data center onto azure but you can't
afford to make any changes so you're
literally taking the vm
and lifting and then shifting it onto
azure but you get to
have access to the virtual machine
underneath so you can control the os
access
layer and also if you already have an
existing license it's a great solution
for that as well
if you are doing a lift and shift but
you don't need to manage the virtual
machine and you want azure to
do all the work for you you have sql
managed instances then you have azure
sql which is the fully managed
mssql database then you have azure
databases for
mario db postgres and mysql you have
azure cache for redis
now this is an in-memory data store for
returning data extremely fast but is
also extremely volatile
and this isn't covered on the exam but i
like to include it because i think it's
just
one of the data services that's
important you have microsoft office 365
sharepoint
not really covered on the exam but you
will hear it mentioned throughout
the course content and you know i think
that if you haven't had exposure to you
should know what it is
it is a shared file system for
organizations the company owns all the
files
and applies fine-grained role-based
access controls you have azure data
bricks this is a third-party provider
partnered with azure specializing
in apache spark to provide very fast etl
jobs
as well as ml and streaming you have
microsoft power bi
this is a business intelligence tool
used to create dashboards and
interactive reports to empower
business decisions we have hdinsights
this is a fully managed hadoop system
that can run many open source big data
engines for doing data transformations
for
streaming etl elt
we have azure data studio this is an ide
that looks
very much like visual studio code but
designed around data related tasks
across platforms similar to sss ssis
but broader data workloads you have
azure data factory a managed
etl elt pipeline builder easily build
transformation pipelines via a web
interface within azure
and then you have sql server integration
services
ssis it's a standalone windows app to
prepare data for sql workloads via
transformation pipelines
there's probably a bunch of other little
services or tools that we don't have in
this list but don't worry
we'll cover them throughout the course
just remember these ones that we went
over here today
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look at the types of
cloud computing for azure data related
services starting at the top of our
pyramid is software as a service
and it's a product that is run and
managed by a service provider so you do
not worry about how the service is
maintained it just works and remains
available and this is specifically
designed for
customers so it's not particularly azure
services
but it'll be like microsoft based
services like power bi or the office 365
suite
is going to be software as a service
going down to platform as a service
this focuses on deployment and
management of your apps so you do not
worry about provisioning and configuring
or understanding the hardware or os
layer and this is specifically for
developers so we would put
hdinsights azuresql cosmodb
managed sql all right and at the bottom
we have infrastructure as a service
these are the basic building blocks for
cloud i t it provides access to
networking features computers and data
storage space
you do not worry about the it staff data
centers and hardware and underneath here
we would have this would be for admins
but we'd have azure disks virtual
machines sql vms
and honestly uh you know like when you
look at aws and azure
these kind of categories are defined a
little bit differently so
you know like manage sql i would
probably put that infrastructure as a
service but
azure says that it goes into the mid
tier i really want to pull up a
particular document here that i think is
important
because this is all about the azure sql
family and they're specifically
categorizing these
in particular so you go down below here
and when we're looking
i have them on here but when you look
here i have sql vm down below
so that would be considered
infrastructure as a service you have
managed sql where they put in the middle
but they
categorize it as platform as a service
and then you have it's covered up here
we have azure sql database which is
platform as a service
i'm showing you this because they might
ask you this question on the exam
uh and so i just wanted to point that
out to you there but there you go
[Music]
okay so let's take a quick look at three
azure data roles that
azure wants you to know about
specifically related to data services
when i say roles here i don't mean like
azure permissions i actually mean like
jobs that people would do within azure
and let's just take a look at it here so
the first one is database administrator
this is somebody that would configure
and maintain a database
such as azure data services or sql
servers and they would be responsible
for database management
management security or granting users
access backups
monitoring performance and common tools
that they would use would be azure data
studio
sql management studio azure portal
the cli the next role would be data
engineer and that would be to design and
implement data tasks related to the
transfer and storage of big data
responsibilities here would be database
pipelines in process
data ingestion storage prepare data for
analytics
prepare data for analytics processing
and common tools that they would use
would be azure synapses studio
sql azure cli and the last role here we
have is data analyst so this is analyzes
business data to reveal important
information
so you have provide insights into data
visual reporting
modeling data for analysis combines data
for visualization
analysis common tools here are power bi
desktop
power bi portal power bi service and
power bi
report builder so i just want you to
know that there's definitely a lot more
roles than just these three here but
this kind of helps you narrow down what
this entire dp900 is focused on which
are these three
kind of rules here but what we'll do is
we'll jump into these common tools and
just talk about them a little bit more
in detail
uh next here okay
[Music]
okay so we're taking a look here at
database administrator common tools the
first being azure data studios this
allows you to connect to azure sql
data warehouses post postgres sql sql
servers big data cluster on premise
i say azure sql data warehouse it must
be azure synapsis
analytics i probably just wrote that
incorrectly there but various libraries
and extensions along with automation
tools
a graphical interface for managing
on-premise and cloud-based data services
runs on windows max and linux possible
replacement for ssms but still lacks
some of those features if you launch a
service it looks a lot like visual
studio code because it probably is
but it's specifically for data related
tasks so if you're used to visual studio
code you're going to be
at home with the service you have sql
server management studio ssms
and it's an automation tooling for
running sql commands or common database
operations it has a graphical interface
for managing on-premise and cloud-based
data services but it only runs on
windows so if you're on
mac or linux you're going to be using
azure data studio
and if you're on windows you might just
have both of these installed because
there's just some things you can do
in ssms that are just a lot easier than
azure data studio
but it's more mature than azure data
studio so um you know it's just going to
be
the features are going to be a lot more
richer in partic in particular for
sql you have azure portal and cli so
here you can manage sql database
configurations you can create delete
resize
the number of cores uh you can manage
and provision
other data as your data services
automate the creating updating or
modifying resources via the azure
resource manager templates which is
infrastructure as code so those are the
three
major ones that a database administrator
is going to be working with
[Music]
now let's take a look at data
engineering common tools so at the top
where we have azure synapses studio
so you know azure synapses analytics
when you click into it there you launch
a studio and this allows you to manage
things like
your data factories your warehouses
sql pools spark pools things like that
you're gonna have to know
really really no sql there's tsql usql
synapsis sql there's all sorts of sqls
within azure so it's definitely
something you want to learn
for the azure cli you'll have to be able
to use it to
then execute sql commands because once
you connect to
an sql server via the cli you're just
going to be writing sql from there
i added these they weren't in the common
tools list prior but i just added them
now because i thought they were useful
so hd insights
which we'd have for streaming data via
apache kafka or apache spark or applying
etl jobs via hive pig and apache spark
as your data bricks also because here
you could be creating an apache spark
cluster and using that to do etls or
streaming jobs to your data warehouses
your data lakes
and of course you'd be working with blob
storage and data likes as well so they
should be on the list here
but just there you go
all right taking a look here at data
analysts for common tools we have power
bi desktop this is a standalone
application for data visualization you
can do data modeling here
connect to many data sources and create
interactive reports
then you have power bi portal or also
known as the power bi service and really
this is just intended for creating
interactive dashboards you can
definitely do other things here but
this is what i know it for then you have
power bi builder report
or report builder this is another
standalone application and this allows
you to create paginated reports which
are just printable reports
definitely there are more tools than
just these three for
uh data analysts but this is what azure
wants you to know
so there you go
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the data
overview so the idea here is that we're
going to be covering a lot of
fundamental
not necessarily as your specific data
related knowledge that you need to know
to really understand how to use azure
data related services
uh so i'll just give you a quick
overview here and then we'll dive deeper
into all these things so the first thing
is data so that's units of information
you have data documents these are types
of abstract groupings of data
you have data sets these are
unstructured logical grouping of data
when you structure your data now it's
called structured data
and then you have data types these are
single units of data that are intended
to be used
in a particular way then you have a
bunch of loose concepts so you have
batch and streaming so this is how do we
move our data around we have relational
non-relational
databases or data so how do we access
query and search our data
you have data modeling how do we prepare
and design our data schema versus
schemas how do we structure our data for
search
data integrity and data corruption how
do we trust our data
normalization and denormalization how do
we trade
quality versus speed and i'm sure we
cover a lot more than just this list i
just didn't feel like
being exhausted here and put every
little thing here so many things that
have the word data in it but let's jump
into it
[Music]
so the first question we should be
asking ourselves is what is
data so data is units of information
that could be in the form of numbers
text machine code images videos audio
or even in a physical form like
handwriting
maybe if you're in the future it's
crystals i don't know and so just some
images here or examples of graphics so
here we have an image
here is a bunch of binary code or
machine code
we have a book here we have
like audio so we have like audio
spectrum here
uh and then you have mathematical
formulas so i'm sure at this point you
know what uh data is but
just in case uh you know you need to
just broaden your your thoughts of what
data is it really
could be everything including physical
stuff
so what is a data document a data
document defines the collective form in
which
data exists so common types of data
documents
would be data sets which is a logical
grouping of data databases which is
structured data that can be quickly
accessed and searched
data stores this is unstructured or
semi-structured data
for housing data data warehouses
structured or
semi-structured data for creating
reports and analytics
notebooks data that is arranged in pages
and designed for easy consumption so
just to give you some examples if we're
looking at data sets
we might talk about the mnist data set
for azure sql that would be a database
for a data store such as a data lake we
have azure data lake
for a data warehouse we have azure
synapsis
analytics and for notebooks we might
talk about jupyter notebooks but this
could also include
you know an actual handwritten notebook
so there you go
[Music]
all right so what is a data set well a
data set is a logical grouping of units
of data that are generally closely
related or share the same
data structure and so i say data
structure there but i just want you to
know that just because something has a
data structure doesn't mean it's
structured data
it can be semi-structured like json
objects or xml files
but generally data sets are unstructured
or structured
they are publicly there are publicly
available data sets that are used for
learning statistics data analytics and
machine learning
the most popular one being the msns
database i can't tell you how many times
i've seen this data set
but it's images of handwritten digits
used to test classification
clustering and image processing
algorithms commonly used
when learning how to build computer
vision ml models to translate
handwritten text into digital text and
here's an example of that data set there
another very popular data set is the
commons
objects in context the coco data set i
believe microsoft had a hand in this one
and it's a data set which contains many
common images in a json file a coco
format
that identify objects or segments within
an image so there again it has json
files
that means that it's semi-structured not
necessarily structured data
here is an example of the data set you
can see that there are images and they
have borders drawn around things they're
trying to identify in the images
such as objects in segmentation
recognizing context super pixel stuff
segmentation no idea what that means
329 000 images and it has a lot of
labels
and a bunch of other things in this data
set
another interesting one would be the
imdb review data set
where it has 25 000 highly polar movie
reviews meaning people really like the
movie or they really dislike them
i pulled out an example here of pluto
nash which at the time
was highly uh liked and disliked there
was a huge split between this movie
mostly i think people disliked it but
apparently it's kind of split
this is great for customer seg sentiment
analysis again you'd probably be using
ml for this
but the idea is to say did people like
the movies like or did they like it
hate it uh we're sad about it that's
kind of like customer sentiment
right how do they feel some other data
sets we have the free music archive this
is a data set of musical
music tracks so you have a hundred
thousand
tracks across 163 genres you have the
uh li i guess this is library but lib
re speech a data set of a thousand hours
of english speech you think they use an
english word to describe that but no
there are many more data sets online
some are paid
some you have to extract via an apis uh
some you have to scrape the data
yourself
um but just taking a big look here of
the full list we got crunchbase
glassdoor
fbi google trends data hub
world health organization it's across
the board right so
you know there's a lot of things that
you can get data online a lot of times
you are just creating your own data sets
but
it's good to know that there's a lot of
stuff out there
[Music]
so what is a data type it's a single
unit of data that tells the compiler or
interpreter so a computer program
how data is intended to be used and the
variety
of data types will greatly vary based on
the computer program
a better way of thinking of it instead
of saying computer program just say
programming language because that's
where you're going to be encountering
data types
so let's take a look at the most common
data types the first being numeric data
types
these are data types involving
mathematical numbers the most common
being
integer which is a whole number could be
negative or positive
a lot of programming languages will have
a variety of these that have different
ranges
like int 32 into 64 what have you
then you have floats or sometimes also
known as decimals this is a number that
has a decimal so 1.5 0.0 can be a
negative number as well
here it is example of an end and a float
in python
we'll take a look at text data types
this is a data type that contains
a readable or non-readable letters so
there are characters so characters is a
single letter
so it could be a to z it could be a
digit it could be
a blank space punctuation special
characters
then you have a string and a string is a
sequence of characters that can
be word sentences or paragraphs they
don't necessarily have to be words but
you know that's usually what you're
using them for so here's an example of a
character
and a string then you have composite
data types and these contain
cells of data that can be accessed via
an index uh or
a key so for example we have an array so
that is a group of elements that
contains the same data type
that can be accessed via the index and
position you have a hash
commonly known as the dictionary and if
you're using python you're probably
known as the dictionary i know it's a
hash because i like ruby so that's how i
know it
and it's a group of elements where a key
can be used to retrieve
a a value and the thing is is that
composites are
they overlap with data structures so
when we talk about data structures
you might say hey is an array and hash a
data structure yes it is
but yes it's also data type it just
depends on the programming language and
the constraints around those okay so
i know those get a little bit confusing
i just wanted to point that out but
here's an example of
again this is um python so we have an
array
and down below we have a python
dictionary and if you use
json or javascript yes uh you know a
json object basically is a hash
we got one more here so we have binary
data types this these are represented by
a series of bits
uh or bytes which either are zero or one
so
off and on so here's an example in
python how to set up a byte
um for billion values if we have true or
false
some languages represent billions as a
zero or
one so a lot of times when you're using
like mysql true and false i think it's
zero and one in there
sometimes it's a t or an f when you're
using um
a post sql it's going to be a t or an f
uh and sometimes it's
just true or false so in python it's
just capital t true
and actually i think they have a
lowercase tree which is a different kind
of object it's a bit confusing but i'm
just saying there's some variance there
then you have enumeration data types or
sometimes known as enums and these are a
group of constants unchangeable
variables
so for example diamond spade hearts and
clubs they're all related because it's
card
groups um so the idea here is the data
type
uh you know it could be also a data
structure again it varies on the
language just like composite types
but here on the right hand side we have
a shake and it's
wrapped in a class and below this again
this is python this is how you do in
python
and so the shake could be vanilla
chocolate cookies and mint a lot of
times the nums will map
to an integer value or something so but
not always the case
um but yeah that's uh that type there
and there you go that's the common data
types
[Music]
okay so let's take a look at schema
versus schema list so what is a schema
a schema in terms of a database is a
formal language which describes the
structure of data a blueprint
of a database and a schema can be can
define many different data structures
that serve different purposes of a
database so
different data structures in a
relational database could be things like
tables fields relationships views
indexes packages procedures functions
mxl schemas
cues triggers types sequences
materialized views
cinnamons cinnamons synonyms can't say
that word
database links and directories gonna
highly vary based on the database that
you're using
and i'm just going to show you an
example of a schema so here
is actually part of my schema for the
exam pro app
and so this is a ruby on rail schema
that defines the structure
for a relational database and it's
written in a dsl
called ruby but the thing is is that
this is going to highly vary uh based on
again what you're using but just notice
that you can see things like creating a
table creating indexes
creating columns for the database things
like that
adding extensions uh schema-less uh
is just kind of it's still a schema but
the idea here is the primary cell of a
database can accept many types
so just going back here for a moment
notice here that we have very particular
notice here that we have very particular
data types like integer string and stuff
like that
the idea here is with schema list that
that data type is a lot more flexible
and the idea there is it allows you to
forego
the upfront data modeling that you
normally would have to do which is a lot
of work
and so that's one of the advantages of
schema lists common stimulus databases
would be key value document columns
and then the subcategory of wide columns
and graph and
not a lot of information here but we
will describe it in more detail when we
talk about
nosql databases okay
[Music]
all right let's talk about query and
querying because those are
terms that you're going to need to know
because you're going to be doing quite a
bit of it
if you are going to have a career as a
anything in data right like a data
analyst
so what is a query a query is a request
for data results
also known as reads uh or to perform
operations such as inserting updating or
deleting also known as
writes and so a query can perform
maintenance operations on the data and
it's not always restricted to just
uh working with the data that resides
within the database
and you'll see this where there's like
there's commands to do
analysis on your database and other
things like that
but here's an example of a query so what
is a data result
well results are data results is the
results of the data returned from a
query so here
you generally will see tabular data
that's usually what people want back but
you know you can get back json
or xml it really just depends on the
database what is querying so this is the
act of performing a query
so the idea is that you write your query
above and it's being sent
as an as a request could be through an
sdk cli
the shell an api lots of ways for it to
uh to get there
and then the idea is that the query is
going to return the the data results
so what is a query language that is a
scripting language or programming
language designed as the format to
submit a request or actions
to the database noble query languages is
sql
graph sql cousteau xpath
gremlin and there's a lot of them but
you know those are ones that stand out
to me right now
and just to note up here this is sql
okay so i just didn't want to make a big
old line this way here but this is sql
here okay
[Music]
all right so let's compare batch and
stream processing so
batch processing is when you send
batches a collection of data to be
processed
and batches are generally scheduled so
you might say every day at 1 pm but you
could also just
queue up a batch whenever you feel like
it batches are not real time meaning
that all the data is sent and then you
wait
until the batch is back to see the
results batch processing is ideal for
very large processing workloads
batch processing is generally more cost
efficient than stream processing and so
here we just kind of have a
representation so here we have our data
we broke it into batches or collections
we pass it to something like an etl
engine
and it will transform the data and then
we'll insert into our database data
warehouse data store
data lake house wherever you want to put
it then we have
stream processing so this is when you
process data as soon as it arrives
you'll have producers which will send
data to a stream
and consumers which will pull data from
a stream a lot of times a stream will
look like a pipeline and data can be
held in that
stream for a period of time so you have
a better reusability of data
if you need it for multiple consumers
uh stream processing is good for
real-time analytics real-time processing
like streaming videos anything that has
to do with real time if you need it
right away
it for that purpose it is much more
expensive than batch processing
um and here's a visual representation
where we have bits of our data they go
into our stream
pipeline that can be held there for a
while and
sometimes minor operations will be
performed on it but consumers will pull
the data and do what they want
with that data if we want to
contextualize these things in terms of
services on azure the idea is you'd have
your data sources and you'd ingest them
into something like azure stream
analytics
or i didn't really make this graphic
very good but the idea is that you go
into stream analytics
or maybe you go into hdinsights or maybe
you go
into azure synapse analytics or
one of these intermediate steps and then
eventually you go to power bi to make
your visualization reports
for stream processing
you could use event hub so event hub is
a
uh a single topic uh streaming service
and you could ingest that into azure
stream analytics
um it's funny because this is the stream
analytics icon this is actually the
hadoop icon
up here it's got it mixed up but anyway
you go into stream analytics and you can
insert that into cosmodb
and then maybe pull cosmodb into power
bi
but yeah that is the difference between
the two okay
all right let's talk about relational
data and this has to do with tables and
relationships between
other tables so let's talk about what a
table is it's a logical grouping of rows
and columns so an excel spreadsheet is
actually
tabular data tabular data just means the
data that makes use of
table data structures okay then you have
views which
look a lot like tables except they are
the result set so a table
when you do a query you're returning
back data and you're storing that
queries data in memory and basically
it's a
temporary or virtual table then you have
materialized views
and it's the same thing as a view except
the difference here instead of being
stored in memory it's stored on disk but
again it's the results of a table so
it's a virtual table
then you have indexes and this is a copy
of your data sorted by one or more
multiple columns for faster reads
at the cost of storage so think of it
kind of like a virtual table but it
doesn't include
all the columns and it's it's just so
it's just to help you
understand what order to retrieve data
you have constraints these are rules
applied to rights that can ensure data
integrity
so like if you have a database and you
want to make sure that there are no
duplicate records you put a constraint
for no duplicates
things like that you have triggers this
is a function that is
is a trigger on a specific database
event this is really useful let's say
after you insert a a column in your
database
you want to have a uuid you'd have a
function that would generate out
the uuid then you have primary keys so
one or more multiple columns that
uniquely identify a table in the row the
most common
primary key is id a foreign key so
a column which holds the value of a
primary key from another key to
establish a relationship
very commonly it's just the name of the
other table with underscore id
so relationship is when two tables have
a reference to one another to join the
data together
i know this text is really boring but
we're just going to cover so much about
relational database tables so i didn't
feel that we needed a visual here
but let's keep moving forward here with
relational data
so for relational data we have tables
and then the relationship between the
tables let's talk about those
relationships so relational databases
establish relationships to other tables
via
foreign keys referencing another's
table's primary key so looking at the
example here uh
you know this is the primary there's a
little icon here that shows you that
it's the primary key so this is the
primary key
and over here in another table it's
referencing
a foreign key so that's the foreign key
that's the primary key okay
and there are four types of
relationships between relational
databases
and their tables the first is one to one
so imagine a monkey has a banana or here
we have a table called country
and it has a capital it's one to one
then you have one too many so a store
has many customers
or you could say a book has many pages
notice that this denotes the many
here then you have many to many so a
project that has many tasks
and tasks can belong to many projects or
here
a book can have many authors and an
author can have many books so there's
many to many
and then last is a variant on the many
to many so
and it's via a join or junction table i
just call them join tables
so a student has many classes through
enrollments and the class has many
students
uh through enrollments so here it's the
same thing a book
can have many authors an author can have
any books but it's all through a library
so you could say
a book has many authors through a
library
and an author has many books through a
library okay so there you go
[Music]
okay so we know that relational
databases store
tabular data but the thing is that data
can also be stored
either in a row oriented way or a column
oriented way and let's just talk about
the differences there and
why we would do that so the first case
we have row store the data is organized
into rows
this is great for traditional relational
databases
which are row stores good for general
purpose
databases suited for online transaction
processing
oltp we are going to come back to that
term later on
great when needing all possible columns
in a row
which is important during a query not
the best at analytics or massive amounts
of data
all right we're looking at column store
data is organized into columns
it's faster at aggregating values for
analytics so the idea is imagine that
you want to
count how many cities there are for
millions of records
if it's organized by column like
querying based on column or data
stored together as columns a lot faster
generally these are nosql stores or
sql-like databases
it's a bit confusing because uh you know
like you would think tableau data is
just relational databases but
when you want to do column store they're
basically no sql stores
so that terms a bit fuzzy there it's
great for vast amounts of data when
we're talking about massive amounts
we're talking millions and millions of
records
terabytes worth of data okay suited for
online analytical processing oltp
great when you only need a few columns
so you don't need to
get data from all the columns and there
you go
[Music]
let's talk about database indexes which
is a data structure that improves the
speed of reads
from the database table by storing the
same or partial redundant data organized
in a more efficient
logical order and the logical order is
commonly determined by one or more
columns such as
sort keys and i always called that a
common data structure for an index is a
balanced tree
uh and it's short for b tree not to be
confused with binary tree which is
something else
um so you might see b tree and be like
okay that's how it's doing that
uh so here we just have kind of a visual
imagine you have a table or a foot like
that's for a phone book
and you want to quickly find people
based on the phone number because maybe
you're trying to find them based on the
starting number being 344 or something
so the idea is you make an index
and you say i want this to index by the
phone number
and so what it's going to do is change
the order there so it might just pull
the id or the number
and reorder it and so now what you'll do
is you'll use that index and that index
will use
as a reference to determine so it's not
storing all the data but
it will use that as a reference to the
original table to quickly return your
data
and so here's a very easy way to create
an index in postgres so we'd say create
index and then we give it a unique name
and we'd say
let's make it index on the um
for our addresses but just on the phone
number so there you go
[Music]
let's take a look here at data integrity
versus data corruption so data integrity
is the maintenance insurance of data
accuracy and consistency over its entire
life cycle and it's often used as a
proxy term for data quality
now you might think it's data validation
but it's just a prerequisite of data
integrity because again data integrity
is all about
the entire life cycle making sure over
all that it's going to stay consistent
so
validation is just one part of it the
goal of data integrity is to ensure data
is recorded
exactly as intended data integrity is
the opposite of data corruption so data
corruption is the act or state of data
not being in the intended state
result in data loss or misinformation
and data corruption occurs when
unintended changes result when reading
writing
and so in the case when you're doing
reads and writes maybe you have a
hardware failure
somebody just inputs the wrong data or
someone intentionally
is being malicious to corrupt your data
or there's unforeseen side effects for
operator operations via computer code so
you wrote code and you didn't know that
it was doing something that it wasn't
supposed to be doing
so how do we ensure data integrity well
we have a well-defined and documented
data modeling so
data modeling if you know exactly how
your data is supposed to be and it
doesn't match the model there then
you'll know
logical constraints on your database
items so we talked about that when we
talked about all the types of relational
data so constraints will keep that data
integrity in place
redundant and versions of your data to
compare and restore
so you have to be able to um not just
validate your data but be able to bring
it back to the state that it's supposed
to be
human analysis of the data so you know
that's where data analysis will
just check periodically uh hash
functions to determine if changes have
been tampered with
you see this quite often when you're
downloading uh open source software or
software
off like soft soft pedia where you can
have an md5 hash to say
did the thing i download match the thing
that it was expected
uh principle of least privileges so
limiting access to specific actions for
specific user roles
will mitigate uh problems that are
unexpected with your data so
all that stuff makes up data integrity
okay
[Music]
okay it's time to compare normalized
versus denormalized data so normalize is
a schema
designed to store non-redundant and
consistent data whereas
denormalize is a schema that combines
data so that accessing data or querying
it
is very very fast so when we see tables
and relationships like a relational
table where everything is
very discreetly organized this is
normalized data and then on the right
hand side where
you could take all those tables in the
right hand side and make them one table
this would be extremely efficient so the
left-hand side for normalized data
integrity is maintained
little to no redundant data many tables
optimize
for storage of data on the right-hand
side we have data tegrity is not
necessarily maintained or there's not
good controls in place you have to do
extra work to make sure it is
in good shape redundant data is common
fewer tables
excessive data storage is less optimal
now when you're using relational
databases
you can use both normalized and
denormalized
schemas and when you are using nosql
it's a little bit harder but like
there's cases where
you can kind of model things like tables
but generally data is denormalized
in nosql so there's a bit more challenge
with data integrity but
the the upside is you get a lot more
performance right so it's just
way way faster at scale
a pivot table is a table of statistics
that summarizes the data of more
extensive tables from a database
spreadsheet or business intelligence
tool
and pivot tables are a technique in data
processing they arrange or rearrange so
pivot statistics in order to draw
attention to useful information and this
leads to finding figures and facts
quickly
making them integral to data analysis so
when you're looking at microsoft excel
it's very easy to create pivot tables
think of a pivot table as an interactive
report where you can quickly aggregate
or group
your data based on various factors so
maybe you're grouping it by
year month week or day some average min
or max
and so over here i have an example of a
pivot table excel i got this from excel
jet which
they actually have really good
information about um pivot tables and
examples so if you
think that you want to learn more about
this i would go check out that resource
but here what you can see is that we
have a table and notice that it has
these little filters at the top
right and so the idea is you can drop
that down and say sort by
date and and other stuff and what that
you can do is create
here is another pivot table here where
we said okay let's sum the sales based
on blue and green so this is a pivot
table and then created another pivot
table
okay uh and so um you know it becomes
very useful tool in excel
all right and just one more thing pivot
tables used to be a trademarked
word owned by microsoft so a lot of
times pivot tables were specifically
just in excel or
their uh was it their microsoft access
database but now pivot tables
is a unique term or a general term that
everybody uses just for this kind of
operations
let's talk about data consistency and
this is when data is being kept in two
different places
and whether the data exactly matches or
does not match so
when you have to duplicate data in many
places and you need to keep them up to
date
to be exactly matching based on how the
data is transmitted and service level
the service levels of your cloud service
provider they'll use these two terms and
we'll hear
strongly consistent and eventually
consistent so strongly consistent means
every time you request data so you query
data you can expect consistent data
be returned within x time so they might
say within 10 milliseconds 100
milliseconds one second
so the thing is we will never return to
you old data
but you will have to wait at least x
amount of seconds for the query to
return whatever that defined time is
we talk about eventual consistency when
you're when you request
when you request data you may get back
inconsistent data within x amount of
periods so two seconds
we are giving you whatever data is
currently in the database
you may get new data or old data but if
you wait a little bit longer it will
generally be up to date why would we
have these two methods it just depends
on your use case maybe you can tolerate
some data to be inconsistent it's more
important to get whatever data is
available now
and sometimes you need an absolute
guarantee that the data is one to one
okay so those are the two different ones
[Music]
so synchronous and asynchronous can
refer to mechanisms of data
transformation
uh and data replications let's break
these two down so synchronous is
continuous streams
i'm just going to mark that there
continuous stream of data that is
synchronized
by a timer clock so you get a guarantee
of time of when the data will be synced
you can only access data once the
transfer is complete you get guaranteed
consistency of data returned it at the
time of access
slower access times so here is the data
and if you're thinking about strongly
consistent that is what this is
this is going to be when things are
strongly consistent then we have
asynchronous so
continuous stream of data separated by a
start and stop bits no guarantee of time
can access data anytime but may return
older versions or empty placeholder
faster access times no guarantee of
consistency
here it is so you see it's moving in
bits right
and so the idea is that we can access
any time in between here to get maybe
up to date data or not up to date data
to solidify this let's
put in some scenarios so a company has a
primary database but they need to have a
backup database in case their primary
database fails the company cannot lose
any data so
everything must be in sync the database
is not going to be accessed
while it is standing by to act as a
replacement so the reason why this works
is that you know
if you have a backup database you have
to make sure all your data is one to one
then on the other side here a company
has a primary database but they want a
read replica a copy of the database so
their data analytics person can create
computational intensive reports
that do not impact the primary database
it does not matter if the data is
exactly one to one at the time of access
because in this scenario it's like any
time the database goes down
you want it up to date to the second on
this side it's like they might run
reports
once a day whatever so you know there's
always new data coming in
and b2 to burdensome to make sure that
the data is always up to the second so
there you go
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at non-relational
data and this is where we store
data in a non-tabular form and will be
optimized for different kinds of data
structures so what kind of data
structures well we're looking at key
value store so
each value has a key design to scale
only simple lookups
then you have a document store so
primary entity is json-like data
structure called a document
you have column restore sometimes this
falls under relational databases but it
is a non-relational data type or
database so has a table like structure
but data is stored around columns
instead of rows
then you have the graph database where
data is represented with nodes
and structures where relationships
really really do matter and so sometimes
non-relational databases can be both a
key value and document store like azure
cosmodb or amazon dynamodb and the
reason for that is that documents are
actually a subset of key values which
we'll talk about
later when we get to that point
[Music]
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
we're taking a look at data sources so a
data source
is where the data originates from so an
analytics tool may be connected to
various data sources
to create a visualization report and a
data source could be
a data lake a data warehouse a data
store a database
a data requested on demand via an api
endpoint from a web app
and flat files such as excel or
spreadsheet
and so the example here is that we have
a data source
and somehow there has to be a connector
between them and it's going to be
consumed by either a warehouse an etl
engine a data lake
or bi tool those are common ones that
need data sources
so extracting data from data sources so
a data tool like
a business intelligence software would
establish a connection to multiple data
sources
at the bi would extract data which could
uh could be pulled data at at the time
of report or could be pulled data on
schedule
or data could be streamed the mechanism
for extracting data will vary per data
source
i just want you to know that because you
know when you're using these services it
does really vary on
how it pulls the data so i just want you
to understand there are a few different
ways okay
[Music]
so a data store is a repository for
persistently storing and managing
collections of unstructured or
semi-structured data so here i have kind
of a visual where we have
files going into some kind of store and
a data store is a very very broad term
so it's interchangeably used with
databases though databases is
technically a subset of a data store
but generally a data store indicates
working with
unstructured or even semi-structured
data so if somebody said
a data store i'm thinking that it's
either unstructured semi-structured okay
a data store can be specialized in
storing flat files
emails maybe a database as we said it
was a subset
or designed to be distributed across
many many machines
or it could be a directory service okay
so that's a data store
[Music]
so what is a database a database is a
data store that stores semi-structured
and structured data
and but a better term i would say would
be a database's more complex data store
because it requires using formal design
and modeling techniques
databases can be generally categorized
as either relational databases so this
is structured data
that strongly represents tabular data so
tables roles and columns
they're generally either row oriented or
columnar oriented
and when we talk about non-relational
databases we're looking at
semi-structured
data that may or may not distantly
resemble tabular data
and i know that i put this one over on
the relational side sometimes it ends up
here or there just understand that that
one kind of floats in between the two
really depends on the technology
underneath
and so here is a pretty common way you
get your sql you hit the database you
get a table back right
so databases have a rich set of
functionality specialized
uh language to query so that is our sql
here right
um we have specialized modeling
strategies to optimize retrieval
for different use cases more fine tune
control over the transformations of the
data into useful data structures or
reports the thing here on the end
normally a database infers someone is
using a relational
row-oriented data store so when somebody
that's when someone says a database
you're usually thinking like mysql
sql postgres smart db things like that
okay
[Music]
so what is a data warehouse it's a
relational data store designed for
analytic workloads which is generally
column oriented data store and again i'm
going to make an emphasis here
sometimes it's non-relational sometimes
it's relational don't get too worried
about that part okay
companies will have terabytes and
millions of rows of data and they need a
fast way to be able to produce analytic
reports that's how you know
you need an uh a data warehouse okay
data warehouses are generally
generally perform aggregations so
aggregations is grouping of data
to find a total or average data
warehouses are optimized around columns
since they need to quickly aggregate
column data and so
here is an example where we have our
warehouse
and the idea is that we're taking data
in from
like an unstructured source through an
etl and then here we have an sql these
are two different data sources
we use sql to then get our results okay
so data warehouses are generally
designed to be hot
hot meaning that the data will be
returned
very very fast even though they have
vast amounts of data
data warehouses are infrequently
accessed mean they aren't intended for
real-time reporting but
maybe once or twice a day or once a week
to generate businesses
and user reports now can report
extremely fast of course
but it's not like at a at a per
millisecond you're running it all day
and keeping it all up to date that's
more for
a stream right a data warehouse needs to
be needs to consume data from a
relational database on a regular basis
or you know through an etl data gets
transformed input in there okay
generally generally data warehouses are
read-only so you insert data
and then you read it you're not using it
for transactional data okay
[Music]
what is a data mart a data mart is a
subset of a data warehouse a data mart
will store generally under 100 gigabytes
and has a single
business focus and so a data mart allows
different teams or departments to have
control
over their own data set for specific use
cases so here we have a data warehouse
and we are running queries to then put
them in their own little data warehouses
but the idea is that you know there are
you know just smaller data sets that are
more focused
data marts are generally designed to be
read-only because you're going to always
have to pull data from the main data
warehouse
data mart's also increase the frequency
at which data can be accessed because of
just smaller data sets
and you don't have to worry about you
know a huge cost because the larger the
data set you have to
query over the more expensive it gets
right the cost of query is much much
lower
and so you might even see people
accessing these a lot more frequently
than they would a data warehouse so
there you go
[Music]
so what is a data lake it is a
centralized storage repository that
holds
vast amounts of raw data so big data in
either semi-structured or unstructured
format
a data lake lets you store all your data
without careful design or having to
answer questions on the future use of
the data
so basically it's hoarding for data
scientists here is
kind of a visualization where you have a
bunch of different data sources dropping
into the data lake
maybe you want to perform etls and put
data back into the data lake
and then you know you can extract out
for reports ml all sorts of things we'll
definitely cover
data lakes when we get to the data lake
section but this is the general overview
here
a daylight is commonly accessed for data
workloads such as visualizations for bis
tools
real-time analytics machine learning
on-premise data data lakes are great for
data scientists but it's very hard to
use data lakes for bi
reporting so it's not that you can't do
it it's just that there's additional
steps and so there might be a different
solution that might be a bit easier
such as a data warehouse if data lakes
are not well maintained they can become
data swamps
which is basically like data corruption
right so uh yeah there you go
[Music]
what is a data lake house well a data
lake house combines the best elements of
a data lake and data warehouse and
this isn't something that azure has an
offering for right off the bat right now
but you can definitely
definitely believe that cloud service
providers will have this in the future
so i want you to know about this today
even if it's not on your exam
so data like houses compared to data
warehouse can
support video audio and text files
support data science ml workloads have
support for both streaming and etl
work with many open source formats data
will generally reside in a data lake or
blob store so the thing with data lake
or data warehouse is usually used
proprietary formats so this is a lot
more flexible
data like houses compared to data lakes
can perform bi tasks very well which is
something data links cannot do
much easier to set up and maintain has
management features to avoid a data like
becoming a data swamp right because data
warehouses are
very well data modeled and data links
aren't
so data lakes are kind of in between and
data lakes
and with a data lake house is going to
be more performant than a data lake so
where would you find a solution right
now well probably with data
delta like which is a data bricks
solution
so it's uh apache data lake i believe is
open source and so if you wanted a
managed version of it
databricks has an offering for that and
so they have this nice little graphic
here where they show you that you know
you combine the two and you get the best
of both worlds
so you know you'll see more data likes
in the future so there you go
[Music]
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro we
are looking at data structures so what
is a data structure
this is data that is organized in a
specific storage format that enables
easy access and modification
and a data structure can store various
data types
so data can be abstractly described to
have a degree of structure so we have
unstructured a bunch of loose data that
has no organization or possibly
any relation semi-structured data that
can be browser search with limitations
structured data that can be easily
browsed or searched so when we look at
unstructured
data think of a bunch of loose files and
this is just a screenshot from one of my
folders here's a bunch of stuff
or semi-structured data we have xml or
structured data where it's like we're
using a relational database so
yeah there we go let's go drill down
into these three types of abstractions
[Music]
so again what is unstructured data well
it's just a bunch of loose data think of
it as
junk folder on your computer with a
bunch of random files not optimized for
search analysis or simply no relation
between the various data so
again there's a bunch of files in my uh
one of my folders there
and so when we're talking about
microsoft azure services that store
unstructured data we have sharepoint so
shared documents for an organization
azure blob storage so unstructured
object data store
azure files a mountable file system for
storing unstructured files
azure data lake for big data it's
basically blob storage but
for vast amounts of data and if i wanted
to add a fifth one there you know like
azure
azure disks but that's more for virtual
machines okay
[Music]
so let's take a look here at
semi-structured data which basically has
no schema and the data has some form of
relationship it's easy to browse data to
find
related data and you can search data but
there are limitations or
or when you search you will pay a
computative or operational cost a great
way of thinking about this
is think of a big box of legos and you
have these lego pieces
so it's not that there's not a schema
defined there's a schema defined
in the sense of the lego piece so it can
connect and make relationships with
other things that are compatible
but overall the entire data as a whole
does not have a schema
right you don't have you're not
upfronting and doing data modeling
so just understand that's why i put the
asterisk there so there is a schema for
the data structures just not
for everything in total totally here
that's why it's called semi-structured
for concrete semi-structured data
structures we've got xml json
avro and parquet i don't know if it's
pronounced parquet but that's the way i
say it
and for azure and other services that
store send me semi-structured data we
have azure tables which is a key value
store
azure cosmodb where its primary one is
document of course it stores other types
but
when we're talking about semi-structure
we're talking about a document store
mongodb which is an open source document
store and then we have apache cassandra
which is a
y column store database um
that's nosql that's just an open source
one okay
[Music]
all right so we're still on
semi-structured data structures i just
want to give them a little bit more
attention because
you know you might need to know some of
the the guts to these semi structures so
what is the semi-structured data
semi-structured data is data that
contains fields the fields don't have to
be the same in every entity
you only define the fields that you need
on a per entity basis so common
semi-structured data structures is
javascript object notation json format
used in json notation
stored data in memory read and write
from files
apache apache optimize row columner
format
also known as ork organizes data into
columns rather than rows so column or
data source structure
apache parquet this is another column or
data store a parket file contains rows
and groups
we have apache avro which is row based
format
each record contains a header that
describes the structure of the data in
the record
you have also xml we're not going to go
through all of these but i do want to
drill down on some of these
semi-structured data structures so you
know how they internally work okay
all right let's take a look at json so
json stands for javascript object
notation
and it is a lightweight data interchange
format it is easy for humans to read and
write
it is easy for machines to parse and
generate and it is based on a subset of
javascript so here is an example
of json and json is built on two
structures the first is a collection of
names
name value pairs in other languages this
is realized as an object a record a
struct a dictionary a hash table keyed
list or associative array
so if you've ever heard of those things
before that's basically what it looks
like the other part is an ordered list
of values
other languages might call them arrays
vectors list or sequence just to point
them out there is the collection and
there is the ordered list
and json is a text format so that is
completely language independent
uh so it is used quite a bit
these days
all right let's take a look at apache
org files which stands for optimize row
columner
it's a storage format for apache hadoop
system so it is similar to rc files and
parkit files
and is the successor to rc files we're
not going to cover rc files here but
you know that's where these come from it
was developed by facebook to support
polymer reads predictive push downs and
lazy reads
is more storage efficient than rc files
taking up
75 percent less space or only supports
hadoop hive
and pig when we get to the hadoop
section you'll understand what those are
orc performs better with hive than
parquet files org files are organized
into stripes of data
so here is that example there the
autonomy of an org file so the file
footer stores the auxiliary information
the list of stripes in the file the
number of rows per stripe
each column the data type is column
level aggregate information so
count min max the stripe footer contains
a directory of stream locations
and we have the row data which is used
for table scans and the index table
includes min
max values for each column and the row
positions for each
columns and the default size of a stripe
is 250 megabytes
with large stripe sizes enable large
efficient reads
for hdfs which is the hadoop file system
which we'll talk about when we get to
the
hadoop section but if you want to just
review this here and then take a look at
this graphic and it'll make
a hundred percent sense here okay
[Music]
so let's take a look here at parquet
files so apache parquet is a column
restore file format available to
any project in the hadoop ecosystem so
hive hbase mapreduce pig spark
presto there's a huge list of them and
not just here
in the hadoop system but other other
services
azure even a bus services work really
well with parquet files so
you know it's just becoming a very
common format for columnar storage
formats the parquet is built to support
very efficient compression encoding
schemes
it uses the record shredding assembly
algorithm that's why i don't go in
detail like work here
here about like talking about this data
structure because it just gets
complicated so
i just want you to know that parket
files are more generally used in org
files work have very particular use
cases
uh and you're going to come across
parkette more when you're doing columnar
storage file formats okay
[Music]
let's take a look at avro so apache avro
is a row-based format that provides rich
data structures
compact fast binary data format a
container file to store persistent data
remote procedure calls rpcs simple
integration with dynamic languages avro
provides functionality similar to
systems such as thrift and protocol
buffers
here is the data structure so when would
you be using
avro over parquet well it's just when
you uh when you have data like you want
to serialize your json into a more
efficient format
we're doing general queries right if
you're doing analytics
right columner based stuff you're doing
it for um
aggregation and stuff like that if
you're just trying to kind of like
simulate general
general relational database structures
for semi-structured or
no skill databases you're going to want
to use avro
[Music]
all right let's talk about uh structured
data so structured data it has a scheme
and data
data has a relationship it's easy to
browse to find related data it's easy to
search data
the most common structured data is
tabular data representing the rows and
columns right
so examples here for azure would be its
postgres
azure data sql database for postgres
for msql azure sql for mssql
and azure synapse analytics which is the
data warehouse service okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at what is data
mining so this is the extraction of
patterns and knowledge from large
amounts of data
not to be confused with the extraction
of data itself a lot of people think
data mining means go on a website and
start scraping that's not what it is
uh cross industry standard process for
data mining called chris dmm
is defined into six phases there's a lot
of way to define data
mining but i just chose this one because
i found that it's the easiest to
understand so we got our big wheel here
let's break through the six phases so
business understanding right so
here we are at the start of our journey
over here business understanding
so what does the business need then we
have data understanding which is what do
we have to do and
what data do we need and you can see
that you can work between back and forth
before you move on to the next step
we have data preparation so how do we
organize the data for modeling
then we have modeling so what modeling
techniques should we apply
over here evaluation so what
which data model best meets the business
objectives and on the end here we have
deployment so
how do people access the data so there
you go
[Music]
let's take a look at different types of
data mining methods and this will
definitely not be an exhaustive list but
it will give you a good idea
what a data miner does so data mining
methods or techniques is the way to find
valid patterns and relationships in huge
data sets so we have classification this
is where you classify data into
different classes
you have clustering a division of
information into groups of connected
objects
you have regression which is ident
identify and
analyze the relationships between
variables because of the presence of
other factors we have sequential so
evaluating sequential data
to discover sequential patterns
association rules discover a link or two
or more items find a hidden pattern in
the data sets
these common these common constraints
math formulas are used to determine
significant
and interesting links so we got support
so indication of
how frequently the item set appears in
the data set confidence indication of
how often the rule
has been found to be true lift
indication of importance compared to
other items conviction indication of
the strength of the rule from the
statistical independence
for outer detection we have observation
of data items in the data set
which do not match an expected pattern
or expected behavior we have prediction
use a combination of data mining
techniques such as trends clustering
classification to predict
future data not super important for you
to remember all this but i'm just trying
to like get you exposure to these terms
and things so that
as you see them more it'll make sense
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at what is data
wrangling so data wrangling is the
process of transforming and mapping data
from one
raw data form into another format with
the intent of making it more appropriate
and valuable for a variety of downstream
purposes such as analytics
also known as data munching so there are
six
core steps behind data wrangling the
first is discovery so understand
what your data is about and keep in mind
domain specific details about your data
as you move through the other steps
structuring so you need to organize your
content into a structure that will be
easier to work for
our end results cleaning so remove
outliers change null values remove
duplicates remove special characters
standardizing formatting
enriching appending or enhancing
collected data with relevant context
obtained
from additional sources validating
authenticate the reliability quality
and safety of the data and publishing so
place your data in a data store
so it can be used uh downstream so there
you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at what is data
modeling but before we can answer that
we should ask what is a data model so
it's an abstract model that
organizes elements of data and
standardizes how they relate to one
another and to the properties of real
world entities a data model could be a
relational database that contains
many tables so here's actually an
example of some data modeling i did
which is for the exam pro platform if
you ever open up
power bi they have like a data modeling
tab so it becomes very clear what it is
but generally
uh you know data models just look like a
bunch of tables and relationships but
it's going to vary
based on what you're using a data model
for so a dml could be conceptual so how
data is represented the organizational
level abstractly without
concretely describing how it works
within the software so people orders
projects relationships
logical so how data is presented in
software
tables columns object oriented classes
physical so how data is physically
stored so partitions cpus and table
spaces
so this one would probably be the the
middle one here which is logical okay
so you know this isn't just exactly how
data modelling looks like
there's all varieties the way uh data
modeling or a data model can appear
so what is data modeling a process used
to define
and analyze data requirements needed to
support the business processes within
the scope of the corresponding
information systems
and organizations so here uh we have
our uh data modeling here so you can see
that uh it's actually broken up kind of
into three sections
which maps up really well c where it
says physical conceptual things like
that it matches up to our three
categories here conceptual logical
physical so just
take in mind that uh you know if you
have data modeling you can move from
a conceptual to a logical to a physical
one all right and so there you go
[Music]
all right let's take a look at etl
versus elt so etl and etl is used when
you want to move data from one location
to another where the data store database
have a different data structure so you
need to transform the data
for the target system a common use case
would be ms sql
to cosmodb so this one is relational
this one's nosql they just didn't have
the same data structures you'd have to
do some kind of transformation
and so here we have our visuals for etl
and elt so let's talk about
etl first which stands for extract
transform and load
so loads the data first into a staging
server and then into a target system so
even though it's not shown here
we actually have an intermediate virtual
machine or server
that's being loaded temporarily into
doing the transformations and then when
it's done it's going to
output it into its target system used
for on-premise relational
and structured data so it's very common
for on-prem like this could be a
migration strategy so
they could be taking an sql database and
just moving it to
um a sql database on
azure right and so there might be like
they're the same type of database but
there could be
different versions of databases so the
the feature sets slightly different so
they do some transformations
it's good for a small amount of data to
be fair etl can be used for larger
workloads but you know when we're
comparing from elts it's generally
smaller
doesn't provide data like support easy
to implement
mostly supports relational databases
okay
when we talk about extract load
transform loads directly into the target
system
used for scalable cloud structures and
unstructured data sources used for large
amounts of data
provides data like support requires
specialized skills to implement and
maintain
supports for unstructured data readily
available so you're going to see that
elt is going to be the more common use
case
where we're dealing with cloud but it
does require a little bit more knowledge
where this one is just like if you know
sql you're going to be in good shape
okay
so there you go
[Music]
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
we are looking at what data analytics is
so
this is when you're concerned with
examining transforming arranging data so
you can extract
useful information a person that does
data analytics is called a data
analyst and they commonly use tools such
as sql
business intelligence tools and
spreadsheets if we look at the data and
analytics workflow so you can understand
their whole scope of their job they'll
do data ingestion so getting data from
multiple sources
data cleaning and transformation so
maybe they're using
uh you know pandas and um
notebooks and things like that or sql
commands uh dimensional reduction so
they have to reduce the amount of data
data and analysis which could be like
statistics and things like that
visualizations you use your bi tools or
you are actually coding in
dashboards and things like that so yeah
that is data analytics
[Music]
all right let's talk about kpis here so
key performance indicators are type of
performance measurement that a company
will use or their organization will use
to determine performance over time so
here's an example of a kpi for
product revenue and the goal was 3.12
million
but the company actually generated out
2.29 million so there's 26 percent
under their goal kpi can evaluate the
success of an organization or for a
specific
organization activity and there are two
categories of measurement for kpis we
have
quantitative and these quantitative and
qualitative or get easily confused
because they're very similar name but
quantitative the properties can be
measured with a numerical result
facts presented with a specific value so
monthly revenue numbers of signups
number of reports
or defects so what we're looking up at
here is quantitative okay
and then we have qualitative so
properties that are observed and
can generally not be measured with
enumerable results numerical
or numeric or textual value that
represents uh
personal feelings tastes and opinions so
maybe customer sentiment would be
example there so that is kpis
[Music]
all right so we're taking a look here at
data analytics techniques and this is
something you 100 need to know for the
exam
so pay close attention here okay so the
top
of our list here we have descriptive
analytics and the question we are
answering here is what has happened
uh so here we might have specialized
metrics such as kpis or return on
investment or
things that we're more familiar with
like generating sales and financial
reports
at this stage we have a lot of data
right it's very accurate comprehensive
it's either live data and we can make
very effective visualizations to
understand
our data because we have all that
historical information but
there's a lot more to it in terms of
value and so we'll move down
or out move out to see
the other stuff that we can do here the
next is diagnostic analytics so
why did it happen it's supplemental to
descriptive analytics we can drill down
investigate descriptive metrics to
determine root cause
find and isolate anomalies into its own
data set and apply statistical
techniques
we have predictive analytics so what
will happen so we use historical data to
predict
trends or recurrence we use either
statistical or machine learning
techniques apply this is where a data
scientist might get involved
we use neural networks decision trees
regression classification neural
networks just means
deep learning machine learning okay
prescriptive analytics how can we make
it happen
so goes a step further than predictive
and uses ml by ingesting hybrid
data to predict future scenarios that
are exploitable and then the last one is
what if this happens and that's
cognitive analysis so
using analytics to draw patterns to
create what if scenarios and what
actions can be taken
if the scenarios become a reality so
there you go that is data analytic
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
microsoft onedrive so microsoft onedrive
is a storage and storage synchronization
service for
files which reside in the cloud similar
to products like dropbox google drive
box and microsoft
sharepoint so onedrive is intended for
personal storage for a single individual
you pay for different sizes of storage
so you have five gigabytes which are
free 100 gb 1tb
and 6tb you do not worry about the
underlying hardware the durability
resilience fall tolerance availability
that's what we call
serverless technology here is a nice
screenshot of what it looks like to use
onedrive both in the browser
and on your phone files can be shared
easily to other users via a shareable
link or a specific email that
has onedrive account files are accessed
via a web app
or shared folders that hold a reference
to file stored in the cloud so shared
folders mean like you can
literally use your file system and
you'll have folders that are linked to
it
files can be synchronized so a copy
resides in a local computer hard drive
is copied to the cloud a file
residing the cloud can be copied to a
little computer hard drive
copying occurs automatically when files
are changed differences and files could
result in conflicts and a user must
choose which file to keep or how to
resolve the conflict might have more
options
files can be versions so you can recover
older versions of files older files
may retain for 30 days and be
automatically deleted so there you go
that is onedrive
let's take a look here at microsoft 365
sharepoint so
365 sharepoint is a web-based
collaborative platform that integrates
into the microsoft office intended for
document management
and shared storage and here is a
screenshot of my sharepoint
uh and so there's the az-104 so the
thing is is that
it's basically one drive uh but
for companies with a bunch of layers on
top of it and it is extremely useful to
use it's super
super useful so like if you work in a
company you should really be using
sharepoint
for sharing files so just going down the
feature list here so sharepoint sites
because there's some concepts here just
besides documents they have things like
sites
so data within sharepoint is organized
around sites a site is a collaborative
space for teams with
the following components so document
library pages web parts and more
sharepoint doctor document library which
will expand there and that's what the
screenshot is on the right-hand side so
a document library is a file storage and
synchronization but
designed for teams it is very similar to
onedrive but files are owned by the
company and not an individual
you can apply robust permissions to
access files within or outside your
organization
a site always has a default document
library called documents
and so there's a lot more going on in
sharepoint but this is the most
important feature of it
and actually when you use onedrive when
you install on your computer there's
like a synchronization device it's the
same
thing so sharepoint most likely is using
the one drive technology underneath i
don't know 100
but it's most likely the case so there
you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at data core concepts
this one's four sheets long so let's
jump into it so the first here is data
which is units of information data
documents types of abstract groupings of
data
data sets unstructured logical grouping
of data data structures
which has some form of structure and
there's variance right so we have
unstructured a bunch of loose data that
has no organization
or possible relation we're talking about
flat files here various files that can
reside in a file system
semi-structured so that's data that can
be borrowed or searched with limitations
so csvs xml json parkette
and so if we're talking about xml files
the markup looks like html for json it's
a text file that's composed of
dictionaries and arrays
rc files are storage formats designed
for map reduce framework
not something we covered in the uh
lecture content but i just wanted to
mention them there
work so a columnar data structure 705
percent more efficient than rc files
limited compatibility
works very well with hive we have avro
so a rose row-wise data structure for
hadoop systems
you have parkette a columnar data
structure that has more
support for hadoop systems than orc then
we were talking about structured data so
data that can be easily browse or search
so tabular data
and so tabular data is data that is
arranged as tables think of spreadsheets
data types how single units of data are
intended to be used we're not going to
go through the whole list they're not
going to ask that on the exam but you
should know
your data types uh four types of roles
that azure cares for you to know we have
database administrators so it configures
and maintains databases
data engineer design and implement data
tasks related to transfer and storage of
big data
data analysts analyzes business data to
reveal important information
then we have our tiers of computing so
we have software as a service a product
that is run and managed by a service
provider
platform as a service focus on the
deployment management of your apps
infrastructure as a service basic
building blocks of cloud it provides
access to networking computers data
storage and space
and remember that uh we're talking about
sql it's going to be the sql vms on this
layer and then here's going to be the
managed sql
and azure sql databases okay
so we're on to the second page here so
let's talk about data stores
unstructured or semi-structured data
for housing data a broad term that can
encompass anything that stores data
databases structured data that can be
accessed quickly
and search generally relative row-based
tabular data for oltp
data warehouses structured
semi-structured data for creating
reports and analytics column based
tabular data for olap
data mart's a subset of data warehouse
for specific business data tasks data
lakes combines the best of data
warehouses and data lakes
notebooks data that is arranged in pages
designed for easy consumption
batching when you send batches a
collection of data to be processed not
real time
streaming when the data is processed as
soon as it arrives so it's real time
relational data data that uses struct
structure tabular data and has
relationships between tables
and in terms of relationships for
relation relational stuff we have one to
one so
one to one so think a monkey has a
banana one to many a store has many
customers many to many a project has
many tasks and tasks can belong to many
projects
a join table a student has many classes
through enrollments the enrollments
would be the join table and a class
as many students through enrollments
then we're talking about
row stores so or row wise data organized
and rows optimized for oltp
then you have column store or columner
data organizing columns optimize for
olap so analytics
then we have indexes a data structure
that improves the reads of databases
this is also shows up under
non-relational databases but i just
threw it here just because
we have pivot tables it is a table of
statistics that summarizes the data of
more extensive table from a database
spreadsheet or
bi tool now talking about non-relational
data
data that is semi-structured data
associated with scandalous neuroscience
databases so we got key value
each value has a key designed to scale
only simple lookups
i like to describe as simple dumb and
not a lot of features we have document
primary entities xml or json-like data
structure called a document
columner has a table like structure but
the data is stored around columns
instead of rows graph data is
represented with nodes and structures
where relationships matter okay
uh we're on to the third page here so
data modeling an abstract model that
organizes elements of data and
standardizes how
they relate to one another in the real
world entities
schema a formal language to describe the
structure of data used by databases and
data
stores during the data modeling phase
schema is generally used for
when upfront data modeling can be
foregone
foregone i did not write that right but
because the schema is flexible normally
used with no skill databases
data integrity the maintenance and
assurance of data accuracy and
consistency over its entire lifecycle
data corruption the act of data not
being in the intended state
will result in data loss or
misinformation normalization a schema
designed to store non-redundant
consistent data
denormalize a schema that combines data
so that access to data is fast
elts or etls transform data from one
data store to another
loads the data in an intermediate stage
doesn't work does not work with data
lakes
e-l-t transformations done at the target
data store
uh works with data lakes more common in
cloud services things of azure app
analytics
okay or azure snaps analytics where the
data is loaded and done
uh in the actual data warehouse or etc a
query when a user requests data from a
data store by using query language to
return the data result
data source data sources where data
originates from
for so analytics and data warehouse
tools may be connected to various data
sources
bi tools would have data sources as well
data consistency
when data being kept in two different
places and whether the date that the
data exactly matches or does not match
strongly consistent every time you
request data
you can expect consistent data to be
returned within a time
eventually consistent when you request
data you may get inconsistent data so
like stale data
synchronization continuous stream of
data that is synchronized by a timer or
clock so guarantee of time asynchronous
a synchronization continuous stream of
data
separated by start and stop uh stop bits
no guarantee of time and this is
synchronization in terms of processing
okay
data mining the extraction of patterns
and knowledge from large amounts of data
not the extraction of data itself data
wrangling the process of transforming
mapping data from one raw data into from
form into another format and we're on
the last page here so data analytics
data analytics is examining transforming
arranging data so that you can
extract and study useful information
key performance indicators probably not
talked about the exam but i threw it in
here because it's just important to know
type of performance measurement that a
company organization to determine
performance over time
then in terms of the types of uh
analytics that we can utilize we have
descriptive analytics what happened so
accurate comprehensive like data
effective visualization so dashboards
reports kpis roi that's when you have
all the information
diagnostic analytics why did it happen
drill down to investigate root cause
sometimes they call that root cause
analysis we didn't talk about that in
the
course but that's what it is focus on a
subset of descriptive and now an
analytics subset so it's a subset of
this one up here okay
predictive analytics what will happen so
use historical data with statistics and
ml
probably should highlight that in red
there for you to generate trends or
predictions
predictive analytics what will happen
use hybrid data with ml to predict
future scenarios that are exploitable
cognitive analysts what if this happens
so use ml
and nlp to determine what if scenarios
to create plans if they happen
these are all really similar but the
thing is is that they just it's it's the
lens you put on like the
the reason why you're doing it okay then
we talk about run drive so storage and
storage synchronization service for a
single user and then we have sharepoint
storage and storage synchronization
service for an organization there's a
little bit more to that but
that is it for data core concepts
[Music]
let's take a look at azure synapse
analytics and this is a data warehouse
and a unified analyst platform we're
going to talk more about the latter
because like you know what a data
warehouse at this point is just
a column or store and so here is a
visual
of um the data analytics or data
synapses studio so here you can see
there's a query going on so we're just
querying data
but there's a lot we can do uh on the
unified analytics platform so we can
perform etl and elt
processes in a code-free visual
environment so you don't have to write
any code
using just data from more than 95 native
connectors
deeply integrated with apache spark uses
tsql queries
on both your data warehouse and spark
engines just that's what we're looking
at there is the tsql
and supports multiple languages so tsql
python
scala spark sql and net and it's
integrated with artificial intelligence
so ai and business intelligence tools bi
so we could use azure machine learning
studio or azure cognito services
or microsoft power bi just to get a
better visual of the entire flow here on
the left hand side you're ingesting
data from sources all the data is going
to be stored
on a data lake uh storage gen
2 here at the top here we have the azure
synapse
analytics studios that's where you're
going to be doing um the interface
you're going to be working with
and then you're going to be able to
output the various services and notice
here that we have
sql and apache spark which are the
different runtime engines
this really looks like to me uh a data
lake
uh or lake house which when i was
talking about lake house i was like
azure doesn't have
an offering but now that i'm looking at
the screenshot this definitely is
a data lake house so yeah i guess azure
synapse is a data lake house cool
[Music]
all right let's talk about synapse sql
so snapsesql is a distributed version
of t sql designed for data warehouse
workloads
it extends tsql to address streaming and
machine learning scenarios
it uses built-in streaming capabilities
to land data from uh
load supposed to say load data from
cloud data sources into sql tables
integrate ai with sql by using ml models
to score data using tsql predict
function
and offers both serverless and dedicated
resource models so
for the serverless side this is great
for unpredictable workloads so unplanned
or bursty
workloads use use the always available
or serverless sql endpoint are our
options for
predictable workloads we create
dedicated sql pools to reserve
processing power for
data stored in sql tables so here we're
talking about dedicated dedicated sql
pools and others so let's talk about
those very quickly
i couldn't even be bothered to make a
graphic for this because
it's just too much work so i just pulled
it right from the docs but dedicated sql
pool is a query service over the
over the data in your data warehouse the
unit of scale and
is an abstraction of compute power that
is known as a data warehouse unit dwd
once your dedicated sql pool is created
you can import big data with
simple poly based tsql queries and then
use the power of this
distributed query engine to perform high
performance analytics
then there's the serverless sql pools
which looks like this and
uh serverless esql pool is a query
service over the data in your data lake
scaling done automatically to
accommodate query resource requirements
as as topology changes over time by
adding removing
nodes or failure it adapts to changes
and makes sure
your query has enough resources and
finishes successfully they're not going
to test you on these data pool things
but
you know i just figured we'd provide a
little more context and some more
uh language around here just to help
solidify what the service is but there
you go
[Music]
just a couple of things that i just want
to give extra emphasis on which is
apache spark and data lake with synapses
so
it's synapse but i just keep on saying
synapses just get used to it
azure synapse can deeply and seamlessly
integrate with apache spark as you can
see here and ml mods with
spark ml algorithms and azure ml
integration for
apache spark 2.4 with built-in support
for linux foundation delta lake there's
the apache spark 3. so i'm surprised
they're not up to date yet at least when
i wrote this
simplified resources models that freeze
your you from having to worry about
managing clusters
fast spark startup and aggressive auto
scaling built in support for
net for spark allowing you to reuse c
sharp expertise in existing.net
code with the spark application talking
about data lake here
azure synapse removes the traditional
technology barriers using sql and spark
together
and you can seamlessly mix and match
based on your needs and expertise
tables defined on files in the data lake
are seamlessly consumed by spark or hive
sql and spark can directly
explore and analyze parquet csv tsv
json file stored in the data lake fast
scalable data loading between
spark and sql and spark databases so
there you go
so a data lake is a centralized data
repository for unstructured and
semi-structured data and a lake is
intended to store vast amounts of data
a daylight generally uses object blob or
files as its storage medium
and so the idea is you will collect data
by putting putting various sources in
there you'll do transformations so
change your blend data into new
semi-structures using etl or
elt and put it right back in the data
lake or we could distribute it by
allowing access to
data to various programs and apis or
publish the data set to a meta catalog
so analysts can quickly find useful data
now if we want to have an azure data
lake
uh you know you're gonna have to create
a data lake storage but the thing is
that gen one is no longer really
intended to be used
the only people that should be using it
are the people that are still in use
but we'll focus on gen 2. so gen 2 is
the data lake storage for azure blob
storage which has been
extended to support big data analytic
workloads designed to handle petabytes
of data and hundreds of gigabytes of
throughput
in order to efficiently access the data
data lake storage adds a hierarchical
hierarchical namespace to the azure blob
storage and this is what it looks like
on the left hand side so
we have two ways of access through the
blob endpoint w-a-s-b-s
the dfs endpoint abfs these are
different drivers one is for object
one is for file but they'll both get you
in there and they're both compatible
with
hdfs which is hadoop and then the
hierarchical namespace you get access
control throttling timeout management
performance and optimizations okay so
there you go
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
polybase and this is a data
virtualization feature of sql
servers and specifically we're saying
msql right microsoft's sql
polybase enables your sql server
instance to query data with tsql
directly from sql server oracle
teradata mongodb hadoop clusters cosmodb
without separately installing
client connection software and so here's
a fancy example to
show you how great this tool is and
polybase allows you to join data from an
sql server instance with external data
prior to polybase to join data to
external data sources you can either
transfer half your data so that all the
data was in one location
or query both sources of data then write
custom query logic to join and integrate
the data at the client
level so there you go
[Music]
let's talk about how elts happen in um
synapse analytics so you can perform
elts uh
in synapse sql and uh within the snaps
analytics so the fastest and most
scalable way to load
data is through polybase external tables
and copy statements that's why we talked
about
polybase so with polybase and copy
statement you can access external data
stored in azure blob storage
data like store via the ts sql language
makes sense because if you can do data
like store blob storage is the same
thing so
here is a graphic where you can see we
are ingesting from
uh sql into polybase into our data
warehouse
and then we can talk to our data lake
and do a variety of other things
so the basic steps for an etl are
extract the source data into text files
load the data into blob storage or azure
data lake store prepare the data for
loading load the data into
into staging tables with polybase or
copy command transform the data and
insert the data into the production
tables
[Music]
so azure data lakes analytics is an
on-demand analytics job service that
simplifies big data instead of deploying
configuring and tuning hardware you
write queries called
usql to transform your data and extract
valuable insights
so the idea here is that by exporting
approximately 2.8 billion rows of tcps
ds
store sales data 500 gigabytes into a
csv it took less than seven
seven minutes and importing a full
terabyte of source
uh took under with a connector took
under less than six hours so the idea is
that
it's pretty darn fast and just to show
you where it is it's over here in the
middle
so the idea is that this tool just lets
you do run uh
queries on your data lake okay so let's
talk about usql so usql is a structured
query language included with data like
analytics to perform queries
on your data lake you can see there's a
bunch of stuff in here like extract and
stuff
um and so usql can query and combine
data from a variety of data sources
including azure data lake storage blob
storage sql db
data warehouse sql server instances
running on azure vm
you can install the azure data lake
tools for visual studio to perform usql
jobs
on your azure data lake i didn't see it
in um
azure data studio but it might be there
too
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
we're taking a look here at the azure
synapse and data lake cheat sheet for
the dp900
let's jump into it a data lake is a
centralized data repository for
unstructured and semi-structured data
a data lake is intended to store vast
amounts of data data likes generally use
objects blobs or files as its storage
medium
for the azure data lake storage
generation 2 this is an azure blob
storage
which has been extended to support big
data analytics workloads it does this
via its hierarchical namespace
and what the oracle namespace gives you
is acls throttle management performance
optimizers
you can access your data like via the
wasb protocol blob
or abfs which is a file system protocol
azure synapse analytics is a data
warehouse and unified analytics platform
has two underlying transformation
engines so we have esqel pools and spark
pools
synapse sql is tsql but designed to be
distributed sql dedicated pools is
reserve compute for processing
serverless endpoints on demand no
guarantee of performance data stored on
azure data lake store generation 2
operations
are performed within the azure synapse
studio
polybase enables your sql server
instance to query data with tsql used to
connect many relational database sources
probably use with other services not
just with azure snaps but there you go
all right let's take a look at azure
blob so blob storage is an object store
that is optimized for storing massive
amounts of unstructured data
unstructured data is data that doesn't
adhere to a particular data model or
definition such as text or binary data
as your blobs are composed of the
following components so we have storage
accounts
which is a unique namespace in azure for
your data you have containers which is
similar to a folder and a file system
and then the actual data being stored
so azure storage supports three types of
blobs we've got block blobs so these
store text and binary data
made up of blocks of data that can be
managed individually so we're up to 4.75
terabytes
we have a pen blobs these optimize for
append operations ideal for scenarios
such as logging data from virtual
machines
and we have page blobs these store
random access files to
up to eight terabytes in size and store
virtual hard drives vhd files and serve
as
disks for azure virtual machines and
there you go
all right let's take a quick look here
at azure files so azure files is a fully
managed file share in the cloud
and a file share is a centralized server
for storage that allows for multiple
connections
it's like having one big shared drive
that everyone you know virtual machines
can work
on at the same time so here's an example
or a diagram of it so to connect to the
file share use a network protocol such
as server message block
smb or network file system nfs
when a connection is established the
files shares file system will be
accessible in the in the specific
directory within your
own directory tree this is known as
mounting so some use cases here
completely replace your supplement your
on-premise file servers
nas drives a lift and shift of your
on-prem
storage to the cloud via classic lift or
hybrid lift
lift and shift means when you move
workloads without re-architecting so
importing local vms to the cloud
a classic lift would be where both the
application and its data are moved to
azure
a hybrid lift is where the application
data is moved to azure files
and the application continues to run on
premise we have simplified
cloud deployment so shared application
settings so multiple vms and
developer workstations need to access
the same config files or diagnostic
share we have all vms logged to the file
share developers can
mount and debug all logs in a
centralized place we can dev test and
debug so quickly share tools for
developers needed for local environments
we can do containerization so you can
have azure files to persist volumes for
stateful
uh containers super useful when you're
working with containers
why use azure files instead of setting
up your own file share well shared
access so
already set up to work with the standard
networking protocols it's fully managed
so it's kept up to date with security
patches designed to scale
uh it has scripting tools to automate
the management and creation of file
uh files shared with azure api and
powershell and it has resilience so it's
built to be durable and always
working so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at azure
account storage cheat sheet and this is
a very short section so azure storage
accounts an umbrella service for various
forms of managed storage
you have azure tables blob storage and
files there's of course cued and some
other things in there but these are the
three that we care about
azure blob storage object storage is
distributed across many machines
supports three types so we've got blah
blah so store text and binary data
blocks
of data that can be managed individually
up to 4.7 terabytes
append blocks optimize for append
operations ideal for logging
page blobs store random access files up
to eight terabytes in size
azure files is a fully managed file
share in the cloud to connect
to the file share and network protocols
used either smb
or nfs azure storage explorer a
stand-alone cross-platform app to access
various storage formats
within the azure storage accounts and
there you go
let's talk about business intelligence
tools so bi is both a data analysis
strategy and technology for business
information
the most popular bi tools are tableau
microsoft power bi and
amazon quick quicksite we're going to
obviously be focusing on power bi
because that's what azure would like us
to focus on
bi helps organizations make data-driven
decisions by combining business
analytics data mining data visualization
data tools infrastructure and best
practices and there's the logo of the
three so you know what it is
and now we'll jump into power bi
[Music]
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
we're taking a look at microsoft power
bi which is a business intelligence tool
for visualization business data and
here's a screenshot of the power bi
desktop
and power bi can get a little bit
confusing because they have a lot of
things under the power bi name but i'll
break them down here so it's nice and
clear
so the power bi desktop is a way to
design and adjust reports the power bi
mobile is a
view reports on the go on your phone
power bi service sometimes called the
power bi portal is to access the modify
reports in the cloud
and power bi embedded is a way to embed
power bi components into your
applications
and usually you need to get data into a
power api and so this is one of the most
powerful reasons why people like using
it
it's because it ingests with so many
data sources so in here this is the
desktop one
you go in and you can go under azure and
there's all like every azure service
you'd ever want
if you go to the database tab there's a
lot of database integrations for
postgres mysql
everything it's crazy and so power bi
can directly integrate with azure
services as you saw here
i couldn't be bothered to make a graphic
here but you know here you can see you
can get things from hdinsights sql
databases
account storage machine learning stream
analytics event hubs things like that
uh so just to compare the two because
these are the most important services is
the desktop and the service and they're
very easy to get
mixed up so power bi desktop is a dell
is is a downloadable
free windows application and installed
on a local windows computer if you're on
a mac you cannot use it sorry or linux
either
report uh it can it has report or sorry
so the role that somebody would be using
would be you would be a report designer
and you'd use uh the desktop application
to publish power bi reports
to the power bi service okay and power
bi service is a cloud-based service
where users view and interact with
reports users in power bi service can
edit the reports and create visuals
based on the existing data model
and they can share and collaborate with
co-workers so just looking at the
overlapping services power bi desktop
has many data sources transforming
shaping and modeling measures calculated
columns python themes
rls creation then on the power bi
service side you have some data sources
that you can ingest
dashboards that is the key thing for
power bi services that you get
dashboards you don't get that on the
power bi desktop part
apps and workspaces sharing data flow
creation paginated reports rls
management
gateway connections page reports is
actually with the
builder which you have to download so
i'm not sure why it's in there
both you get reports visualization
security filters bookmarks q a
and r visuals but just make a note here
that you use the
power bi desktop to create reports and
then they're get they can be used
in power bi service to create dashboards
okay
[Music]
let's talk about data visualizations and
chart types and specifically power bi
ones so power bi has
many kinds of visualizations we'll cover
the most common ones but you can see
over here like look at all these little
little squares
that represents all different kinds of
visualizations you can make and even
with them they're highly configurable
okay so let's go and look at bar
and column charts so see how a set of
variables changes across different
categories we've all seen bar charts
it supports stacked ones and bar charts
stacked side by side or horizontal ones
you know the you know what bar charts
are line charts overall
shape of an entire series of values so
they're just lines
uh we have a matrix so that is where you
have a tabular structure that summarizes
the data
you have key influencers the major
contributors to a selected result or
value and that one kind of has a very
cool looking visualization
you have tree map charts of colored
rectangles with size representing the
relative value of each item we have
scatter graphs of represent
relationships between two numerical
values so you have an x and y it's
basically a bunch of dots on a graph
you have bubble chart it's the same
thing but the the dots now are bubbles
and the larger the bubble can represent
a third dimension
you have dot plot charts and these are a
little bit confusing to look at but they
are basically
bubble charts but you they're organized
based on an x-axis so
you're basically putting those into
categories i'm always confused when i
look at that one but that's just one
and one more for us here is a field map
so we have a geographic map where
different areas can be filled
uh so like here you have states of
different colors that represent things
it could be gradients
there's a lot you can do with maps and
geographical maps and that again is not
all the data visualizations but the most
common ones you'll come across
all right let's take a look here at
power bi embedded and honestly this
probably won't show up on the exam
it's just that when you look use azure
and you type in power bi it shows up in
the console
and i was like what is this thing and i
thought this was kind of interesting and
i feel like it's
it's relevant so that's why i have it in
here so azure power bi embedded is a
platform as a service analytics
embedding solution that allows you to
quickly embed visuals reports dashboards
into an application
for independent software vendors it
enables you to visualize application
data rather than
building the service yourself for
developers you embed reports and
dashboards into an application for their
customers
to use azure power bi if you need a
power bi pro user account
you need to create an app workspace and
you need to choose a capacity so either
i guess it'd be like billing work via
capacity based or hourly
metric modes there you go
[Music]
let's take a look at power bi
interactive reports and these
and so basically when you're using power
bi desktop and you can generate reports
in the in the portal or service
but uh the reports are interactive so if
you're getting confusing like there's
power bi reports and interact reports
basically by default everything's
interactive with power bi okay
so here is an example of one i just
downloaded the uh like the example one
that
microsoft provides and as you can see
they uh
like in the middle of it there's like a
little knob so that kind of gives you an
indication of interactivity
or there's like other buttons here so
like if you go here you can actually
click between map and tabular
i believe you can move this range around
just get different information so
they're highly interactive
uh then they're extremely stylized as
you can see you can make them look
really really good
a report can contain many pages and
you can assemble reports as easy as
choosing a visualization and dragging it
out so you take that just drag it out
where you want to go
and customize it from there now
underneath what you can do
is you can see the underlying data so
it's just like tabular data and all the
tables and fields that
populate it and you can and i think with
like a pro version you can modify it
and so you cannot do these with
dashboards so we're using the power bi
service you're not going to get access
to this
when you're looking at data modeling
it's again in power bi desktop
you can see the relationships between
models and modify them and do things
with them
again you cannot do this with dashboards
and that's a key thing you need to
understand between the interactive
reports and the dashboards
let's take a quick look here at power bi
service and also
dashboards which is very important for
this so power bi is a cloud-based
service where users view and interact
with reports where they can create
dashboards and so here
is um a screenshot of me logged into
power bi
if you want to know how to get there you
go app.powerbi.com
and uh if you already have you have to
even if you have a microsoft account you
have to fill in a form and then it
activates the service
and you can go and explore some
dashboards and reports right off the bat
for free so it's very easy to jump into
one of the concepts that's very
important with power bi service is
dashboards and so before we talk about
that let's talk about what a tile is a
tile is a snapshot of data
pinned into your dashboard so here's an
example of data a tile can be created
from a report a data set a different
dashboard
qa q and a box excel sql server
reporting service ssrs
and many many more looking at a
dashboard
is a single page often called a canvas
that tells a
story through a visualization so there
it is the visualizations you can see on
the dashboard
are called tiles you can pin tiles to a
dashboard
from reports okay
[Music]
it is very very very important that we
know the difference between reports and
dashboards so
this isn't going to be a fun slide but
we'll have to go through it and work our
way through so
let's talk about the difference for
capabilities they both have pages but
dashboard has a single page and reports
has multiple pages for data sources
one or more reports you can have one or
more reports and
one or more data sets per dashboard and
for report a single data set per
dashboard for filtering you can't filter
or slice
for filtering out reports many different
ways to filter highlight and slice
you can set alerts for dashboards you
cannot for
reports for features you can set one
dashboard as your featured dashboard
reports there's no such thing as a
featured report
you can see the underlying data set
tables and fields so
absolutely not for dashboards absolutely
yes for reports for customization no
and for reports you got tons of
customization so
there you go
[Music]
all right let's talk about paginated
reports which are reports designed to
fit into page formats so they can be
printed
or shared the data display of all data
are tables which can span multiple pages
so rdls is an xml representation of an
sql server
reporting service so that's an ssrs
report definition file
a report definition contains data
retrieval and layout information for
report pattern reports are just a
visualization
of dot rdl files so power bi report
builder is
used to design pixel perfect remember
that word pixel perfect they really use
that a hundred times
over passionate reports using power bi
report builder
it is a tool specifically designed for
creation of patching reports so if you
want to figure out how to download this
power bi thing
within your power bi service go to the
top right corner
go to download i don't know why that's
animated but it worked out fine
and so once you're in there uh you will
download the file and you'll install
this really
old looking software but i guess the
thing is is that
this is a huge pain point for companies
i guess and they really make a huge
emphasis on it so i guess we need to
know what it is
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the power bi cheat
sheet for the dp900 let's jump into
it so the first is business intelligence
or bi which is both a data analysis
strategy and technology for business uh
information
helps organizations make data driven
decisions
now we're talking about power bi so
power bi desktop a desktop app to design
interactive reports from various data
sources
can be published to the power bi service
then you have the power bi service also
known as the power bi portal
a web app to view reports and create
interactive
shareable dashboards by pinning various
data sets and reports
visualizations you have power bi mobile
a mobile web app to view reports on the
go
power bi report builder a windows app
that builds
pixel perfect printable reports used to
build page data reports
power bi embedded embed power bi
visualizations into web apps
interactive reports reports in power bi
drag visualizations load data for many
data sources both
uh in desktop and and service meaning
like
you can do you can make reports in both
power bi desktop
and power bi service okay paginate
reports
pixel perfect printable report files uh
tabular data laid out in page format
dashboards build shareable dashboards by
pinning various power bi visualizations
a single page report basically
designed for a screen only for the power
bi
service dashboard tiles or just tiles is
a representation or
represent a visualization that has been
pinned to a dashboard
it could be a bunch of other things but
that's what the key thing it is
visualization
of visualization uh is a chart or a
graph that's backed by
it says my but you see by a data set and
whoops we went to the next part but
that's it for power bi
[Music]
all right let's take a look at
structured query language which
stands for sql it's designed to access
maintain data for a relational database
management system on
rdbms we use sql to insert update delete
view data from our data
databases tables and sql can join many
tables
and include many functions to transform
uh the final output of results on the
right-hand side that is a real query
that i use
in my postgres database to um grab exam
sets so if you're on the example
platform and you're doing
a particular set of an exam this query
gets that relative information and
you can see that it's polling if you
look down below here
it's joining in tag information and then
it has like sub queries and stuff so
it's a very complex query
and doing that formatting the sql syntax
was standardized as
iso 9075 that won't show up on your exam
but
it's good to know relational databases
will mostly adhere to the standard while
adding in their
uh not one but own database specific
features
sql's highly transferable skill and we
see sql being used in non-relational
databases
provide a popular and familiar querying
tool so it's something you definitely
want to know how to do
[Music]
all right let's compare olap to oltp so
online transactional processing versus
online analytical processing
when we're talking about ltp we're
generally using databases uh so
databases is built to store its current
transactions and enables fast access to
specific transactions for ongoing
business processing so think of uh you
know any kind of sql server
and then on the right-hand side we have
data warehouses a data warehouse is
built to store large quantities of
historical data and enable fast complex
queries across all the data so when we
visually look at the oltp we have a
bunch of small transactions that are
uh evenly uh distributed so they look
pretty similar in the read and writes
and then for a data warehouse we have
very very few
uh re-transactions and we have
large payloads i think that the arrows
are supposed to be pointing this way
but that's okay it's not a big deal so
when we're talking about databases you
have a single data source you have short
transactions small and simple queries
with an emphasis on rights many
transactions late
it's latency sensitive and you have
small payloads
on the olap side we have multiple data
sources so you're ingesting data
long transactions long and complex
queries with an emphasis on reads
fewer transactions or very few and
throughput
sensitive and large payloads the use
case over here would be general purpose
adding items to your shopping cart would
be an example a use case on the
analytics side would be generating
reports so there you go
all right let's take a look at some open
source relational databases that we know
we are going to definitely encounter on
azure starting with mysql which was
created by my school a b
i believe that's like a switzerland or a
swiss company
and they they're required by sun
microsystems and then they're acquired
by oracle
and mysql was or is an open source
project
uh so mysql is a pure relational
database rdbms it is a simple database
which makes it easy to set up use and
maintain
has multiple storage engines so in odb
and my
ism when it says that there's multiple
they just mean there's two because i
don't know of any other than those two
but it's the most popular relational
database the reason why it's been around
forever it was one of the
earliest mysql databases that was open
source
which is a very important thing to note
um you know and it's just very easy to
use
mario db is a fork of mysql by the
original creators of my
mysql ab after oracle was acquired my
school
uh the uh uh required mysql there was a
concern that oracle may change the
open source licensing or stop future
mysql from being
free to use if you know oracle they'll
like to charge
charge you for their stuff and oracle
has their own database and so
you know there was a lot of fear around
that and the thing is is that when
my sql ab sold their database to sun
microsystems it's because they trusted
sun
but then they didn't know that sun was
going through a lot of financial
difficulties and then literally a year
later
some was acquired by oracle it's just
how it goes eh
so they would have never sold to oracle
originally that's why we have mario db
um then we have postgres which evolved
from ingress
the ingress project at the university of
california postgres is an object-related
relational database so o-r-d-b-m-s
it just has a single storage engine
which i guess is the ingress engine
right here and so it's the most advanced
relational database it can support full
text search table inheritance triggers
rows data types
request slot you know they say the most
advanced i mean it's more advanced than
mysql
postgres is the database i love to use
it's such a great service
i don't understand how it's object
relational i think it's just how they
store the data underneath and that's
what makes it so flexible
but i can tell you that postgres is a
lot easier to use
like initially mysql the syntax is
easier but postgres
in terms of data modeling is a lot
easier because you could just create
columns
you don't have to worry about them
whereas like mysql you gotta fiddle
around with the data types it's very
frustrating or there's like serious
limitations on rows
so yeah that's the two there okay and if
you want to deploy these on
azure it's really simple uh you just
type in the name you go mario
or mysql or postgres and then you just
do azure database for mariodb
and you just launch a server okay
let's talk about read replicas for azure
databases here so a read replica is a
copy of your database
that is kept synced with your primary
database and this additional database is
used to
improve read contention if you've never
heard the word contention before
it means heated disagreement uh so the
idea is that if you have a lot of reads
and it's
and it's hurting the database you can
offload those reads to
your secondary database that's dedicated
specifically for read operations so
re-replicas can be applied to azure sql
and the managed instances so i guess you
can't do it with the azure vms
uh like the virtual machines uh the uh
sql vms that's what they're called
you can have multiple real quicks for a
database i can't remember what the range
is maybe it's between two to six i don't
think that matters for the exam
and just kind of a visual you have your
read and writes that go to your primary
and then
a lot of your reads go to your read
replicas and a very common use case to
have a re-replica is so that you can use
it as an olap when you
are a very small size i'm not going to
talk about an exam but i just know from
a practical standpoint that's something
that i've done
multiple times over the years so there
you go
[Music]
all right let's take a look at scitis on
azure and honestly i don't know if it's
cetus situs sometimes i
want to say citrus but
i could not find a pronunciation for it
so i'm going to call it situs
and it is an open source postgres
extension that transform postgres
into a distributed database and so situs
extends postgres to provide better
support for database sharding
real-time queries multi-tenancy which is
super useful
time time series workloads and if you go
to azure postgres and you see hyperscale
option it really is just using siteis so
um
this is a really really really really
good service if you are using postgres
it's one of the
few reasons i would consider using azure
for my database because i use postgres
as my primary one
this will absolutely not show up on the
exam but i think it's very useful to
know what the service is
[Music]
all right let's take a look at the azure
sql family when we say
sql we're talking about microsoft's
version of sql
and if you search sql you'll see a bunch
of stuff here even more than this
and it can get really confusing but you
absolutely need to know this for the
exam you need to know the difference
between these
three main services so at the top you
have sql server on
azure virtual machines or sql you'll
just see like vm for
escort vm a lot when you need os level
control and access
when you need to lift and shift your
workloads to the cloud
when you have an existing sql license
and you want to save money via the azure
hybrid benefit this is when you're going
to use that okay
if you've never heard the term lift and
shift the idea is that on your
on-premise environment you're running a
virtual machine
that is your database and you can
literally save a virtual image
import that into azure and it runs
exactly how it did
on your on premise so you don't get a
lot of the advantages of the cloud but
the idea is it's the easiest way to get
onto the cloud right
the next option is sql managed instance
this is when you have an existing
database you want to modernize
it's the broadest sql server engine
compatibility highly available just
disaster recovery automated backups
ideal for most migrations to cloud so
the thing is
if you're going to do a lift and shift
um you can
you can kind of go to esco manage so you
probably have to do a transformation
some kind of like etl job or something
to
go into here but the idea is that
there's a lot of different versions of
um of mssql depending on how old it is
and stuff like that so if you aren't
going to be bringing your license or
need os level you really want to be
using this one because you get all the
built-in scalability stuff right
the third one is azure sql database this
is a fully managed sql database designed
to be fault tolerant built
in disaster recovery high of it's highly
available
designed to scale and it's the best
option um
but again you know if you have an older
database maybe you could do a
transformation to it
and then underneath it has sql servers i
thought this was a fourth option but
really when you go to azure sql and
launch it you actually have to create a
server because you can have multiple sql
servers associated to a database
and there's things called like what's it
called like elastic pool or something
like that so
that's just the underlying server for
the azure sql database it's not a
service in itself
but it's just a component of that
service okay even though you can go in
the ui and
and see a list there it makes it really
really really confusing but yeah there
you go
so azure elastic pools is a feature of
azure sql
and it allows you to uh there are simple
cost effective solutions for managing
and scaling multiple databases that have
varying
and unpredictable usage demand so
databases in elastic pool are on a
single server and
share a set number of resources at a set
price elastic pools in azure sql enable
sas developers to optimize the price
performance of a group databases
within a prescribed budget while
delivering performance elasticity for
each database
why would somebody want to do this
because like it doesn't seem like a good
practice to put a bunch of
databases on a single server it's more
like you'd rather want a database to be
distributed across
servers so if you're running a sas
product
software's a service you'll have
multi-tenancy meaning that each person
has their own database
there's different levels of tenancy but
if you did give let's say you had a
company and
um or like you had five large clients
and they use the same software and
they're all varying sizes
but they're not large enough to justify
their own server this would be
the service for you right where you are
constantly spinning up databases per
customer
but i don't think i would ever use this
in practicality and i am a multi-tenant
sas but
uh it's nice that they provide that
option so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are on to the relational database
cheat sheet
uh and so let's jump into it so
structure query language sql designed to
access and maintain data for a
relational database management system
online transaction processing keyword
there is transactions so frequent and
short queries for transactional
information so databases any kind of
generic
a workload or web app online analytical
processing so complex queries for large
databases to produce reports and
analytics so
think data warehouse onto the
open source relational databases we've
got mysql a pure relational database
easy to set up most popular open source
relation relational database definitely
something i started off with mariodb
is a fork of mysql postgres is an object
relational database now my favorite
relational database to use is more
advanced and well liked
among developers read replicas is a
duplicate of your database
in sync with the main to help to reduce
reads on your primary database
now talking about azure sql it's an
umbrella service for uh
for different offerings of mssql
databases hosting services
so we have sql vm so for lift and shift
when you want os access and control or
you need to bring your own license for
azure hybrid benefit manage sql for lift
and shift when your broadest
when you need the broadest amount of
compatibility with sql versions mssql in
particular
you can use uh manage sql on on premise
by
using azure arc it gives you many of the
benefits of a fully managed database but
it's not as good as
the azure sql database which is a fully
managed sql database
has a few options here you can run it as
a single server run it as a database
which is a collection of servers
run in an elastic pool so databases of
different sizes residing
on this on one server to save cost
then we have connection policies so we
have three modes we got default so
choose proxy or default initially
depending if the server is within or
outside the azure network we have proxy
outside the azure network
proxy through a gateway it's important
to remember to listen on port
1443 this might show up on your exam so
remember this
port 1443 when connecting via proxy mode
through a gateway outside the azure
network and then last is redirect
redirected with the azure network and
that's the recommended way to do it
and i just want to point out for these
three here i didn't write it in here but
remember that this one here is for
infrastructures code this one is for
platform as a service and this one's for
platform as a service okay
right let's talk about tsql which stands
for transact sql and it's a set of
programming extensions
from sybase and microsoft that added
feature several features to the
structured query language if you've
never heard of sybase
i think the original company that
actually made the microsoft sql database
and then maybe microsoft bought them out
or et cetera
but there's a long history there so tsql
expands on the sql standard to include
procedural programming local variables
very
various support functions for string
processing date processing mathematics
changes to the delete and update
statements
for the microsoft sql servers there are
five groups of sql commands and honestly
there's five groups for regular sql
actually normally they'll just say even
for this exam they're only going to
tell you of about the definition
manipulation one but i'm going to tell
you all of them because you should know
all of them it really helps to know them
so the first is data definition language
so this is
ddl used to define the database schema
we have data query language dql used for
performing queries
on the data data manipulation language
dml
manipulation of the data in the database
data control language dcl
rights permissions and controls of the
database transaction control language
tcl
transactions within the database and so
now that we've covered what tsql is
let's dive in and actually look at all
these types of documents
let's start off with the data definition
language which is
sql syntax commands for creating and
modifying the database or database
objects
so tables index views stored procedures
functions and triggers
the first is the create command here and
so
we can create a database or database
object so here you would just say
create whatever it is you want to create
table database etc
so here we're creating a table called
users and we're providing those
fields okay then we have alter so this
alters the structure of an existing
database so alter table
whatever it is the table and then we can
add a column
if we want to drop the database that
deletes all the objects from the
database truncate would just delete the
records within the database
comments is just a comment and rename is
if we want to
rename a database object now this is
what's interesting here where we have
execute sp rename so when we said that
tsql
extends this is its own little special
language because in other
other sql variants it definitely does
not look like that okay
[Music]
let's take a look at data manipulation
language dml and so this is going to
have to do with anything with
manipulating data so the first thing is
we have an insert command
to be able to uh insert data so here you
can see we say
the values we want and if you're
wondering how does it know what values
it's going to be the order
in which the column appears in the in
the actual table that's how it knows
that
andrew goes under first name and email
goes like the email goes into the email
field
then for update this is uh when we want
to update existing
materials so we'll say update users then
we'll have to
say where so we want to match the id 8
update user 8
and then we'll set the values that we
want to change then we can delete a user
very simple delete from users where id
equals 6 merge or upsert to insert or
update records at the same time i don't
see these in other languages so i think
it might be a tsql specific thing
it's kind of hard to show this because
they're very large queries but if you
need to do an insert and update at the
exact same time you use this
then you have call this allows you to
call proceed or
java sub programs basically functions so
let's say you need to cal you made a
function
uh to calculate the distance between
toronto and chennai uh you could uh do
that
you have lock table and this is for
concurrency control to ensure two people
are not writing to the
to the program at the same time okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at the
data query language dql and the first
thing we have is the select and by the
way
every if it's query that means it has
everything to do with selecting data
okay
so here what we're going to do is select
the these particular fields and do
from users if we want to get all fields
we can just do an asterisk here
um but that's the idea is like i want
these fields from this users
you could even say like where and other
stuff in there we have show so this
describes what a table looks like
most other languages like by school
would just say like show and then the
table name
but here again we have that these kind
of weird exec
sp columns thing which again is a tsql
specific thing
and so show would describe what the
table looks like so what columns is
contained okay
we have explained plans so returns the
query plan of a microsoft azure synapse
analytics sql statement without running
the statement
this thing is really complicated i could
not show you an example there but you
know that's what it does
help is just like i want to understand
more information about database objects
so here you're asking more information
about
the user's table again this is the
special tsql stuff
all right let's take a look here at data
control and this has to do with
well control right so we have grant
saying i have a
i have a table called employees i'm only
going to let the
ts google user or the uh mssql user
andrew only be able to select insert
update and delete on
then you have revoke and that's the
opposite let's just say you know we
don't want baker to be able to delete
anything on the employees table
and that's pretty much it
[Music]
let's take a look here at transaction
control language tcl so tcl commands are
used to manage transactions in a
database transactions is when you need
multiple things to happen and if they
don't all happen then you roll back on
them okay
so this is really important in finance
where you have multiple people that have
to be part of the purchasing decision
and if all purchases don't follow
through then you don't want to commit
that
transaction okay so we have command so
set to permanently save any transaction
to the database
rollback restores the database to the
last committed state
save point used to temporarily save a
transaction so that you can roll back to
this
to the point whenever necessary set
transactions specify characteristics for
the transaction
[Music]
all right just a quick review of all the
sql documents we or syntax documents we
just looked at
and so we had ddl which is for defining
dml which is for manipulating dql which
is for querying dcl which is for
controlling
and tcl which is for transacting now i
highlighted ddl and dml in red because
these are what the exam will focus on
and sometimes they simplify
they'll take things like that that go in
um
like select and they'll just put it in
manipulation okay so these are the two
main ones that you'd have to choose
between but i wanted to show you all
five of them because this is really what
sql is based off of
uh and so you know this is just the
right way of looking at it
this is not an exhaustive list of all
the possible commands but it was what i
could terry pick out that i recognized
that i was familiar with
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are on to the tsql cheat sheet so
transact sql is a set of programming
extensions from scibase and microsoft
that adds several
features to the structured query
language this is used for
ms sql databases okay for mss google
servers there are five groups of esco
commands
and so we have data definition language
used to define the database schema
data query language used for performing
queries on data data manipulation
language
manipulation of data in the database
data control language
rights permissions and other controls of
the database
transaction control language tcl
transactions within the database so
on the exam they're going to ask you
either this or this they don't bother
with all of them but
they're actually r5 okay and so uh
that's all you need to know here
[Music]
let's talk about connectivity
architecture so when a connection from a
server to a
azure sql database the client will
connect to a gateway that listens on
port 1443 and i want to remember that
port number because it's an important
part number that might show up on your
exam
okay so over here on the right hand side
we have a virtual machine connecting to
various different sql servers and so
the idea here is that based on the
connection policy the gateway will grant
traffic and route access to the
appropriate database so we actually have
three kinds of policies we got proxy
so connections are proxy through a
gateway increased latency and reduced
throughput
intended for workloads connecting from
outside the azure network
redirect which is mostly recommended
establishes a direct connection reduced
latency improved throughput
intended for workloads connecting inside
the azure network and default
which is just going to default if you
launch a vm outside the azure network
it's going to use proxy if you launch it
within the azure network it's going to
use redirect so this thing this port for
1443 is only important when you're doing
proxy
because if you're internal you don't
need to go through that port there's no
gateway to pass through
but yeah that is just the different
kinds of connection policies there
[Music]
all right so let's take a look here at
ms sql database authentication so during
the setup of your mss google database
you must select an authentication mode
you've got two options here
windows authentication mode which
enables both windows authentication and
disables sql server authentication
and mixed mode which enables both
windows authentication and sql server
authentication
so if you were to remote into your
windows machine and under your server
properties look under security and
server authentication
there are those two options
interestingly they don't call it mixed
mode in the ui
but that's what it is it's called mix
mode so let's talk about
what windows authentication and sql
server authentication is so windows
authentication which is
the recommended way is specific windows
users and groups
group accounts are trusted to log into
the sql server and
very and this is the most secure and
easy way to modify revoke privileges
because you know if they're windows
users that means that you can then
manage them from azure active directory
right
then you have sql server authentication
so we have a username and password which
is set and stored on the primary
database
you cannot use a kerberos security
protocol so that's one
disadvantage login password must be
passed over the network
at the time of connection so that's an
additional attack vector but this is an
easier way to connect to the database
from outsider domain or from a web-based
interface so
it's just going to be based on the uh
the scenario that you're in but if you
can just
stick with windows authentication
[Music]
let's take a look here at network
connectivity so for your sql database
you need to choose either a public or
private endpoint
a public endpoint is reachable outside
the azure network over the internet
and you would use firewall rules to
protect your database for private
endpoints
you're uh they're only reachable within
the azure network or connecting
uh or originating from inside the
network so you would use azure private
links to keep your
traffic network within the azure network
so here's just the two options you would
see
when you provision your database you'll
just see here that you choose either
public or private
and you're setting firewall rules or
you're creating private endpoints okay
[Music]
well let's take a look here at azure
defender for sql which is a unified
package for advanced
sql security capabilities and what it
does is vulnerability assessment and
advanced threat protection so
azure defender is available for azure
sql the manage instance
and synapse analytics and what it does
is it discovers and classifies sensitive
data or classify sensitive data
surfacing and
mitigating potential database
vulnerabilities detecting anomalous
activities and you can turn it on at any
time and you just pay a monthly cost
within the azure portal so there you go
let's take a look at azure database
firewall rules so
azure databases are protected by server
firewalls a server firewall is an
internal firewall
that resides on the database server all
connections are rejected by default
to the database so once your database is
provisioned you have an
option where you click server firewall
and what you're going to do is configure
it so you'll say
here i allow azure so i give zero zero
zero zero zero zero
and notice also the connection policy
remember we talked about that before so
you can set proxy or
redirect um and so there's that there
and then if you wanted to do it via tsql
you could as well this is
allow only allow the server at zero
point four at zero zero zero point four
because you can specify your range
there is azure firewalls which is uh a
totally different service and then
there's network security groups
which it which is like a logical
firewall around your uh
vm or your i'm sorry around your
nic cards and the subnet but uh this is
the one we were talking about here which
is
the server firewalls for azure databases
okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
always encrypted which is a feature that
encrypts columns in the azure sql
database or sql server
so if you had a column like a credit
card number and you wanted to always
keep it encrypted
you'd use always encrypted and so always
encrypted uses two types of keys
we have column encryption keys which are
used to encrypt the data in an encrypted
column and call them master keys a key
uh protecting the key that encrypts one
or more column encryption keys
and you can always uh uh you can al you
can apply
always encrypted using tsql and so since
there is a key that encrypts the key
that is called
envelope encryption and that is a great
way of doing that i imagine that maybe
it gets stored in eks or whatever the
name of the service
that azure calls for their encryption
keys
let's take a look here at roll base
access control specifically for
databases so
role based asset controls is when you
apply roles to users to grant them
fine grade actions for specific azure
services and there's four
in particular that we really do care
about here uh to databases
and this is and this will probably show
up on your exam so you definitely need
to know these
we have sqldbcontributor so this role
allows you to manage
sql databases but not access them can't
manage their security related policies
or their parent sql servers
you have sql managed instance
contributor this is so you can manage
sql managed instances and required
network configuration can't give
access to others sql security manager
manage the security related policies of
sql servers and databases
but not access to the sql servers and
last
is sql server contributor manage sql
servers and databases but not access
not have access to them those sql
servers okay
so our bacs you definitely want to know
these four okay
[Music]
let's take a look here at transparent
data encryption tde
which encrypts data at rest for
microsoft databases it can be applied to
server sql
uh or sql servers azure sql databases
azure synapse analytics
tde does real-time io encryption and
decryption of
data logs and files encryption uses a
database encryption
key called a dek data database boot
record stores the key for availability
during recovery
the d e key the d e k is a symmetric key
so it's the same cryptographic key for
both
of the encryption uh of plain text and
decryption of ciphertext
just to give you a visual there to help
you out the idea is you have something
that's plain text you use the same key
to encrypt it
and then the same key to decrypt it and
that's just how that works
so the steps to apply tdd to database
create a database master key create a
certificate
to support the tde create the database
encryption key
enable tde on the database so that's
just how you do it there
within the azure portal and there you go
[Music]
before we start talking about what
dynamic data masking is let's define
what is data masking this is when a
request for data is transformed
to match the sensitive data so imagine
you have a credit card here
and you do not want to expose that to
particular users maybe there are
part of your support team or or even the
end user themselves and so the idea is
that
it's in the database it's stored in its
raw format it's untransformed but what
it'll do is pass through
a masking service and that will have
different rules on it which will then
apply a particular filter so here we'll
only show the last three so dynamic data
masking which is a feature of
a particular azure sql servers
anyway can be applied to azure sql and
manage instances and synapse
um and so the idea is you would just
turn this feature on and then you create
a
masking policy so you could say exclude
a particular user for masking so like
let's say you have
like root users admin users that need to
see all the data you can do that
you make masking rules so what fields
should be masked and then you have
masking functions so how to apply
the masking field so here this would be
a masking function that would
say okay only show the last three
letters okay
let's take a look at private links so
azure private links allows you to
establish secure connections between
azure resources so traffic remains
within the azure network
so here's a big graphic of what that
looks like and the idea is that you have
a private link endpoint
uh which is just a network interface
that connects you privately and securely
to a service powered by
azure private link and private endpoints
uses a private ip address for your vnet
so many azure services by default work
with private link
and third party providers can be powered
by private link as well private link
service which allows you to connect your
own workloads to private link
you may need an azure standard internal
load bouncer to associate with the link
service
but the idea here is that if you have
your sql server
right that way you can connect it to
your on-premise
loads or if you have an sql server on
your on-premise and you want to do it to
a vm
that's what you're going to use okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
we are on to database security for
azure the dp900 so let's jump into it so
mssql database authentication
we have two modes when setting it up
when you're
remoting into a windows machine so you
have windows authentication mode which
enables windows authentication and
disables
sql server authentication and we have
mix mode where it enables
both of these things what are these
things well windows authentication
is when you authenticate via windows
users and sql server authentication is
between the user and password you can
connect from anywhere
windows authentication is the
recommended one because it's just more
secure
for network connectivity we have public
endpoints so they're reachable outside
the azure network over the internet
you use server firewalls for production
and you have private endpoints so only
reachable with the azure network so use
azure private links to keep traffic
within the azure network
azure defender sql a unified package for
advanced sql
server security capabilities for
vulnerability assessment and
advanced threat protection server
firewall rules an internal firewall that
resides on the database server all
connections are rejected by default
uh to the database always encrypted a
feature that encrypts columns
in an azure sql database or sql server
role-based access controls for databases
so these are roles you need to know the
sql db contributor manages
sql database but not access them can
can't manage their security related
policies or their parent sql servers sql
managed instance contributor manage
esql instances and require network
configuration
configuration can't can't give access to
others
sql security manager manage the security
related policies of sql servers
databases
but not access to sql servers and the
last is sql
server contributor manage sql servers
and databases but not access
to them to the sql servers okay
you have transparent data encryption td
encrypts data at rest for microsoft
databases in many cases it's already
turned on for you
dynamic data masking you can choose your
database columns
that will be masked obscured for
specific users azure private links
allows you to establish secure
connections between azure resources
so traffic remains within the azure
network i should have put one underneath
but this is generally if you want to
also connect in a hybrid connection
okay so there you go
[Music]
let's take a look at what a key value
store is so
a key value store is a data store that
is really dumb but it's
super super fast okay and so they'll
lack features that you would normally
see in relational databases like
relationships indexes aggregation
transactions all sorts of things
but you know there is a trade-off for
that speed okay and so
here is kind of a representation of a
key value store which
you have a key which is a unique you
know key to identify the value
and i'm representing the value as a
bunch of ones and zeros because i want
you to understand that there aren't
really
columns it's just key and value so the
idea is that imagine that
those ones and zeros actually represent
a dictionary and that's usually what
they are is it associative array hash
dictionary underneath
okay and so even though it looks like
you know what i mean like if this was a
relational database you know you could
see these as kind of like columns
and so if we kind of did that that's how
a key value store
can kind of mimic um you know a tabular
data right
but the thing is is that you know there
is no consistency between
the the rows hence it is schema-less
but that's kind of a way to get tabular
data from key values but due to their
simple design they can scale
well well beyond relational databases so
relational databases it becomes very
hard to shard them and do a bunch of
other stuff with them
but key value stores are super easy to
scale but you know
they come with a lot of extra
engineering around them because of these
missing features
all right let's talk about document
stores so document store is a nosql
database that stores document as its
primary data structure a document could
be an xml
but it's most commonly json or json like
structure and documents
stores are sub classes of key value
stores
so the components of a document store
compared to relational database looks
like this
so the idea is that you have tables is
now collections rows or documents
columns or fields indexes are still the
same name and when you do joins they're
called embedding and linking
so you know if a key value store can
kind of store this why would you do it
well there's just a lot more features
around the documents itself and so you
know how we saw key value store didn't
have
like it had like nothing like no
functionality well document store brings
a lot more of the functionality that
you're used to in a relational database
you know and so it makes things a little
bit easier to work with okay
[Music]
all right let's take a quick look here
at mongodb which is an open source
document database which stores json-like
documents and the primary data structure
for mongodb is called a bson
so a binary json is a subset of json so
its data structure is very similar
to json but it's designed to be both
efficient and storage
in both storage space and scan speed
compared to json
and bson has more data types than json
has date times byte arrays regular
expressions md5
binary data javascript code json's just
strings integers and arrays it's very
very simple uh but because it has all
these
new other data types and it's stored in
this binary format it's not plain text
it's actually binary data
that's the one reason why it the storage
space and the scan speed is so fast
now if you were to use javascript to
perform an operation like say
insert data this is what it would look
like so you have kind of an idea that
you're inserting items into a collection
there okay
just to list out some features of
mongodb it supports searches against
fields range queries regular expressions
it supports primary and secondary
indexes it's highly available
it's it's high availability can be
obtained via rep replica sets
so replica to offload reads or access
standby in case of failover
momodube scales horizontally using
sharding mongodb can run multiple
servers via load bouncing mongodb can be
used as a file system
which is called grid fs with load
balancing and data replication
features over multiple machines uh for
storing files mongodb provides three
ways to perform aggregation
uh grouping dat and aggregation's just
grouping data to return a query so
aggregation pipeline map reduce
single purpose aggregation mongodb
supports fixed collections called
capped collections i'm going to become
claims to support
multi-document asset transactions so
mongodb when it first came out didn't do
all this stuff
and people complained about it i like it
being very hard to scale but now it's a
lot easier to use so
you know mongodb is something that is uh
more uh
a more popular option nowadays than it
was a few years ago so there you go
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at what
a graph database is so graph database is
a database composed of data structures
that use vertices nodes or dots which
form relationships to other vertices via
edges arcs and lines so some use cases
here fraud detection real-time
recommendations engines master data
management network and it operations
identity and access management
and there's a lot they're saying like
it's really really good for that i
am something i want to look into later
traceability and manufacturing contact
tracing
data lineage for gdpr customer 360
degree analysis
like for marketing product
recommendations social media graphing
and
feature engineering for ml so let's just
kind of break down
you know the little components here so
what you'd have is a node
and a node can contain data properties
and then through that it would have a
relationship
through an edge and that relationship
can have a direction and also data
properties on it
and so it's a lot more um verbose
like in than a relational database and
also just how it can point to stuff so
uh super useful uh for particular use
cases
[Music]
let's take a look here at azure tinker
pop which is a graph computing framework
for both graph databases
oltps and graph analytics systems olaps
so tinker pop enables developers to use
a vendor agnostic distributed framework
to traverse
query many different graph systems they
always say traverse because there's so
many
it's a tree right so there's a lot of
databases that this thing connects to
and so here they all are but the ones i
want to indicate to you that are
important
is amazon neptune cosmodb hadoop via
spark neo4j which
is one of the most popular graphing
databases orient db
and titan okay so the thing is is that
this
isn't a graph database it is
a basically adapter to other graph
databases
and ticker pop includes a graph
traversal language called gremlin which
is the single language that can be used
for all these graph systems so let's
talk about gremlin gremlin is a graph
traversal language for
apache tinker pop and so it looks like
this and sometimes uh you know like even
without tinker pop
i think this is with cosmodb that
they'll support this language by default
so you don't necessarily need to have
tinker pop to work with some databases
but it's great to have that service if
you if or like the framework if you need
it
so gremlin is is designed to write once
and run anywhere
w-o-r-a gremlin traversal can be
evaluated as a real-time query
so lltb or a batch analytics query so
over here it's just kind of showing you
these are the oltps
graph databases over here and then on
the right-hand side we have
olaps okay and so gremlin hosted
language embedding means you can use
your favorite programming language
when you write gremlin okay so there you
go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at azure tables which
is a type of storage for nosql key value
data store within the azure storage
accounts
azure table stores non-relational
structured data with a schema-less
design
and there are two ways to interact with
azure tables through the storage
table storage api or microsoft azure
storage explorer which i find is the
easiest way
to interact with it so just kind of
looking at storage explorer there if you
wanted to add an entry
you'd have to provide a partition key
which is a unique identify
fire for the partition with a given
table and a row key a unique identifier
for an
entity within a given partial a
partition and so you have all your data
types here so we see string boolean
binary data type
double uh guids 32 and 64.
if we wanted a query you'd have to query
along the partition and row key
so you could also do some additional
filtering here so just notice here
that you know you have your partition
key you put in your value like klingon
and
wharf and then this is not this is just
additional properties you added
a lot of time the way these key values
work is that
this will return the results like all
the results and then
server side and then client-side these
will be filtered client-side i don't
know if that's the case with azure table
but that's generally how these things
work
and so there you go
[Music]
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
we're looking at cosmodb which is a
service
for fully managed no school databases
that are designed to scale
and be highly performant so cosmodb
supports different kinds of nosql
database engines
which you interact via an api so we have
the coresql which is their document
datastore
their azure cosmodb api for mongodb
their azure table
and gremlin okay and this will be using
uh probably tinker pop
um so all of these nosql engines uh
specify capacity so you can do provision
throughput for
pay for guarantee of capacity or
serverless pay for what you use
so if you are just playing around with
the service you can go ahead and choose
that serv
serverless option and so a lot of times
when people talk about cosmodb they're
usually talking about core sql so if you
say
cosmodb it's usually document but
understand that there's a bunch of stuff
underneath it
now if you want to start viewing data
and making stuff and playing around with
it you'd use the cosmodb explorer
which is a web interface that you can
find at cosmos.azure.com so after you
made your cosm
db cluster or container whatever they
call it then
you could go access your database so
here we have the esql api
and so that would be the document store
and you could just see here that
we have we've created a new item here
for that data
okay and so i just want to show you that
if you drop down here you choose
container or database so we create a new
container
um also if you are in um
azure it looks like they just have it
here under the data explorer tab so it's
the same thing
it's the cosmo db explorer just in line
okay so you don't have to like
go to that url you could just click into
your um your
it's called account cosmodb account and
go to data explorer
i just wanted to show you here like if
you made a graph database that you can
do everything through this explorer for
all the different types
the interface will change a bit so here
we'd add a new vertex right and it's
just
slightly different okay
[Music]
all right so the thing about azure
tables is that you can
use it within either cosmodb
okay or you can use it within account
storage and the thing is is that
um it's a really good comparison to look
at these two things because
this way we can really understand like
how powerful cosmodb is all right
so what we'll do is compare the two so
over here when you have azure tables in
account storage it's fast but it has no
upper bounds of latency
for azure cosmodb it's going to give you
single digit millisecond latency for
reason writes
for throughputs it's variable throughput
it's limited to 20 000 operations you
get a guaranteed
uh backed by an sla and no upper limits
when you're using cosmo
db for global distribution it's a single
region
and for cosmic db you have 30 plus
regions for indexing you only get the
primary index or partition and row
no secondary indexes and then for
cosmodb you get automatic and complete
indexing in all properties
no index management for green you get
query execution
uses index for primary key and scans
otherwise and for
uh cosmodb you get queries that can take
advantage of automatic indexing on
properties for fast query times for
consistency we got strong with primary
region
and eventual with secondary regions and
with uh cosmodb
there's like five you know what i mean
there's just uh the consistent levels
are a lot more flexible okay
for pricing it's consumption based and
then for
cosmodb you have consumption base or
provision capacity for the slas it's
99.99
availability and here it it's backed by
an sla but some conditions it does not
apply
okay so you know hopefully that shows
you that cosmic db
like is very performant is globally
available uh single digit millisecond
and i i really feel like this is to
compete with um
adabus um dynamodb because it sounds so
similar to dynamodb but yeah there you
go
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are on to the azure tables and
cosmos db cheat sheet for the dp900
i want to point out something uh that
i'm sure you already know about but in
the course i spelt cosmos db without the
s
like everywhere and i'm not going to go
back and fix that
but i know i'm going to hear like never
the end of it for like the next year
okay
so let's start at the top here azure
tables it's a key value data store
can be hosted on either azure storage
account storage it is designed for a
single region
and single table can be hosted on cosmos
db
and when it's hosted here it's designed
for scale across multiple regions
cosmodb a fully managed nosql service
that supports multiple nosql engines
called apis why they didn't call them
engines i don't know
coresql api this is the default one it's
a document database
you can use sql to query documents and
when people are talking about cosmodb
that's what they're talking about the
document database the default one okay
graph apis a graph database you can use
with gremlin to transfer traverse the
nodes and edges mongodb api a mongodb
database
it is a document database tables ai is
just as your table's key value but
within cosmodb
apache tinkerpop an open source
framework to have an agnostic way to
talk to many graph databases they
probably won't ask you about tinkerpop
on the exam
gremlin graph traversal language to
traverse nodes and edges you definitely
need to know what gremlin is
and be used to seeing what it is like
identify what it looks like
mongodb an open source document database
and the way
it works is it has its own um data
structure it's document structure called
bson which is binary.json json a storage
and compute
optimized version of json introduces new
data types
cosmo db explorer a web ui to view
cosmos databases and there you go
[Music]
so what is apache hadoop well it's an
open source framework for distributed
processing of large data sets hadoop
allows you to distribute large data sets
across many servers
and computing queries across many
servers so htms and mapreduce were the
first
features that were launched with hadoop
way back in the day in version one
and since then there's a lot more
services now but the idea behind
distributed
processing is the idea is the idea is
that your computer servers do not need
to be on specialized hardware you can
run them on common hardware and that's
actually how google
back in the day like uh there's a story
over google they just kept on like
adding like all random machines to build
up their search engine didn't matter
what it was
and that eventually became the hadoop
system so apache dupe framework has the
following so hadoop common collections
of common utilities and libraries that
support other hadoop modules
hadoop distributed file system a
brazilian and redundant file storage
distributed on
clusters of common hardware hadoop
mapreduce writes apps that can
process multi terabyte data in parallel
on large clusters of common hardware
hbase a distributed scalable big data
store yarn manage resources nodes
containers and perform scheduling
hive used for generating reports using
sql
pig a high level scripting language to
write complex data transformations
if they sound like they do the same
thing they absolutely do they're just
slightly different
hadoop can integrate with many other
open source projects via the hadoop
components and we're going to see a lot
of those open source
things here in a moment
let's take a look here at apache kafka
which is an open source streaming
platform to create high performance data
pipelines streaming analytics data
integration and mission critical
applications absolutely the number one
streaming service though it is open
source so you have to find a way to uh
to host it
kafka was originally developed by
linkedin and open source in 2011.
coffee was written in scala and java so
to use kafka you're going to be writing
java code
here is just kind of a diagram of how it
works so you got producers consumers and
topics so
in kafka data is stored in partitions on
a cluster which can span multiple
machines which makes it distributed
computing
producers publish messages in a key and
value format using kafka producer api
and consumers can listen for messages
and consume using the
the cough consumer api messages are
organized into topics producers will
push messages to topics and consumers
will listen on topics
so there you go
so azure hd insights is a managed
service to run popular open source
analytics services so here's kind of a
graphic of how it works
and hdinsight supports the following
frameworks apache hadoop which is
it which is what it is it's the entire
system apache spark
kafka storm hive hbase and
lap and i also can run our workloads
hdinsights
has broad range of scenarios such as etl
data warehousing
machine learning internet of things just
because you can put in so many things
here and so
you know hdinsights is just a managed
version of hadoop and
it just makes it really easy to to do
stuff so you can consume stuff run these
in
clusters so i think these are each
called a cluster for whatever you're
running and they can go
out out to somewhere now once you launch
hdinsights
you can use the apache ambari which is
an open source hadoop management web
portal to provision manage and monitor
your hadoop clusters
and so when you create a cluster you're
going to get one by default it's just
under here where it says
cluster dashboard and the idea here is
you'll see all the types
like htf map reduce all the stuff here
and it just makes it really easy to
interact with hadoop okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and welcome to the hadoop cheat sheet
for the dp900 let's jump into it so
apache hadoop is an open source
framework for distributed processing of
large data sets
and underneath it has the hadoop
distributed file system hdfs a resilient
and redundant file storage
that's distributed on clusters of common
hardware
you have mapreduce which writes apps
that can process
multi-terabytes data in parallel on
large clusters of common hardware
hbase a distributed scalable big data
store yarn managed resources nodes
containers perform scheduling
hive used for generating reports using
an esco language
pig a high level scripting language to
write complex data transformations
apache spark can perform is 100 times
faster in memory and 10 times faster
than disk
than hadoop supports etl streaming and
ml flows
you can run that on hadoop that's i just
did not put it under the um
i debated whether i should put it in in
line or there but that's where i put it
apache uh kafka a streaming pipeline
analytics service
hd insights a managed service to run
popular open source analytics services
it is fully managed hadoop system so
it's just hadoop but managed by
azure there so there you go that's the
chi chi
[Music]
apache spark is an open source unified
analytics engine for big data
and machine learning and spark lets you
run workloads much much faster than
hadoop though you can run it in the
hadoop system okay
so 100 times faster in memory 10 times
faster than disk
and which is why spark is being
described as lightning fast so when it
says hadoop you know it's
talking about hive and pig and the other
things that usually come along with
hadoop and so apache spark is a
collection of libraries that work well
together to form an analytics ecosystem
so we have the spark core this is the
underlying engine and api the api
supports the following programming
languages r
sql python scala and java you have spark
sql which introduces a data structure
called a data frame
not the same thing as a pandas data
frame but they're just called the same
thing okay
which can be used with uh dsls to work
with structures and semi-structured data
you have spark streaming allows spark to
ingest data from many
streaming services so hdfs flume kafka
twitter
kinesis you have graph x so distributed
graph processing framework you have
machine learning the mlib library
and this is a distributed machine
learning framework with common machine
learning statistical algorithms
the way you are going to interact with
spark is through resilient distributed
data set rdd
which is a dsl to execute various
parallel operations on the property
spark
cluster so here are some common
functions map
filter distinct count min max mean
paralyzed you get the idea
and here's an example of rdd api so just
notice here
um i think basically all of these are
are
those functions right so that just makes
it really easy to transform and work
with data okay
[Music]
so databricks is a software company
specializing in providing fully managed
apache spark clusters and the company
founders were the creators of the apache
spark
delta lake and ml flow open source
projects and databricks has two
main offerings the database pro platform
and so david's cloud
based spark platform with an easy to use
web ui
where you can launch fully managed spark
clusters launch notebooks to write code
and interact with spark create
workspaces to collaborate with team
members and role-based
access controls create jobs for etl or
data analysis tasks that run immediately
or on schedule
create ml workflows and is available on
all main
cloud service providers aws azure and
gcp
they also have the database community
edition which is a free version of the
databricks platform for educational use
create a free michael cluster that
terminates after two hours when idle
no workspace jobs or rbac so really it's
just
a subset of the one above so
azure databricks is a partnership
between microsoft and databricks to
offer the database platform within the
azure portal running on azure compute
services
and it offers two environments
workspaces and so basically this is just
the azure database
platform with integrations to azure data
related services for building big
pipelines
so if you need to do batching you can
use azure data factory streaming
apache kafka event hub iot storage azure
blob storage
azure data like storage the other side
of it is azure database sql analytics
run sql queries on your data lake create
multiple visualization types to explore
your query results build and share your
dashboards
now if you want to launch a databricks
workspace it's really easy
all you got to do is create a workspace
and choose your plan launch a workspace
use sso to connect to it and start your
datablex platform so if you go up here
and this is in the azure portal with
azure databricks we'll just choose which
one we want
and then we launch the workspace it'll
sso in and then you're in there
okay so um you know basically if you
launch it's not going to cost you any
money so if you want to play around with
it you can do that
or if you're really antsy you can just
go to the
databricks website and try the community
edition because there's risk there's no
risk of
spending any money when using that okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
we're taking a look here at the apache
spark and data bricks cheat sheet so
let's jump into it so apache spark is an
open source unified analytics engine for
big data and machine learning it's a
hundred times faster in memory than
hadoop
ten times faster than disk than hadoop
can perform etl so batch
streaming and ml workloads uh for the
apache ecosystem it's composed of spark
core which is the underlying engine api
spark sql you use sql it also has a new
data structure called a data frame to
work with data spark streaming which is
a way to ingest data from many streaming
services graph x distributed graph
processing framework
mlib a distributed machine learning
framework there's also rdd it's a domain
specific dsl
to execute various parallel operations
on apache spark clusters
then we're talking about data bricks
here it's a software company
specializing at providing fully
managed apache spark clusters we have
azure databricks a partnership between
microsoft and database to offer
the the databricks platform with within
the azure portal running on
azure compute services azure database
offers two environments we have
the databricks workspace so this is the
databricks platform with integrations to
azure
data related services for building data
pipelines if you
went to azure or sorry if you went to
databricks website and signed up it's
the same portal okay
azure database sql analytics run your
query on your data lake
and i believe that this is basically
azure synapse analytics so that's the
engine that's in there okay
take a look here at sql management
studio also known as ssms
which is an id for managing any sql
infrastructure if you take a good look
at the screenshot
you can see that it allows us to work
with databases write sql statements
and that's pretty much it so access can
access configure manage administer and
develop all components of sql server
azure sql database azure synapse
analytics and it has a few components in
it so we have object explorer view and
manage all objects in one or more
instances of sql server template
explorer build and manage files
for boilerplate text that you can use to
speed the development of queries and
scripts
and this is deprecated but you might
hear about it so i just mentioned it
here and this is
build projects used to manage
administration items such as scripts and
queries so
not a complicated service but uh yeah
there you go
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
server data tools ssdt which transforms
data development by introducing
ubiquitous
declarative models that span all phases
of development phases within
visual studio so this is a visual studio
tool like azure basically has
like a tool for everything like it'll be
the same tool but it will be repurposed
for
their different other tooling products
and this one's for visual studio so
i don't have a great internal screenshot
but you can see that it works with
um it has a few different components
inside there and analysis reporting
integrations
so it uses ss transact so tsql to build
debug maintain refactor databases also
provides a table designer for creating
editing tables in either database
projects connected database instances be
able to view control data
loaded files easy to publish to escrow
database or sql server
has an object explorer offers a view of
your database similar to sql
ssm mess allows you to lightly
duty database administration design work
easily create edit rename delete tables
stored procedures functions
edit table data compare schemas or
execute queries by using contextual
menu rights i don't think this is on the
exam but because it's just
one of these many services i figured
we'd throw it in here
just so that if you do see this
initialism you know what it's for
[Music]
so azure data studio is a cross-platform
database tool for professionals using
on-premise and any data platforms for
windows mac os and linux and here is a
screenshot
and if you recognize it it looks just
like visual studio code right
if you open up the extensions that's
what you would see so query design and
manager database and data warehouses
data azure data studio offers a modern
experience with intelligence very
similar to experience to
visual studio code code snippets source
control integration integral terminal
built-in charting
customizable dashboards jupiter
notebooks connected to your data set
and it has a marketplace of free
extensions so some i noticed that seemed
very useful was
sql database inspector so a great way of
looking at your data
cousteau extension for azure data studio
postgres extension and many many many
more so there you go
[Music]
so azure data factory is a managed
service for etl elts and data
integration create data driven workflows
for orchestrating data movement and
transforming data at scale
and so if you see the image it makes it
pretty clear what you can do with it
there's a bit of a pipeline there so
create pipelines to schedule data driven
workflows
build complex etl processes that
transfer data visually with data flows
using computer services such as
hdinsights hadoop data bricks
sql database publish and transform data
to data stores such as
azure synapse analytics raw data can be
organized into meaningful data stores
and data lakes let's break down the
components here so we just have a better
idea how this thing works
so pipelines is a logical grouping of
activities that perform units of work
activities is a processing step in the
pipeline
data sets or data structures within the
data store link services define
connections information
for data sources to connect to the data
factory data flows are logic to
determine how data moves through the
pipeline transform
integration runtimes compute
infrastructure used by data factory
control flows orchestration of pipeline
activities that include chaining
activities and a sequence of branching
you should know what
control flows are and data flows are and
there you go
so microsoft sql server integration
services ssis is a platform for building
enterprise level data integrations data
transformation solutions
ssis can be used to automate sql
database servers it can be
used as an integration runtime for azure
data factory you can perform the
following tasks
copy files download files loading data
within data warehouses cleansing mining
managing
sql server objects managing sql server
data you can perform etl for a variety
of sources xml flat files relational
data sources
and ssis has built-in tasks and
transformation graphical tools for
building packages
integration service catalogs databases
where you store run
and manage your packages it comes with a
graphical interface to transform so you
don't have to write any code
and the designer is a graphical tool
that you can use to create and maintain
integration services packages just to
show you what it looks like
here it is so it allows you to drag out
transformations and design different
kinds of flows and control flows and
data flows notice it has control flows
and data flows similar to azure data
factory
uh but you can see this is the tool kind
of azure data factory is like kind of
like the web version of this
but yeah there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look here at etl
and sql tools cheat sheet so let's jump
into it the azure data factory is a
managed service for
etl elt and data integration jobs you
can create data driven workflows for
orchestrating data movement and
transforming data at scale
build elt pipelines visually without
writing any code via web interfaces
you have ssis the sql server integration
services
a platform for building enterprise level
integration data flow solutions
a low code tool for building etl
pipelines very similar to data factory
but existed 15 years prior
mostly focused around sql no surprise
there
integrates with azure data factory so
you can extend it to non-relational
database workloads okay
we have azure data studio an id similar
to a very similar to visual studio code
those cross-platform and works with sql
and non-relational database
data has many many many many extensions
you have sql server management studio
smss an id for managing any sql
infrastructure
that only works for windows more mature
than data studio
very similar in terms of parallel so we
have like the
modern version that's the web mode
versus web that's both
s like relational and non-relational and
then the older one that's mature
but is a windows app and does a lot of
interesting stuff for sql
you have sql server data tools ssdt this
is a visual studio extension to work and
design visually
sql databases within visual studio so
there you go we're all done
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and i wanted to show you how to go ahead
and install
power bi so what i've done is i'm on my
windows machine
and i pulled up the microsoft store and
all i did was go in the top right corner
and type in power bi
this is the easiest way to install power
bi you can download the application but
i find
this is just the best way to do it and
we'll hit get
or free to get started here
um and it should now start downloading
so we go in the top right corner
you'll notice here that it is now
downloading okay so we just have to wait
for that to finish
and i'll see you back here in a moment
all right so after waiting a short while
here it looks like power bi desktop is
finished downloading what we can do is
click into power bi
and we can go ahead and launch this
service and so we'll let that go ahead
and
launch
and that initial time you launch it it
does take a little bit of time there so
i stopped and restarted the video
but here you can see we are now inside
of power bi
uh and if we wanted to get started there
are a few ways we can go ahead and do
that they have some nice tutorials
here's in the bottom right corner but
what i want to do is just get something
open so we can start looking at
something so if you were to type in
sample data sets for power bi microsoft
has this nice page where you have a
bunch of downloadable
reports or things we can work with and
so maybe we should give the first one a
go so i'm going to go ahead and download
this one here
and if we go down below so we'll just
take a look here
so i think we just have to go ahead and
click here
and uh from here i just want to hit that
download button
so i'm just looking for it
here it is okay great and so i'll go
ahead and download that file
notice that it's it's the power bi x
that is the file that we are looking
for and we'll go ahead and open this
file
so after waiting a short while there the
file did open it does seem to take a
while for things to open but i'll just
hit the x there
they have a new modeling mode we'll just
say not yet and so down below you can
see i have a bunch of tabs here
and this allows us to go ahead and
explore this data
but you can see things are extremely
interactive here in
power bi desktop so you can do all sorts
of things
uh here okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and in this follow along we're going to
be looking
all at azure sql so what i want you to
do is go to the type here and type in
sql
and you'll notice you'll get the options
like the databases managed instances and
virtual machines those are the three
under the azure sql tier
to make our lives a little bit easier
we'll type in azure sql i find this
really confusing and so i'm hoping that
i can show you the easiest way to find
it but if you go to azure sql here and
add it
this will actually now give you the
option to choose between the three so
you can make an informed decision
and we'll work our way from the right to
the left so sql virtual machines is
great when you want os level access to
the virtual machine
uh when you're doing a lift and shift
that means you're moving your uh
sql server from on-prem to the cloud
because you want to
take advantage of the cloud and also if
you want to bring your own license to
take advantage of the azure hybrid
benefit so if you drop down here you'll
notice that you'll see byol
and if we expand here it'll tell you all
the details here as to why you'd want to
use that
i'm not going to spin one up because i'm
going to show you the price okay so we
go over to the price and we scroll on
down we go to
um page you go you're going to notice
whether it's on or off with high
hybrid benefit you're paying about a
dollar to two per hour and so
you know it's you're not going to learn
that much by spending one up
because we are going to spin up an sql
server but at this stage it's not going
to really matter
it's they're all very similar so you
know i just i don't want to
spend money if you're a student there
let's look at sql managed instances
we'll expand that
again this is for lift and shift meaning
you're moving from on premise to the
cloud
but here you don't have access to the os
level you're not bringing your own
license
however the upside is it's a fully
managed service meaning that it can
scale very well
it's going to have great backups and
things like that and it comes in two
flavors we have single instance in
single
instance azure arc now i didn't cover
this in the course but azure arc allows
you to
um extend your i think it's the control
plane it's either data plane or control
plane but the control plane
uh two different cloud providers and
also to your on premise so the idea here
is like you can use sql manage instances
and ha like you can have all the
benefits of here and launch the instance
within your
own infrastructure so um you know if you
really need to keep that server
on prem then you can do that with azure
arc but here's a single instance
um you know it's just whatever there and
so i'll show you the pricing on that one
and so we'll go to manage instances
we'll scroll on down here and the lows
cost
one here for pays you goes a dollar so
it's still kind of expensive if you're a
student
again i don't know if it has a free tier
and i i
wouldn't imagine it would because that's
not really a free tier kind of product
but you know i just want you to know
that that option is there we'll make our
way now to
sql databases and so
we have a few options here we have
single database elastic pool and
database server
okay so single database is you have it's
a great fit for modern
uh cloud cloud-borne applications that
need fully managed database with
predictable formats so it has hyperscale
i mean that it can scale up to 100
terabytes
it has serverless compute it's easy to
manage you have elastic pools we covered
this in
in the lecture content this is where you
might be like a multi-tenant sas
and you have multiple databases one per
customer and you want to save cost so
you actually have them all running on
the same
server and you have database server and
those so this is just to manage a group
of
single databases and elastic pools it's
a way of grouping stuff together
and so today what i'm going to do is
launch myself a single database
okay and what we'll do is we'll just say
azure sql or we'll say dp900
dp900 azure sql
just so i can see what i'm doing we'll
go down below here and i'm just going to
call this
um my azure
uh sql
we will drop down here and select a
server we'll have to create a new server
so this will be
my azure sql server
and you might have to work to choose a
name i'm gonna do one two three
four five six there we go
okay for the login i'm gonna do azure
user
for the password i'm gonna do capital t
testing one two three
capital t testing one two three it's
really nice sometimes they make you do
four five six and then an
exclamation mark but we have the shorter
password there we're going to say okay
do we want to use an elastic pool no i
don't think we need that today but let's
expand the general purpose here
i want to make sure that we have the
lowest cost possible so notice
to the right here it's 381 dollars if
you're provision it
you can also do serverless i've actually
never
used the serverless feature here but
this would be really great if you're
just trying to
learn because it's going to be based on
usage here i've definitely used
serverless
services just not this one in particular
for sql but what i'm going to do is
stick with provision
i'm going to look for a basic plan and
what we'll do is scroll this all the way
to the left here
and you know this is just if we forget
to turn off our database so now it's
five
five dollars a a month and probably you
know per hour it's you know
fractions of a penny so we'll go here
and hit apply and we'll scroll down as
we have some options geo-redundant
zone redundant locally redundant
honestly we only need locally redundant
so i'm going to go ahead and select that
obviously
you know if you're doing a production
database you want geo-redundant because
you're going to have um
uh you know better like a better
redundancy in terms of like if a
region goes down you'll still have your
database okay we're the next step to
networking
and here we either have public or
private endpoint this is really
important for uh security purposes right
and we do cover this in the lecture
content as well
and so i think it would be a great idea
to have that there let's go read about
firewall rules allow services and
resources to access server yes to
communicate from all resources inside
the azure boundary
that may or may not be private
subscription so allow azure services and
resources to access this service
yes uh add current ip address yeah
because that's me so i'm going to say
yes to both of those it's going to set
up our firewall rules which is really
nice we'll go next to security
here we have azure defender for sql if
you want that additional
protection you turn that on it costs 15
a month
and we'll go to the next tab here here
we could um
i guess let's see for backup so start
with a blank database restore from a
backup or select a sample
i'll select a sample because that's nice
to have some data i didn't know they had
that there
um and so we'll go to next tags
i didn't really cover tags in the course
but they're actually really important
especially when we're talking about data
because you do want to
catalog and and categorize all your
stuff
so tagging is very simple what we do is
we have a name so we could say
um workload and i'll just say like uh
learning right but allows us to filter
and find resources later down the road
we'll go ahead and hit review create
we can review all of our stuff see that
the price is okay with us
we'll go ahead and create and again
we're not going to get billed five
dollars by pressing that button
because it's again build per hour um
so you know we will be build some kind
of sense i don't know if azure sql has a
free tier
probably does uh free tier let's see
here
free tier i don't see it but
i'm not too worried about that um so you
know again if you're really worried
about any spend just uh watch and don't
don't do it but i do recommend if you do
have the pennies to go launch the stuff
up yourself because you'll learn a lot
more that way okay
so i'll see you back here when this is
done provisioning
all right so after a short little wait
there our server is ready so i'm going
to go ahead and hit click
go to resources and what we can do on
the left hand side is just do a little
exploration so look at the top here
where it says set server firewall
remember from our uh our security part
where
if we had set um some default rules well
here they are okay so here is my ip
address that is allowing me to connect
to it
notice we have that connection policy
where it's default proxy or redirect
you know things like that so we'll go
back uh one step here
and i just want to show you down below
that there are some features so notice
that
tde transparent data encryption is
already turned on
uh there's your azure defender for sql
we have our dynamic data masking so on
the left hand side we'll scroll on down
and just take a look at some of the
security so we go to tde and you can see
it's already turned on for us which is
great
i'm not going to click on the security
center because it's a pain to exit out
but let's look at dynamic data masking
so here what it's doing is it's
suggesting
uh fields that should be masked and we
can go ahead and just click add and add
and then we can mask these domains so i
just click that there
and so now these domains are masked and
it shows you a bit of the mass function
as to what it would do to to mask it so
it's as easy as that
um data discovery classification this
will be useful it's in preview right now
it's not showing any
information as of yet but the great
thing about this is that it could
discover some information that you might
care about that needs to be
that's considered sensitive right so you
might say this is confidential
gdpr address here um information types
let's see what we can do here so we'll
say customer
and we'll say credit card and we'll say
highly confidential
and i'll say add classification
i haven't used the service before
because i had never seen it before but
um it looks like that's a great way to
um you know keep track of that kind of
stuff so that's cool
uh auditing i don't think i ever do
auditing but um
you can turn azure school auditing it
will track uh logs and stuff like that
so
the thing is is that if someone were to
get into your database and try to
make changes or to corrupt your data
stuff like that you'd want to see who
was actually accessing those queries so
definitely if you care about security
you'd absolutely want to turn that on
and then we'll just scroll back to the
top here back go to our overview
i want to show you that through connect
we can connect to data studio or visual
studio
if you click this it's going to tell you
you need to install it i don't have
azure data studio yet so i'm going to go
ahead and install it on this computer
and we'll go down below and i'm on a
windows machine today so
this is for windows mac and linux and so
i will go ahead and use the
user installer i guess and i will
download that to 100 megabytes as that's
going we'll make our way back
to our main page here and i also want
you to notice there's power bi so we
will go
and download this uh we can go download
actually right now so
if we were to click on um uh
is it just get started yeah it's going
to download this my azure
pb ids and we'll be able to open that
file in power bi
and you know we did power bi earlier in
a earlier follow along so it'll be easy
to open
i want you to know if you don't have
time to do all the stuff because we're
going to have this database up and
running for a little a little longer
than you expect
so if you if you don't feel like you can
do this all in one setting you can
delete this database and always go ahead
and spin it up again when you're ready
to continue but on the left hand side
they have a query editor here
and we're just going to go log in so i
said my password was testing with
capital t
one two three we'll hit ok and now that
we're in i can see my tables on the
left-hand side here
uh we got views and stored procedures
but let's say we wanted to execute a
query
so i'll just expand this i've never seen
this database before so i'm just going
to go with it but
we'll type in select um oops
and it's going to be very aggressive
about autocompletes you got to be really
careful
here i'm just going to say select
asterisk which means all fields
and we want to select it from sales lt
dot
customer and notice when it auto
completes it has square back brackets
around it
that is just the thing that tsql does
let's say you had a field called
first name and you wanted to have it
with a space and that's what brackets
that you do
so they're just filling that in case you
have reserved words or um
you know spaces but we don't actually
have any spaces here so we just remove
it like that
sales lte is kind of like the container
for all these um
all these tables it's just a naming
convention they have for their table
names
and so we'll go here select all and hit
run
and we should get some data back and so
let's just perform a very simple join so
a join will happen when you actually
have
a foreign key you can join on so here
you can see this is the
primary key customer doesn't seem to
have a whole lot of information so let's
go into
products and this should have
yeah here you see it says product
category that is a foreign key so we can
use that
so i'm going to go here and type in
sales lt
and we'll do product okay
and then we'll do where or sorry we'll
do a left join so we'll say
left join and i want to left join
on this product id so it would be left
join with
sales lt dot product
uh category and we would say on
and so we would say sales lt dot product
and it's going to be
uh what was it called it is
product category okay so we say product
category id
equals and we'd say sales lt
dot product category
um category dot id
so we're saying we want to join where
these match on here
assuming joins working like every other
language which it should
and so i'm going to be very particular
and just pull out some particular keys
that i want so here i'm going to say
i want the sales lt.product oops
and i wonder if i can do this as on this
like as
prod or for pe or because i'm going to
go crazy if i keep on typing that a
so we'll just try that um i think it
should work um if we do that because
then it'll just be easier to read here
it's like a way of aliasing it sometimes
you can don't even need to put the word
as you just put p like this
and for sales product we could do that
as well so i took out the on so i'll
just say like
pc and we'll see if it lets us do that
okay and so here we have product
id and i want to
get the product name looks like it's
working
and we want the category name i think so
we'll drop this down
i assume it must have a category it's
taking it's time to load here but we'll
just say
pc.name
as product name
as name as id
and we'll see if that lets us run that
it's currently not available if the
problem persists contact customer
support so we'll hit run again
i'm not sure why our server's having
problems i didn't i didn't turn it off
did i
let's go back here and take a look it's
online yeah it's in good shape here so
we should be able to query it
maybe just lost our connection so what
i'm going to do is just click back here
i'll type in testing123
[Music]
and i'll go ahead and close that there
we'll make our way back
go back in the query editor
there we go i'm not sure i was giving us
trouble
i threw an error here um
invalid id oh yeah it's not called that
it's called uh
product id there we go
we'll run that invalid column name
product id
must be naming these wrong here
capital d here uh is it the same thing
down below here
normally you know like when i name these
i would have them all lowercase
underscore but you know
in the azure world they they like to do
this quite a bit so we will try this
um
[Music]
product id so it doesn't oh right it
wouldn't be uh
this would be product category id sorry
so this is product category id
and yeah that should match there we go
so we just did a join between the two
tables so we have the name
and the product name which is pretty
good there
our azure data studio looks like it's
done downloading so i'm going to go
ahead and install that so
what i'm all i'm doing here is i'm just
double clicking the file to open it up
and we'll just give that there a second
oh it was here the entire time we'll say
i accept
next next next uh
we'll get a desktop icon sometimes i
can't find them later registered data
suit is an editor for supporting files
new i like other other programs for that
and we'll go ahead and install that
doesn't take too long
and we will launch the data studio
and yeah if you've ever used visual
studio code it's going to look very
familiar to you
see um
so don't like the light mode rather have
it dark appearance can we change that to
dark
zen mode oh no oh no what did i do uh i
don't know how to get out of that okay
great maybe not do zen mode i just
wanted to make it
a dark mode uh not sure how to change
that i guess it's not a big deal but
what we'll do is we'll go over here
the top and we can go ahead and add a
new connection
and so that's an mssql server what we'll
need to do
is i want to keep this open because um
it's very hard to find the tables here
but what we'll go here is go back and
we'll get the server name so we'll copy
that
and then within visual azure data studio
we'll paste in our server we have three
options windows authentication sql login
azure active directory i'm going to use
sql login the password is azure user
username is azure user the password is
capital t
testing one two three what i like will
tell to remember is that if you drop it
down it'll see if the database is there
and there it is so my azure sql that's
what we called it
i'm going to go ahead and connect
and if i expand it i should be able to
see tables good and stuff like that
very good a lot easier to work with than
that preview editor there so what we can
do
i'm just going to go over here and grab
our query
copy this and what we'll do up here is
we'll make a new query so
i think you uh it's over here new query
maybe it's over here as well let me see
i guess we just do it from there i'm
just trying to figure out what's the
easiest way to go up there and do new
query i'm going to go ahead and paste
that in notice we can change our
connection i don't think a database is
selected right now so we'll go ahead and
connect to this database here
we'll go ahead and run that and it's the
same data okay uh there's the
thing called notebooks which is kind of
cool so i can go ahead and make a
new notebook i think it's using jupyter
notebooks underneath
but what we'll do can we save that query
we sure can
i'm not going to save that query today
because i do not care but yeah it is
jupiter notebooks great so what we'll do
is go file
new notebook and here i can write some
text so
this will return back
both products and product categories
okay and then what i can do here
is add another piece of code we'll paste
that in whoops
and i can even say like limit so i could
say like limit
to 20 or maybe 10.
let me go ahead and run that
and we'll just connect on the server
here just needs to connect
okay and we spelt limit wrong so we'll
just
spell that again there
limit
i don't think i'm spelling it wrong but
i'll just take it out because i don't
feel like goofing around with that today
and so here we have our records okay
it should just be limit right l-i-m
maybe it's not limited tsql give me two
seconds tsql limit
oh they don't have a limit function i
did not know that okay well that's kind
of interesting
they have things like where row is equal
to like i'm just looking at it over here
right
so c here is use the top record so
select top five
you know top ten let me try that
there we go so i guess it's just not
limit so we have that in there which is
kind of nice um
and so let's say we wanted to narrow
that down to something in particular
uh if there's a way we could browse the
data
oops i mean that by accident but what we
could do here is just take a look
i wanted to see the um i'll do it over
here i want to see the
product category id because then maybe
we could just do a like a where
statement really
quickly and so these are all mountain
bikes when it's
five so what we'll do is we'll make a
where statement
and we will say when pc product
category d is equal to five
uh and then we'll hit run
okay and then up here we'll just say
that you know show us
oops uh can i edit this
yep show us the top
10 mountain bikes
it's not really saying like it's not
this is not very useful to information
because it's not saying
uh why it's the top 10 it's just listing
it there's no ordering here so maybe
that would be also a good idea here
so let's just take a look at our data
structure here i mean we could do it in
in here as well if we want to uh explore
that way but
i think it's a bit easier to do it here
so let's look at the product
um and see if there's like any
definitive information that makes it
interesting like list price
so maybe that's something we could
return here so we'll say um
p dot list price as
price
and what we could do is order that so
we'd say order by
p dot list price
descending
there we go when you have to do that
tutorial it's it's easier to forget so
now it's
listing it from descending prices uh
that amount isn't very human readable i
don't know if it's like 3000 whatever i
wonder if we could use a function to
do that if we're using ms or sorry like
postgres it would just be like floor
so maybe i could like floor the result
here or round it let's just see if i can
do that
sometimes it's like round yeah there it
is those are like built-in functions to
most sql languages here
and uh it needs two arguments what's the
second oh probably
what to round it to so we'll probably
put a zero here because it's going to be
like
rounded to what maybe it needs to be a
one
other languages you just put round in so
i don't know what that is so what we'll
do is look that up so we'll say tsql
round
okay just doing that off screen here and
so it says
number expression is an expression of
the exact numeric approximation
is the precision in which you want it to
be if i can get a nice example
so uh round's a number
i just don't want it with zeros
um so that will round it to
two decimal points and then we have
negative two so we'll go up the top here
is the precision to numeric to be
rounded length must be an expression of
tiny and when the length is a positive
number
is rounded to the number of decimal
points specified the length with a
number
uh it's on the left side of the decimal
point oh okay that's kind of interesting
so what we want to do is probably round
the left or right side
so either give it two there
can't convert data type vnc oh it's name
you know what you're probably watching
me be like andrew what the heck are you
doing
so it's supposed to be up here so we do
round
okay and i'll just say two and that
should round it to two decimal points
which is fine but i don't i really don't
want anything there so i'll say zero
and you know i probably would want that
just as an integer there's probably a
way to cast it so
maybe there's like a cast function or
two int
so i don't see that so cast
float to ant
tsql yeah it's called cast that's what i
thought
and so as simple as that so what we can
do
and we probably don't need to round it
because the cast will probably uh
rounded itself so we can say cast
and say as int
very good that looks really nice let's
say we wanted to like concat something
onto that
uh again i don't know how to do concat
and tsql so we'll look it up so we'll
say tsql
concat strings in postgres it's just a
pipe
oh it's a plus wow we get a plus i love
that
you don't usually get a plus so what
i'll do here is i'll cast this as an end
and then i'll cast this as i don't know
what it is in this as varchar bar chart
yes
can i do that first it's still a number
great and now that it is a
a string we can do maybe string dollar
sign like that
we'll say run we'll let me do that yes
very good and we'll give it
also the usd there he goes that's kind
of nice so now we kind of have a human
readable
human readable thing there okay so what
i'll do is i'll just copy that over put
it in my notebook
and we'll just have that there
i'll move that off screen and you know
that's pretty much how
you would create data with sql now now
that we have a mysql database we can
actually consume it with uh with a lot
of other services like power bi
or maybe some other services that we can
think of but
yeah how about we do that next let's try
to load this data into power bi
[Music]
all right so now let's take a look at
using power bi with our mssql server
here so in the bottom left corner you
saw that i downloaded that file earlier
so i'm going to go ahead and open that
up
if you don't have it just make your way
over to power bi and download it again
and all it's going to do is establish a
connection to the data source now
we didn't really need to download this
file to do it it's not that hard to
establish our own connection
uh but it does save us one little step
here okay so
it's going to load here just give it a
moment
it's going to pop this up if you don't
see this what you can do i'm just going
to go ahead and close this
to show you how to make a manual
connection so i'm going to go over to
server name copy that
go back and if we go into now you have
this button here but we'll just go get
data more
so you have a more predictable way of
loading data in
and we'll go to database here we can go
to azure
and so we have azure sql database um
which i think that's what we're using
and so we'll go ahead and hit connect
and so we'll put the server name in
there and the server name is my
azure sql we'll hit ok
we'll give it a moment to connect and
we'll get back to the same screen so
here we can import the data that we want
we'll say product product category
um customer
right customer address address the more
we bring in the more it's going to be so
you know what i'm just going to narrow
it down to just product product category
and customer
you can transfer the data which is
really nice i'm not going to get into
that because that's a whole other thing
but we'll go ahead and hit load
and what this is going to do is it's
going to start to import this data
and we'll give it a moment
so it's going to load the data in and
it's also going to detect relationships
and do our data modeling so the data is
now in if we go to here
we'll be able to see these tables and
explore that data in its raw format
if we go over to this tab here we can
see that it's detected a relationship
the more tables the more relationships
it will auto detect so we didn't want to
make that too hard
i want to go back over here to our
report and
i just want to show you how you can
visualize some information so one of the
easiest ones to do
off the bat is card so i'm looking for
card it's this one nope slicer
card okay and so i'm just dragging this
one out
just there we go i just clicked it
whatever you have to do to get there and
this is great if you have a single field
so i'm going to go drop this down
and i'm going to find product by list
price so i'm going to drag that onto the
field here notice it went into there it
only takes one input for the fields
and there's my price if i want to change
the look of it and go down here
and there's all sorts of things we can
change here like shadow
you know other things that you can do
for fun but you know there's a little
bit of styling there
and let's say i wanted to see that as a
table
so what i could do is just change that
to table and now it's a table uh table
display
but this information is not very useful
so what i want to do is drop this down
and then
drag out the name of the product
category remember that these have a
relationship it's established here so
it's going to know
how to slice that information to make it
useful and so now we have a breakdown of
price and name based on category right
and i mean that's category which there's
a i don't know how to rename that very
well
yeah for this visual here we'll say uh
you know product or so this would be
category
and for here we'll just say we'll just
rename that to make a bit easier we'll
just say price
there we go now let's say we want that
as a graph so we just change that over
to a graph so we can kind of see the
difference in prices
all sorts of things we just click around
here to have some fun
okay bar chart's going to be the most
useful one i believe so
yeah i don't know if there's anything
else that's really fun here we have
another breakdown kind of see
like uh the cost there of all the stuff
that they're selling
okay i think that has the highest price
is the bikes right because
so the volume of sales is just the cost
of each item right that they're selling
uh you know so that's how you'd use
power bi desktop with
um uh with your sql server so yeah there
we go
so another thing that we can do since we
have power bi and we connected it to our
mysql server or our sql server no
problem is we probably should try to
publish
it to the power bi service so that we
can see how to make dashboards so what
i'm going to do is go up the top here
and type in app.powerbi.com
if this is the first time you've ever
gone here it's going to ask you to make
an account even even if you have a
microsoft account it's just another way
of authorizing that there and so here
you can see
uh we can explore all sorts of data sets
if we click into here these are just
dashboards right
and we'll go in here we can see all this
kind of information which is uh really
nice and we can go here
and just select some information you can
see it's very interactive which is
really nice
um and you know we can go ahead and
create our own uh kind of things here if
we were
to publish a data center or do whatever
but uh
you know what i want to do is
uh to connect to some more data sources
download power bi desktop we already
have that installed so what i want to do
is just publish and get something into
here
so i'm going to reopen up our file we
had there earlier
and establish a connection to our ms sql
server
we'll make a little port and we'll
publish it and see how we can access it
through the
power bi service here okay
so give it a moment and all i want is
product and product category
once it decides to load here so we want
product and product category
and i will say load we'll give it a
moment
and now that is loaded what we'll do is
again make ourselves a visual so
i will drag out a card like we did last
time
and we'll go down to product here i will
try price
it's better probably better if it's a
table it's a little bit more useful i
think
and we'll go here to product category
and drag out the name
again we'll rename these i'll just say
rename price
rename
category
and what we'll do there's a published
bubble go ahead and hit our publish
button so do you want save changes yes
uh and we'll just save this whatever we
want to call it we'll just say my power
bi report
okay
and uh so we will just have to put our
email in here
okay oops it's thinking
we'll give it a second
there we go so it's asking me to log
into my account
and we'll say my workspace sounds great
to me
and we'll give it a moment to publish
that report
great that report has now been published
we'll make our way back to power bi
and so it should be under our workspaces
right
all right so what we'll do is make our
way over to our workspace and left-hand
side and you'll have to
click on here it's not very clear and we
have a data center report if we click
into a report we have this error about
missing credentials so what we'll do is
make our way over to our data
set and we'll just go to uh settings
here
and we might need to provide some
credentials here again so let's edit the
credentials
and we'll just say as your user capital
t testing one two three
uh privacy level settings is private
we'll sign in and you know what the pro
i wonder if it'll give us access to user
updates etc because it's from a
a uh it you know like remember how we
had that firewall
rule so it could be the firewall rules
that is preventing it
so by clicking on my report yeah it's
still a problem so what i'll do is go
over to my azure server set the firewall
rules here allow azure services to
access this resource
yes um
so it's denying the rules
so we'll have to figure that out there
okay so uh looks like actually as going
the data set and updating the
credentials did work that message was
just a bit of a false flag there i mean
like it did need to reestablish
connection but uh
uh you know i thought i thought maybe i
had to go digging around in our
firewall settings but since we have this
turned on you know power bi should be
able to access it and it can
so we have we're looking at a report
right now within
power bi but let's say we want to make a
dashboard well how would you do that
well you go ahead and you just go and
hit the pin
we'll say my dashboard we'll go ahead
and pin that and
uh i mean if we want to create a mobile
layout we could do that
okay so there it is for our mobile
layout and we can go back to our web
layout
right and from there you know now that
we have our dashboard we can go ahead
and
just you know share that with our team
or put it in chat
you know whatever it is but this is
where the point where you would then hit
the power bi pro where you have to
upgrade
but uh yeah it's as simple as that so
yeah there you go
so we saw azure data studio as a means
to connect to a database but there's
another tool which is
um at sql server management studio i
figured we should give that a go so what
i'll do is go ahead and download that
and it's 635 megabytes so you have to
decide whether you want to download that
once that's downloaded what we'll do is
go ahead and install and give it uh give
it a look okay
all right so after a very long wait sss
ms is
done downloading and even in here it
says that it downloads azure data studio
with it
so they really really want to use azure
data studio which we've already used
but you know it doesn't hurt to open up
ssmss and give it a go
if you can use it and so
i'm just going gonna go ahead and
install that there okay
and it sounds great
it's gonna go
there we go couldn't tell i hit install
or not
all right so waiting a little bit of
time here this finally installs we'll go
ahead and close that and now what we'll
do is go actually ahead and open that
program
ssms uh i'm not sure where it installs
into so i'll see you back in a moment
all right so i'm back and i found it
it's under c program files microsoft sql
server management studio 18
common 7 id now uh you know your start
menu
you should be able to type in ssms and
find it for whatever reason on my
computer nothing ever shows up under the
start menu and i can't be bothered to
fix it
but it's good to know where it actually
installs to so now we know where it is i
just double clicked it and now it is
open
and so here we can see a bunch of stuff
and uh this will be a way for us to load
this so what we'll need is our server
name as per usual
so i'm going to go back to azure here
and i'm going to grab the server name
we'll go back paste that in we'll choose
sql server authentication we'll type in
azure user we'll type in testing with a
capital t
one two three connect honestly i like
this a lot better
as your data studio i don't know like
real apps just feel feel like they work
a lot better you know
and so we can go into our database here
look at some tables
okay give it a moment to load and we can
go into like customer or maybe product
okay uh there should be a way to
visualize whoops
visually that so maybe go design mode
here
give it a second to open up
yeah so we can kind of see like what
columns there are and stuff in here
which is really great
but what i want to do is create a new
query
and i just want to show you that you can
query it in here too just query it
everywhere right
and so uh from our azure data studio
that i still have open from before
what we can do is grab ourselves this
code here
and paste it on in we go ahead and
execute that and we can see we get the
results so
you know this is a very very very very
powerful tool um you know and it's just
i could do
spend all day trying to show you how to
use this uh tool here but um
yeah i mean this is all you need to know
so yeah there you go
so that is ssms and i'll just go ahead
and close that
and there we go
[Music]
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
what we're going to look at here
is storage accounts and specifically
blob storage tables
and maybe azure files and so what i want
you to do is go all over the top here
and by the way i'm just carrying this
over from my
mysql or sql tutorial so something to do
while i'm waiting for this thing to
install
but what we'll do is type in uh account
store storage accounts we'll go here
and oh yeah just hit cancel there that's
for my other tutorial
we'll hit add and we'll create a storage
account
okay and what we'll do is i'll say
dp 900 storage
it will say ok and we'll name this
storage account we'll say we'll call it
uh my storage account notice we have the
option between oops
one two three four five six there we go
oh
somebody really really wants uh to have
the same name as me nine eight seven six
five four three two one
because those are unique names right um
oh it doesn't like that uh can only be
contains must be
three characters is now too long okay
there we go
and so they're uniquely identifiable
across all accounts that kind of gets
annoying between standard and premium if
you choose it you get a few different
options so
with premium you get block blobs file
shares page blob so we're going to stick
with standard to save some money
we change the redundancy we'll stick
with local redundant zones because
that's the most cost effective
go over to advanced see what else we
want here
um here we have the option to turn on
uh uh higher or higher cold name space
that's if we're doing
a data lake gen storage 2 which we're
not doing at this point in time
so what i'll do is go ahead and hit
review and create
and we'll scroll down and say create
okay
and we'll just wait for that to create
the storage account i'll see you back
here in a moment
all right so we waited a little bit of
time here and our storage account is
ready so go in here and what we'll do is
go to the left-hand side we can see we
have some containers
we wanted to make a file share it's
really easy just hit the file share
button
and we'll name it so say my azure file
share
okay and we can
pick how the tiers we want um
transaction optimize seems okay to me we
have to set a quota
uh we'll say i don't know one gigabyte
we're not really going to do anything
real here so
i'm just going to hit create okay and so
now we have our nice file share there
if we click into it we can uh upload
files so
i need to go grab some kind of file off
the internet and we'll just type in
star trek here anything
images as long as it's appropriate and
yeah here's a photo so go ahead and save
that
save image as and we'll go to
our downloads here
and we'll just say kirk
and spock okay
and that is now downloaded we'll make
our way back here i'll say upload
and what we can do is go to our
downloads again
kirk and spock we'll say open upload
and there's the file right uh not super
complicated
so that's that uh let's go back over to
here
into our storage accounts uh back here
and i want you to show you uh storage
explorer
so you can go ahead and download storage
explorer if you haven't so you go here
you download it
hit download now i think i already have
it installed so all i'll do is just
click open
and say open takes like two minutes to
install
yep i do and this is just an easier way
like if you don't want to have to open
up the portal and you want to be able to
easily work with files it's another way
you can do stuff so
we'll give it a moment to open and so
here we have our storage account we can
drop it down and see what's under there
because we have a bunch of disks that i
need to go ahead and delete but if we go
here to file share we have our file
share here
and you can see it's just an alternative
interface we can upload and do stuff
there if i wanted to download that i
could do that okay
but let's go take a look at blob storage
okay
so go over to containers we'll make
ourselves a new container we'll say
my blob storage uh
yeah it can be private that's fine
uh we'll say create we'll click into our
blob storage
and we need to upload a file so again
we'll upload the same file so we'll go
here
and we'll upload our kirk and spock file
here
and we'll upload it and there it is
again
and if we go over to our storage
explorer and we go under blob containers
and there you can see we have the data
there so that's really really nice
um so there's that
we should probably take a look at
tables so go back to my storage account
left hand side we'll make ourselves a
new table so we'll say
my azure table say okay
and click into this actually we can't
this is kind of a pain you'd have to use
the api stuff but this is where the
explorer comes in handy
so on the left hand side we will look
for tables
and we'll say my azure table
and uh we'll say add
okay we have to set a partition key and
a row key so our partition key
would be something like uh we could say
wharf and our category could be
lieutenant commander
okay insert and uh
if we wanted to edit this we could add
more property
such as like um
you know planet
kronos whatever you want you got all
sorts of types here
but it's pretty darn simple as you can
see not super complicated there
um but yeah maybe we should learn how to
use the azure tables via the cli so i'll
be back here in a second and show you
how to do that okay
all right okay so i have the commands
that we can do to uh
do that for the cli so what i want you
to do is click up here in the top right
corner that is the
azure cloud shell there and i want you
to start in bash
if it asks you to create a storage
account go ahead and do that
because it needs a volume so under here
we'll actually make one this is the one
that is for my developer environment
so just hit yes and just wait for this
to load sometimes it takes a little bit
of time
and if it's giving you a lot of trouble
i'm gonna hit restart
it doesn't usually give me that much
trouble but
there we go okay great it's i'm so used
to waiting around in azure it's crazy
but uh so what we can do is type in a z
that is the cli command for a z if we
hit enter
it should spit out some information
yeah so it tells us all the things we
can do there so what we want to do i'm
typing clear here
az storage identity insert hyphen
t we want to put the name of our table
table is called
my azure table uh we need the
container account name we'll need we
don't need the container name so the
account name is
up here so i'm going to try to type it
in here i'm going to go ahead and paste
that in
and now we can go ahead and insert
so yeah it will go here to the hyphen e
so e is going to be what we insert so we
have partition key
and this will be uh we'll say uh
beverly and we'll put the row key
as a commander and then we could say
planet equals earth
okay and if we hit enter i think we got
it all right there give it a second
uh doesn't know what account name is
let me just see if i spelt that wrong
maybe it just doesn't like where it is
so i'm going to just copy it out of here
trying to make a bit clean by putting it
there but
i will put it on the end here
oops go ahead and paste that in there
still doesn't like it um if it doesn't
like that we could try giving it the
container name
it might just pick up the account name
which is the account we're in um but i'm
going to go
here and find my container
that's where i had this like working
like a second ago and just decides not
to work
okay
okay so that's fine so i already have a
working version here on the side
so what i'm going to do i'm just going
to
change some of the values here
okay and so i have this here and i know
this 100 works right so we have
um a-z-a-z storage storage identity
identity insert insert
um hyphen t for the table so maybe that
was my problem is that
i just didn't do hyphen t there so i'll
just paste that in there
i don't think container is used anymore
but we'll hit enter
so it doesn't like the container name so
we'll just erase that out there
and so there it has inserted the data so
there we go so yeah i'll just show you
like azure's a bit painful sometimes
even when you have perfect instructions
it still doesn't work properly
we'll go ahead and hit refresh and there
is the record in our table database
so there you go uh and i might just
leave these
accounts open here because they might
want to adjust them in another tutorial
but uh of course we will clean them up
at some point near the end of the course
okay
[Music]
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
in this uh follow along what we're going
to do is take a look at cosmodb so what
i want you to do is go to the top here
type in cosmodb
and we'll go here and add a new cosmodb
account and notice that we have some
options we have
sql mongodb cassandra gremlin azure
table so what i want to do
i'm going to be pretty crazy here i'm
going to make a new core sql one
and so we'll just say under here i'll
say cosmo
dp900 cosmodb
okay and i'm just going to call this one
cosmo
db core sql
and just to be more you can say dp900
here i don't know if this one conflicts
with other ones
so we have provision throughput and
serverless i'm going to choose
serverless because um
i don't need provision throughput and
there is a
free tier here but i'm going to go with
serverless okay
just so we don't have to worry about it
we got a lot of options here like global
distribution etc like that
i don't care about any of that stuff and
so what i'm going to do is go ahead and
hit review and create
okay
and we're going to repeat this process
again and again so what i'm going to do
is go back to cosmodb create a new
account
and we'll create a mongodb one now and
we'll drop this down and we'll choose
cosmodb
i think i called it dp900 cosmodb so
this would be dp900 cosmo
db [ __ ] db the name is not available
you just have to change it till you get
it i'm going to make this one serverless
as well
and we'll hit review and create so i
just want to show you the variance of
these ones okay
so this is a little bit of annoying but
what we have to do
we'll add another one here this will be
azure table
we'll drop it down we'll choose uh dp900
cosmodb
we'll say cosmodb uh we'll say dp900
cosmo
db um azure table
serverless go ahead review and create
and we'll create that and we'll go one
more time we'll do
a graph database okay oops doesn't want
us to go back
and we'll say gremlin
and we'll choose our dp900
dp900 cosmo
db gremlin
okay serverless review and create
and we'll go back to here and i'm just
going to wait until these are all done
so i'll see you back when we see
all of our i think we made four four of
our cosmo dbs okay
all right so after waiting a little
while here actually my gremlin database
didn't create or my account didn't
create so i had to make that twice but
here they are and you can see this one
is still creating but we can go and do
some things while we're waiting first
let's go check check out the core sql
and so on the right hand side you'll see
there's this quick start it's always a
great way to
get started so if we wanted to uh you
know in azure we could start inserting
data so if i was to go over to node.js
and we say create items container this
is what i'm the most familiar with now a
lot of people go over to the explore
data but i'm just curious as to what
this stuff looks like so
because i've never used the quick starts
before so i'm just curious to see the
quality of it so let's go ahead and
create that items container
right now i think it's just waiting to
create so if i go over to that data
explorer tab
uh it's probably just going through that
process of creating so it actually
created us a to-do list which is nice
okay and it set up a partition key
and oh looks like it's done so now we
can go ahead
and download that application says npm
install npm start
it's kind of cool and i have it over
here so i just gotta unzip it
okay so i'm just unzipping that here
it's using winrar that's what i got
installed and we'll just drag that on
over here
and i wonder we'll go up here
now you may or may not be able to easily
open this depending on how your setup of
your computer is so if you do
you can't just you can just follow along
here i'm opening up visual studio code
here
you just can't see it's off screen but i
just want to close some things
in here okay
and i'm just going to go open
go here file open a folder
and this is my downloads so i'm going to
navigate all the way to my downloads
here so we'll say
um this is users andrews
if you want to see me i'm just writing
this over here downloads
sql and we'll say ok
and what we'll do is open up a new
terminal here
and the instructions said that we should
be able to do
npm install npm starts we'll give that a
go we'll say npm install
i might as well take a look here at the
code just curious what's going on here
so it's actually using the azure's cosm
yeah cosmodb client
it has a config file over here which
contains uh our configuration
information
looks like it has some initial items
that it's going to insert so there's
some
initial data which looks kind of cool it
sets up a partition key here
we have an endpoint so what it does
create the database if it does not exist
read the database definition create the
container if it does not exist
read the container scale the container
create family item query the container
so there's a lot of examples here so
here it just gives you some stuff so
you know if you know you're coding and
you want to go through this it's a great
way to get started it looks like
finished installing we'll do an npm
start i don't know if i'll be able to
actually view this
because it's running through a machine
oh so it just runs it okay
i thought i was going to like uh output
a um
like a localhost 3000 you could view it
so it actually just ran that stuff so
create the to-do list reading created
etc so yeah all of it's there so if
you're familiar with that you can take a
look but what we'll do now is make our
way over to day explorer
we can also go up to cosmos uh
was it cosmos.azure.com is that what it
is
there we go this has a little bit more
room i'm going to click on sign in
it's the same thing as the date explorer
just a little bit easier to work with
subscription one
and we are in sql here we'll drop it
down now we actually have some data we
can take a look at some good items
check out items here
and it should show us some right
hmm
go back here
it says first name etc so you can see
that
it created the to-do list reading the
database create the items reading
oh completed with an error entity with
the specified id does not exist in the
system
okay so it's expecting something to
already exist there and that's why it
couldn't run
so maybe what we'll do is just go ahead
and create what it wants
okay so while we go ahead and create a
new item
so the partition key is called partition
key that's a
very uncreative name but when you create
these records you always have to have
the id and the part partition key name
so i'll go here
and we'll type in partition key
and i guess it could just be whatever we
want um
i'm just looking at the record here to
see what they wrote
so we just scroll up here
we are looking for create item
just scroll up here see if we can find
it
this is more like reading an item here
i'm not necessarily creating
partition key at sign country usa so
um i guess we just say usa here
say name oops
andrew let's see if he'll let us create
that
uh we'll go ahead and just copy this
oops
place with id so we'll just say one
we'll say save
okay and it added some additional data
underscore sts is for uh for a time
stamp okay
um and now what we can do is go and look
at that data so we'll hit more
oh i guess we're exploring it right
there okay so let's say we wanted to
query that data we could create a few
other records because that's not a lot
of information right so what i'll do is
just copy this
we'll create a new item here uh
i'm technically not in the usa i'm in
canada so we'll put in vaco here
just copy that and we will save we'll
create a new item
uh there should have been different ids
but whatever
we'll say brazil put in roger
and we will go ahead and save okay and
so now let's say we wanted to query that
data
uh it should be these icons are very
cryptic
let's sort procedure whoops
um yeah i guess we could do it right
here
no you ask your query that's what i want
okay
so uh if we hit run
execute query to return us all the data
but let's say we wanted to only select a
subset of data so we just do where
um name equals andrew let's give that a
go
see if that works oops
uh what if we do c dot name
there we go so yeah it's as simple as
writing queries
not like any other kind of sql so that's
pretty easy let's take a look at
another one here so that was that let's
close that off and we'll take a look at
mongodb next
all right let's take a look at mongodb
so we'll go ahead and click into here
make our way to quickstart and we have
some options
we have node.js so if you wrote
javascript and use the connection girl
that's one way of doing it
i think mongodb might be the shell might
be a fun way to do it so
what i'll do so go over here i don't
think i have this installed but it comes
part of the
server installation for mongodb so i'll
go ahead
if you would like to download the [ __ ]
self separately from server yeah that
sounds better to me
i don't think i need everything and so
select the zip download
which includes the [ __ ] uh okay
and well i guess we'll have to click on
the computer community edition here
oh windows we can do the zip or msi yeah
i guess we'll just install the full
thing it's not a big deal
maybe i'll use it for something else but
we'll go there it's only 200 megabytes
so we'll just wait for that to download
shouldn't take too long here
there we go and i just got my downloads
over here we'll open that up
sure we'll go ahead and hit next i agree
next
i guess we can customize it
so maybe if you only wanted the client
i'm going to just take everything
um we'll say next that seems all fine to
me we'll hit next
install
this process is on a mac or linux it's
just going to be different process
but yeah we'll go ahead and see this
here
all right so after waiting a very long
time uh on that compass step it finally
uh finished installing i guess it was
doing a
visual installer there it looks like it
is opened
and uh i guess we installed [ __ ]
compass and it makes it really easy cool
uh sure we'll say yes to everything
there there's a little bit too much
information
um but i guess what we can do is
establish a connection and i guess i was
thinking we just use the shell but this
looks
better so what we'll do is go ahead and
take a look here so
we will go grab our connection string
and hopefully you'll just take it as
that it looks like it's
hold on here i think what we really want
is this this is the string here
connection string
i guess we can grab it from here it's a
bit easier we'll go back to
our connection service here we'll hit
connect fingers crossed it works first
time
yeah there we are we're in okay cool so
uh i
it's a new data like it's completely new
so i guess we wouldn't have anything in
it like a database or anything like that
so we can do at the same time as we're
doing it let's make our way over to
cosmodb
um oh i guess i closed it cosmos
azure.com and we'll go down and flip
over to our mongodb
database and we don't we haven't created
anything yet so we have to make a new
database so i'll just say
my [ __ ] database or my mongodb
my collection can you think of a
collection as like a table right
uh shared key whatever we want uh my
shared key again i'm just showing you
how to insert stuff
uh we don't need this sharded so we'll
just say unsharded
okay makes it a bit easier on us here
i just want to see if that actually
reflects over here in our manga db
compass
because it probably should
we'll give it a moment there to create
the database if it doesn't what we can
do because there's a reload here right
so let's hit reload until the data loads
and yeah looks like we have it now so
that's all good and
i guess we have to click on this maybe
click on this one again here to
reconnect
great now we have a database so we can
go in here
click on my collection can add data
let's hoping to execute a command oops
and i'm just trying to see if it allows
us to do that here in any way
again i'm not that familiar with this
tool but uh yeah i guess we can go
create a document here we can make it
through here so let's go to documents
we'll add a new document and say one
and i guess we should probably put our
shirt key so my shared key
say blue we'll just say
name andrew
and we will go ahead and save that
document we'll go back here
refresh we can see our document there we
can edit it in here as well
a lot nicer in this say we can add data
we'll say document
it's a little bit more cryptic i think i
prefer to do it in there i'm again i'm
not that familiar with this tool but
what i really wanted to show you was the
command shell so what we'll do
oh is this new shell up here
oh that's nice okay i thought we were
going to have to uh you know i thought
we're going to have to paste this in
so maybe we didn't have to install that
all along but hey this looks pretty good
to me right
so what i have pulled up here is the
uh api i had here a second ago at least
you say mongodb shell i definitely had
it open here for us
um because i wanted to show you the api
uh so there's like right one
okay here we go so i found the mongodb
api here and if i just go back it's
shell method so if you typed in
mongodb.com for slash mail reference
methods you can see all the kind of
stuff that we can do
and so let's just go ahead and see if we
can insert something we only need to
insert a single document and so here we
kind of see the uh
the stuff here yeah underscore id is the
the main field there and what we'll do
is scroll on down and we'll just go
ahead and copy this command and see
if we can get that to work okay so
we'll go back over here give that a
paste
hit enter and we'll go back to our
document and see if it's there
there it is we will go back and check in
our mongodb cluster here give it a
refresh
i want to see
uh well it shows two records
so what i'll do yeah it's not what i
want so we'll try this again
yeah i just started typing it's like i
already have an error
and we want the my shared keys we'll say
my
shared key
okay double quotations we'll say
green and we'll just put in here name
baco we'll say insert
okay that record is there uh we'll give
this a refresh here
oops there it is there's the record as
well
it didn't insert the other one i wanted
so we'll go back into our shell here
we'll say db.products it's probably
because i didn't i you know if you don't
have the um
partition keys just not gonna insert it
right i thought it would error out or
say something that's what i was looking
for
so i'm gonna say id we'll say five
i'm going to put uh my shared key we'll
say red
and we will put name here and we'll say
roger
we'll give that a go
and if you don't type it right it will
not work so we'll say insert one
there we go we'll go back to our
document here we'll give it a refresh
here
i'm having like no luck doing inserts
today
but uh you know you get the general idea
right so we're not here to really teach
you a mongodb tutorial but i just want
to show you that
you know you use the shell to insert
data there's this tool here
and what a document looks like so that
pretty much covers the document
mongodb so what we'll do is go back here
and let's take a look at azure tables
all right so let's take a look at cosmo
db as your table so click into it we'll
make our way over to the data explorer
then we'll say new table and i'll just
say my new table
say okay
and we'll give it a moment to create
this new table here
as you can see we didn't have to make it
a database or anything it was just a lot
more straightforward here
but it does seem to take a long time to
make a table to be fair it is serverless
so it could be uh
having to provision something before it
do something we'll go here look at
entities and we can go ahead
and add ourselves uh
a new entity here we go up the top here
so we'll just say worf
lieutenant commander
planet kronos
add entity and there it is
okay go maybe over to the query builder
and if we wanted to filter this out we
could say partition key
i guess we need another record for this
to make sense so we'll say um
data uh commander
um okay he's not from earth but we'll
just put earth
we'll add that entity we'll add another
one might as well
we'll say um crusher
commander earth
and we can go here and we just filter it
out so we'll say crusher
uh partition key app that's right so it
should be able to run that so
run query okay gets that exact record so
pretty simple
not too complicated and so now we'll
move on to gremlin
all right so let's take a look at cosmo
db gremlins so click into it and what i
want you to do is go to quick starts
we'll go to guided gremlin tour
and we'll create ourselves a sales graph
collection so we get a little bit more
information that
we normally would have
give it a moment here
and as there we go yep it's ready so we
created the sample this downloaded a
package that contains a console app
as.net the console app needs to be
executed first to upload the sample data
and the asp.net web app will allow you
to visualize your data okay so i guess
we have to go ahead and do that so we'll
go ahead and download that
and there it is i'm just going to unzip
it here
and we'll double click and do it and
it doesn't look like much but i'll drag
it out into my folder here
whoops and we will go
and click into this and
i want to know how to use this so i
guess we'll open this up in
vs code
okay let's give this a read
sample application shows to interact
with the cosmodb gremlin etc etc
visual studio code 2015 sample data has
two projects uploading the sample data
is done via the console application
project included in the quick start
run the console app
all right so it's saying that we need to
go to tools
and we're going to double click this and
luckily i
have visual studio installed if you
don't have install you don't have to go
do this but we just want to see
a nice looking gremlin graph in our
cosmodb
and i will go ahead and sign in
and i'll use my example account
and i guess it really wants me to choose
some stuff but i'm fine let's just go
ahead and start it
the c project is targeting.net which is
not installed in this machine to proceed
select the option below
change the target you can change it sure
as long as it runs you know i didn't
feel like i was going to be doing dot
net today but we'll go ahead and open
this
up all that really matters is that we
can run it projects loaded and ready to
use in the background
and so we need to run this
so it says over here
so verify the settings if you download
etc i just want to run it run the
application
f5 so i think it's telling me to hit f5
on my keyboard
and so i have a mac keyboard so i'm not
sure if that's going to work but what
i'll do
is i'll go to the top here oops
might need to install extra components
so we'll go ahead and install whatever
components it wants
just click that over here in the right
hand corner there it's probably because
it needs a very particular version of
dotnet yeah it needs the dotnet desktop
development here even though i'm not a
dotnet developer i still know my way
around
ids pretty darn well so we'll go ahead
and give that an install
and it looks like it's 848 megabytes
i'll see you back here in a moment okay
all right so after waiting a little
while here it looks like it's installed
and restarted
and i think i can actually run the
application now so we'll go at the top
here
and we'll run we'll say
should be like a project run i guess we
just hit the start button
that works too right
you.net fans that are watching you can
make as much fun as you want to be
okay and so you know we just want this
to run so that it loads the data right
that's all this thing does
so it's going to build the project
and it's complaining about virus and
threat protection not really worried
about that
and it said it succeeded verify the
database exists your collection etc
uploading the graph
now excellent there we go
and we're just going to wait for it to
upload those nodes
and we're going to have a really really
good example here
i'm not sure how many nodes there are in
this could be a lot
there we go oh now it's starting up
edges great
this is 469 nodes i wonder if there's
going to be as many edges
or less we'll see
there we go so now it says graph
uploaded you can now show this
application
okay sounds great so what we'll do and
i'll just go ahead and close visual
studio because i don't need it open
anymore
and what we'll do is open up the data
explorer
actually kind of prefer cosmodb so we'll
type in cosmodb again
and we will switch over to
our gremlin database here and go into
persons graph database
well you should be able to see a
visualization without having i guess we
could just hit
execute search query
hmm maybe insert it in this one we'll go
ahead and execute it over here
there we go so now we have some records
so cool
all right we got that working and um so
yeah this is like that gremlin
language up here um i'm not that
familiar with it so you know what i'm
going to do i'm going to be right back
and uh
and learn it in two seconds okay all
right so i'm back and i learned a little
bit here and what i did was i went to
the
apache gremlin website for tinker pop or
gremlin in particular so g
dot v parenthesis is when we want to get
all records back
if we put in a particular id here it
should give us a particular result i
also figured out as we move around here
if you scroll into things like this and
you click on there
it will expand the next area it should
there it goes it's a bit slow
right but you know we have an id here so
let's give it a go and see if it
actually works so we'll do
g v and let's see if we put that in
there like this
we'll give it uh maybe quotations they
just have the number one so i'm not sure
to tell you there
and yeah so it grabbed that particular
point there um
it looks like we can grab different
values so i'm assuming that these are
values on it here so maybe we'll just do
dot values here
values uh well if we give a label here
there we go service plan so yeah it's
not that hard
go back here execute the plan and then
there's like commands like out
e i assume that's the way like you would
select things in the region so
um i don't know if like that is a
definitive one but we'll just go ahead
and
put that in there and see what happens
and we got nothing
because you know we have relationships
between other sources
like edges and so maybe it's based on
the
label here so let's try this
execute the plan
yeah i'm not sure what it is but my
point is is that we populated ourselves
a graph you can tell that that's how you
use the language if you really want to
learn more you can go through the
tutorial
uh on how to create that information but
for our purposes we just wanted to show
that we could populate a graph and play
around with one there a bit okay
so that is gremlin we did [ __ ]
we did azure so that's all of them so
we're all done here again i'm going to
keep these around just in case i want to
pull them into other services
and at the end we will destroy all these
resources okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from example
we're going to learn how to use data
factories to run a transformation job
maybe between
our sql and our blob storage because we
do still have the setup from previous
tutorials
so i'll make my way over to factories
you just type in data factory at the top
here
and you can see i have one there it's
right now deleting because i'm not happy
with it
but what we'll do is create ourselves a
new one so i'm going to make a new group
here
dp900 data factory 2
okay and here i'll have to name it so
we'll say dp900
data factory
we'll go with version two it doesn't
like it so i'm gonna put a two on the
end there
and we'll go to next i do not want to
use git at all that was the reason i uh
i restarted this was because it was
complaining about that
for networking it's going to have a
public endpoint for we have the ability
to encrypt our data which we do not care
today i'll go ahead and hit review and
create
we'll go ahead and create our data
factory and we'll give it a moment here
it doesn't take too long to set up a
data factory so
there it is so we'll go ahead and go to
resource and the way we're going to
actually access it
i don't know why they have the button
here but this is where it is it's author
and monitor
it's going to open up takes about a
second and here we are
so what we'll do is we want to create
ourselves a new pipeline we'll make it
easier on ourselves go to the left hand
side
hit the plus create a pipeline and we'll
say
sql to um sql to what
it's a bit glitchy there sql to blob
okay and we'll go ahead and
save that um i think it uh
does it auto save yeah it auto saves so
what we'll do is go to the left hand
side here go to link services
click the plus we need sql we have an
sql database so we'll go here
we'll say continue we'll have a
connection string
we'll select our subscription our server
name
our database name our type is sql
authentication
azure user capital
t testing one two three okay you can
have always encrypted on there i'll go
ahead and create that you can hit test
connection if you're concerned that it's
not working i think we can click into it
hit text test connection there to get a
nice little green so that's all good
we want to put this in our blob storage
so i will
add another one here we'll type in blob
we will create that hit continue
i don't care about the name but what
we'll do is use a connection string to
select it as well
so we'll go down here subscription one
it's
my storage account and we will test the
connection
and it's all good we'll hit create
cool so we'll now go back to our
pipeline or our authoring here we need a
data set
um can we get that from sql
we sure can we'll click on that we'll
hit continue
we'll select our linked service which is
here
we'll select the table we want so let's
say we want to translate over the
products
and we will go hit okay
all right and so now we have our data
set
okay and so we'll move on to the next
step all right so let's go set up a
transformation
so what we'll do is drag out copy data
and we will choose our source and we'll
say
our sql table and we're going to want to
put that into a csv
oops i did not create our data set here
so we'll create a new data set go
over to blob storage here hit continue
choose csv format so you can do excel
json all fun things
we'll choose our link service which is
blob storage
this has to be the name of our blob
storage i already forgot what it's
called so we'll go up here
make our way over to storage accounts
on the left hand side go into storage
accounts we need to find that container
name
there it is go all the way back put that
in there
call that transform and we'll say
products dot
csv first row is header
sure but we don't have any import scheme
there's because like you could have
one in there and say okay this is what
the schema should be like have the
headings in there
so it knows what it needs to translate
over to but uh
it's going to be a one-to-one mapping so
it's going to be something really simple
here
uh so this seems all fine to me notice
we don't have any schema we could
import one but there's nothing to import
so go back to our copy data we'll choose
delimited file
and we'll take a look at mappings we'll
import schemas
it's going to import the schema from the
table here are the column names here
so as you can see there are no column
names which is totally fine
and uh what we can do is go ahead
and let's go hit uh debug
okay and so it's queued up and
now what we'll do is go ahead and
validate
okay
and it says it's been validated no
issues as of yet
we'll go hit publish
um yep go ahead and publish it
and so now it has actually ran the
pipeline so what i want you to do is go
over to your storage accounts
give it a refresh go into my blog
storage
now we have a folder called transform we
have a product called uh
csv called products we'll go ahead and
download that
okay we can go ahead and open that up in
excel
and there you go so we just did a
transformation it's not the most
beautiful transformation but you can see
that it's a very powerful tool
we didn't have to write any any code
whatsoever which is really nice
so there you go
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
in this follow along we're going to take
a look at a data bricks
and sparks so what i want you to do is
go to the top and type in azure data
bricks
we'll go ahead and hit add we'll create
an azure databrick service
and what we'll do is hit create dp900
azure databricks okay
within our workspace here what we'll do
is choose
dp900 azure databricks very uncreative
of me but
it works out fine
and we have some options standard
premium trial i'm going to stick with
standard i do not want this to cost much
whatsoever
go ahead and create that environment
there
and i'll see you back here in a moment
when it's deployed
all right so um our databricks
environment is ready so if you click
launch workspace it does take a little
bit time to launch so i'm not pressing
it but
we'll have our environment here and so
uh you know there's stuff you can do
here like uh create clusters and run
jobs and notebooks
but just so you don't spend any money
i'm going to show you another way you
can run this service which is totally
uh totally won't cost you anything so
we'll go to databricks and type in
community edition
if we go down below here i already have
a log if you sign up
here it's exact same thing
pretty much but there's no chance of you
having unexpected spend so i prefer to
do it this way
even the cluster is shut off over a
certain amount of time and so we'll
click on the explore
quick start tutorial here and i think
it's shift
enter if you want to know the commands
it's in the top right corner this little
keyboard thing it tells you what you can
press so run command and move to next
cell that sounds like what we want to do
so i'm going to hit
shift enter shift so it says in the
sidebar
create a cluster etc but if we just keep
on going here
it should automatically create this one
so automatically launch one without
to clusters without prompting so we'll
just hit attach and run
okay and that's going to start up a
cluster
but as it's running we can just kind of
take a look here and so you can see that
we're running sql commands
um and so it looks like we're it has
we're loading a csv
and then we're trying the csv with sql
which is really nice so that's the thing
where it's like you have data
that's not necessarily in a database but
you're able to run
sql commands on csv files and things
like that
and then down below you can see uh it's
using python to use spark to load and
format the file
um and uh and you can even visualize
information in here so it automatically
let us plot it and change some of the
options here so go here make a histogram
quantile map that's useless
area bars so it's very very useful tool
but wait till that cluster spins up here
it takes a little bit of time if you
want to monitor a cluster we can go on
the left hand side
and just go to clusters here
okay and you can leave this and and and
totally not be worried about it you
don't have to worry about it like
spinning
up and costing you money okay so i'd go
here and give it a refresh
and i don't see the cluster
so i think it's just because i was
terminating an old one and now it's it's
waiting till i can turn
start up a new one so
it might not spin up but it's not really
that oh there we go
it's uh terminating great
uh is it going now
you can never tell these things
is the free edition so but if i just go
back here we can even look at the
commands here cyborg create cluster
quick start and database runtime drop
down to l3
create a cluster um so is it going to
create cluster now
nope will it cancel there yes
and let's just follow it manually so i
go to clusters create the cluster
here it's saying l3 lts
it kind of gives you an idea how old
their tutorial is
lts but that's what it wants we should
match it exactly
sparking scala i doubt that it's for
that one there and so
we will just name our cluster quickstart
oops right after the name of what it
asked for
oops
and we'll go ahead and create
and we'll i guess wait until that starts
up
it could take about a few minutes to
start up so what i'll do is i'll see you
back in a moment when it started okay
all right so we had to wait there a
little bit but uh now it looks like our
cluster is running so what i want you to
do is go back to that notebook we had
and this time it should possibly and
we'll close the other one because that
is our
the one we don't want to use but we'll
do shift enter shift enter
shift enter um it's not would you like
to launch a new cluster
no i want to use the existing one maybe
i can drop down and choose the cluster
oh here we go
um and so hold on here
quick start confirm there we go okay
and we'll see if that executes the
command
now it's a bit slow but again this is a
community edition and also
imagine if you're dealing with massive
amounts of data so it's not really
surprised that it's not like
super fast but like you have to think of
it at scale right
and so complete the job so that was
pretty good we can go ahead and run this
line again for fun
okay so you get the idea here right
so that's all i really wanted to show
you here um just kind of a bit of
exposure to a data bricks there
but you'd have to learn all about apache
spark to really understand
the stuff behind it um but yeah so what
we'll do
and again you don't have to shut it off
it doesn't matter but what we'll do is
just terminate
and be be good about that also we'll
delete this
at the end all these follow alongs for
the dp900 we'll definitely be sure to
delete all of them but just for this one
in particular i just want to get rid of
it
so i don't forget about it um yeah there
you go that is databricks hey this is
andrew brown from exam pro we're going
to be looking at azure snaps analytics
today in this follow along so what we'll
do
is go to the type here and type in
synapse
make our way over to analytics we'll go
ahead and add ourselves a new
workspace and i'll create a new one here
this is the dp900 so we'll say dp900
um synapse workspace
okay and we need to give it a managed
resource group uh so
i guess same thing dp900
synapse workspace
i'm just going to keep on naming it the
same as long as i can have it
for our subscription we'll have to
create a new account because we do not
have
a gen 2 storage account i wonder if i
could just make it in my other one nope
so we'll have to just because i already
have a storage account sitting right
right on there so we'll say
data lake storage okay it probably wants
it all lowercase data lake storage
dp900 okay
and we don't have a file system so
dp900 data lake file system
okay and notice here it says assign
myself storage blob data contributor
role for the data lake storage too
if you remember from our lecture content
about
very important roles this is one of them
and it's being auto assigned to us
go here to security here it has this but
i'm going to just say azure user
and capital t testing one two three
capital t testing one two three just so
i can remember it between our other ones
enable double encryption that sounds
good but not something we're doing today
um we'll go to network this seems okay
to me next
review and create
and just notice up here it says azure
synapse workspace
is 6.40 so it's not something we want to
have lying around um this is per
terabyte right but we're not going to be
working with a lot of data here so it
shouldn't be a big deal for us
we'll go ahead and create that
and uh yeah i'll see you back when this
is all done okay
all right so after waiting a little bit
of time there our synapse analytics
environment is ready what i want to show
you on the left-hand side is if you
scroll on we'll actually got to go to
the workspace first
scrolling down you have your analytics
pool so you have sql pools where you can
run
sql operations so you can go there and
create those clusters these get pretty
darn expensive
so um it's not even showing the
estimation there but
the thing is is that you know if you
needed sql you could do that because
remember there's two
engines that you can use you can use the
sql engine or the apache spark
engine right so you create those pools
uh sql pools first
you can also create them within um the
workspace
but we'll go up to overview the
workspace is the studio so we're going
to open that up
and once we get in here we can
ingest data and do all sorts of things
so it makes
it very easy but let's actually just go
back
you can't exit out of that once you open
that up so i'll go and reopen this up
because they do have some test data we
can use
which is uh should not cost us much but
if we go all the way over to learn here
and we go to sample sample data we have
some options here if you choose this one
it will create a pool but what i'm going
to do is go to query with data with sql
and it will give us some sample data so
we click on this
and what you can see here and this is
just me trying to run it before
but what you'll see here is
we could use uh the synapse sql
right and we're actually able to import
files so here it's importing a parkette
file from
a azure open like it's a storage account
by
azure and it's just an open data set so
here you can just kind of see that
there's ways of querying it
and uh what we would do is choose where
we want to do it so we go built in
we can publish that before we do that
there and we'll go ahead and hit run and
so
you know it's going to pull that data
it's going to take a little bit time to
get it loaded in and before it runs it
but it doesn't usually take too long and
there is the data so
yeah that gives you kind of an idea how
azure synapse uh works
um but yeah so if it wasn't sql here you
just write your apache spark
usual stuff there uh yeah and hopefully
that gives you a good idea how that
works i don't like to keep the service
running it is
can get very expensive very quickly so
me being paranoid i'm going to make sure
i terminate this one
definitely early even right now
but yeah that is azure synapse analytics
okay
[Music]
all right so we are at the end of our
follow alongs and you could tell that
they all kind of tied in with
one another so what we'll do is we do
some cleanup so
from the left hand side go to resource
groups and and it's dp900 you can go
ahead and delete so
what i'm going to do is just click on
each one here it could be from other
ones but i'll go ahead and just type in
like cosmodb
again it's based on what you named them
but this is the fastest way i find to
clean up all my stuff
and i'll go here and just keep on going
down the list
you know because mostly the things we
used they're not going to have ongoing
cost
the one that will will definitely be
like the sql server so that's something
that we
definitely need to terminate okay
some of these might give us some trouble
so again i'm just running down the list
here deleting as much as i can and then
i'm going to see if there's any errors
here but
i think we already deleted this one but
we'll give it another go here
and yeah that should be all of them here
if you get a failure you might have to
investigate it so here it says failed to
resource the client uh does not have
permission
yeah i do however that's tonight against
the
deny assignment so the idea is just you
know wait for this to finish
uh it could take a little bit of time
and sometimes like it's deleted but it
just takes time for this to
vanish and another thing you can do is
go to your resources and just make sure
the resources aren't running anymore so
i'm looking here
and what's going to cost me money is
this sql database that's running so
you know i want to make sure that stuff
is deleted
so say yes you could also do it from
here as well you should let the resource
groups delete it because sometimes it
gets confused
but uh you know i just want it all gone
i've got an ip
here data factory storage account
all these things i want them gone
just say yes uh you know it doesn't show
up here is disks
i know i have a bunch of disks let's go
over here
no there's nothing okay good i thought i
might have had like a bunch of disks you
know why because i was looking at my
explorer
and probably just showing the old one so
yeah it takes a while for this to
to happen but um you know i'll come back
here and show you that i've deleted them
all and that's what you should do too
okay so i'll see you back here in one
more wrap-up video
and that's it all right so after waiting
uh quite a little while here i just
wanted to see if it was all cleaned up
so i'm gonna give it a nice refresh here
looks like my resource groups are
cleaned up if i make my way over to my
resources here
it doesn't look like there's much uh
here remaining so
and just check our notifications make
sure everything is deleted so
that's how we make sure that everything
is cleaned up in our azure account and
that's it for
our follow alongs okay